like
section
s
all right
uh good morning uh it's now actually 903
so we're a little late uh welcome this
is the uh house Judiciary Committee uh
and we're about to begin uh first I
would like to ask representative Andrus
if she would lead us in Pledge of
Allegiance
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you representative Andrews
all right so um the first bill
um that we have up for hearing is House
Bill uh 3 20 and I will recognize the
thank you very much Mr chairman it's a
pleasure to be before Judiciary it's a
rare occurrence but uh always a
privilege
um so I will say next to nothing about
the bill uh because I uh I'm pleased to
sponsor it on behalf of my former
colleague and good friend representative
The Honorable Neil Kirk
who has suggested it to me and he is
very knowledgeable on this subject so I
will
stand in his shadow and take no
questions but I am pleased to support
the Bill thank you very much all right
but do we have the list of the the pink
cards
no no that's all right
thank you so much
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee
uh for the record my name is Neil Kirk I
live in Ware I'm a former state
representative uh
but voluntarily retired
uh Mr chairman with your permission I'd
like to distribute some material to
committee members yes certainly
well if you're just split it up maybe on
give them a half around each side we'll
uh
foreign
members of the committee this house bill
320 is an important bill
it deals with free speech in the United
States and
in the state of New Hampshire
as we all know from recent news articles
there are
allegations and in some cases most folks
have concluded
demonstrated situations in which social
media companies have censored various
messages that individuals are trying to
communicate on these
and for example on vaccines
and there's also evidence that the
federal government itself
including organizations such as the FBI
involve themselves in
um influencing the content that say
Twitter
were allowed or by themselves censored
to put forward
we've all read about the hunter Biden
this is not a partisan issue it's true
at the moment it seems the Republicans
are accusing the Democrats of doing
these things
but you and I both know
that what sauce for the goose is sauce
for the gander
and so when the Republicans are in
control as they are of the house in
Congress now they will start using or
thinking about using these same kinds of
tactics to achieve their political ends
and
it's an for me and I hope for you
unacceptable
that the private sector or the
government
would choose to use their mediums of
communication available to all and
censor them
that to me is the bit is it attacks the
basis of a democracy if we cannot have
free communication between us as
individuals through Twitter or Facebook
or whatever medium we're using including
the newspapers but they're not part of
this
then we all suffer because
the basis of a democracy is debate and
conclusion and there can be no debate
there can be no discussion if someone
has his fingers on the scale
that's the situation now
where government is attempting to censor
and
these mediums of communication are
themselves attempting to censor the kind
of communication that goes on between
individuals
um
foreign
who gets hurt from this
the people of New Hampshire get hurt
because we can't have the kind of debate
we need to make reasonable decisions
Congress as you know is not acting
Congress is doing nothing about this
they're talking they're investigating
but they're doing nothing to solve this
on a national basis
and so
what can we do in New Hampshire if
anything
the answer is house bill 320.
let me explain a little bit is how as to
how this came about a number of months
ago in October I was reading the Wall
Street Journal and there was an article
in there by a Columbia law professor
Philip hamburger
that raised this issue and proposed a
solution something I had never thought
about
and that is he suggested that if these
organizations Twitter Facebook and so
forth were considered common carriers
you know like railroads or common
carriers and utilities are common
carriers
um they could be regulated in a way
that was compatible with democracy and
not overly invasive
but would guarantee that
Viewpoint discrimination did not exist
Viewpoint is where somebody says
I'm pro-vaccine and somebody says I'm
anti-vaccine
if you discriminate and say no the
pro-vaccine people cannot or the
anti-vaccine people cannot have a voice
on this platform we're going to censor
their Communications that's Viewpoint
discrimination
so
inspired by this by the editor by the
op-ed I wrote to Professor hamburger and
said do you have any legislative
solution for this and he said yes I do
state by state
regulation of these organizations as
common carriers if the federal
government won't act New Hampshire can
act Vermont can act Maine can act
and that's what this bill is
he sent me a
I guess you'd call it a piece of model
legislation
it was overly complex and legal so I
tried to pare it down to something at
least I could understand and hopefully
all of us can understand
and that's what you have before you
please understand that Viewpoint
discrimination is banned by this bill
but not content discrimination
the platform can say we're not going to
entertain any religious
or any political you name it
material on our website
but if they allow religious or political
or whatever on their website then they
cannot discriminate
as between those people who take one
position on a religious issue and those
people who take another position that's
what this bill does
it is constitutional there are no free
speech violations because of course the
entities Facebook or whatever it is can
voice whatever opinions they want
themselves
as long as they don't do it in a way
that in effect
um bans those people with a different
point of view from having their
perspective heard on Facebook or
whatever the the platform is
as you know there's a long history of of
uh common carrier regulation in the
United States starting with I think the
railroads I remember when I was in high
school or maybe it was College we were
discussing this and it seemed that the
railroads had this great idea that where
there were two competing lines they
would charge the farmers who wanted to
get their goods to Market One price
that was lower than what they would
charge the farmer who was only served by
a single railroad line so they were
discriminating based on location
the farmers obviously a vast majority of
people in the 1880s were upset by this
in Congress uh past legislation that in
effect prohibited this kind of activity
this discrimination based on location
for railroads
as I said there's no First Amendment
issue here
um we are this legislation has no impact
on the ability of the common carrier in
this case let's say Facebook from
advocating its own positions on its own
network
so
to whom does this apply it applies to
social media companies such as Twitter
and Facebook that have at least 50
million users in any calendar month so
this only applies to very large
platforms where people are using many
people are using them
it allows the companies to regulate the
content
whatever they want to cut to carry they
want videos or no videos whatever they
want that's up to them
it forbids discrimination
on a viewpoint on any topic
and
as I said the company can voice its own
opinions
it this bill also allows the companies
to ban unlawful content
for example
pornography
doxing violence support for terrorism
those can be banned they can
discriminate on the basis of content if
finally there is no conflict with
Federal section 230 which provides
protection for these social media
platforms against content discrimination
they cannot be sued if they for the
content that's put up on their websites
let's say it's vaccines or whatever it
might be they cannot be sued for
anything that anybody says about that
but section 230 has nothing to do with
Viewpoint discrimination and that's
where the state of New Hampshire can
regulate
so
I would ask the committee to pass this
bill to protect the ability of everyone
in New Hampshire to express his or her
opinion on social media and not be
subject to censorship
and
to prevent the government
from influencing our ability to hear
other views
or to voice our own
as I said this is very important
legislation that promotes free speech
and I hope the committee will vote it
out as ought to pass with whatever
amendments are necessary to clarify
things thank you Mr chairman I'd be
willing to answer any questions if there
are any questions from members of the
committee yes representative Wallace
thank you for taking my question have
any other states uh enacted this
legislation no as usual New Hampshire is
going to be first thank you
other questions yes representative yeah
thank you Mr chair and thank you sir for
uh bringing this bill uh a couple of
questions you said that this would only
apply to social media platforms of 50
million users in a calendar month
correct what is to prevent them because
that seems like an arbitrary number
although I'm sure they well exceed that
but we know that Twitter for example and
other social media have used Bots to
inflate what the appears to be the
number of users when they are in fact
phony accounts so what is to prevent
them from suppressing the user numbers
in order to be able to fly under the
radar of this and avoid any
accountability to this
um I suppose the direct answer is
nothing but from a from a company point
of view that would be very undesirable
in terms of advertising and other
Revenue I doubt very much if the company
would care so much about this that they
would be willing to sacrifice millions
or tens of millions of dollars in
Revenue to avoid this kind of Regulation
follow-up sir yes thank you and secondly
uh
you said that this would not prevent
them from censoring such as uh child
pornography and terrorism and stuff like
that and while that sounds good and we
want we certainly would want that the
problem comes into who defines what is
Terrorism when a parent standing up at a
school board meeting is now called a
domestic terrorist
Point well taken sir my understanding is
the law with respect to support for
terrorism is a federal law
and I'm not an expert on that and it may
be that that federal law is flawed but
to the extent it's flawed we all suffer
from that generally and in this
legislation this legislation does not
try to correct that issue to the extent
other questions for this witness yes
I'm sorry
good morning I wanted to ask you a
paragraph Roman numeral three says some
interactive computer services
and then it goes on and is the
definition of some related to the size
is that how you're defining some yes
representative Horgan do you have a
question
um well yes uh
you talking about uh we're asking for
about support for terrorism but we're
versus these Services draw the line when
it's you know not just a parent at a
school board meeting but you know a
National Republic official or another
individual actually has
um you know power to encourage others to
break the lawn is using the platform to
do so so like would that be appropriate
would that be appropriate to uh would it
still be appropriate for them to you
know block such an individual
if they believe they're engaging in
illegal activity and
I'm not not naming any individual in
particular because the one I'm thinking
of is someone we're not supposed to talk
about but anyway yes so this would not
prevent him from uh this would not
prevent him from blocking the use of
their platform to encourage you know
illegal activity though no I don't
believe it would
I don't think this bill in any way
changes or deals with that problem and
it is a problem
but I don't think this bill deals with
it if the problem exists it continues to
exist with this bill and it will
continue to exist if this bill is not
passed this bill does not address that
issue and It suffers as does all
legislation from that the fact that that
thank you Mr chairman and Mr chairman uh
America
and looking at this bill
um
I come I understand that we would be
breaking new grounds and we usually have
no problem with that I'm just curious
mechanism are we expecting that to fall
completely on the courts when a user
brings a complaint or is there another
way that the user could demonstrate a
complaint and then what happens
uh the provision of this bill is
enforced by the provisions of this bill
are enforced by the individual who
suffered an injury as a result of this
and yes you're right the individual
under this bill would go to court and
sue the social media platform for the
violation
um
as you can see from the fiscal note
there is an
indeterminate amount of a number of
additional court cases as a result of
this
um
therefore the fiscal notes does not
specify a particular number but yes
there would be an additional burden on
representative Andrus did you have a
question
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question why is this
bill limited to
uses of 50 million a month or more why
not smaller
uses included
that's a good question when I originally
uh drafted a version of this I dropped
the 50 million down to 1 million
and as you'll see from
Professor hamburger's letter which each
of you has a copy of as well as the
original opinion piece that I mentioned
it has to do with the nature of what a
common carrier is
there are three points that he makes
about common carriers and one of them
has to do with size and the number of
people
that are affected by
the activity and when I suggested a
million he immediately said that number
is too low that would give opponents a
really good case to say that this isn't
that these platforms are not common
carriers they don't affect enough people
and so it was his number that I restored
in the New Hampshire version because I
want to make sure that
these activities these social media
platforms are in fact considered common
carriers
and they have to serve a large number of
other question yes uh representative
Turner
uh yeah thank thanks for uh answering uh
questions
um I guess my concern really is around
the concept of common carrier at a state
level
um I don't know and maybe this is a
multi-part question is it are there
other examples of common carriers that
are established at the state level and
sort of within New Hampshire
do we have any statutes that discuss
what a common carrier is and my
understanding is most of them at the
federal level are assigned under an
oversight
um board or something that they're
responsible to so could you say a little
bit more about what a common carrier at
the state level is and how it would how
it would operate
um
I think I'm On Solid Ground on this but
I would stand corrected
if if I'm not
I believe our Public Utility Commission
regulates common carriers that is to say
telephone companies water companies and
other utilities which
um
basically um
serve a large number of people have some
sort of Monopoly type power or
significant Market influence and that
the state of New Hampshire has
determined by Statute that these
companies are common carriers and need
to be regulated now in the case of these
kinds of utilities there's a very
stringent regulatory framework with a um
regulatory agency in the case of this
bill the idea is to tread very lightly
and not regulate them except for one
thing Viewpoint discrimination
just a quick follow-up so so are you
suggesting that this would fall under
the puc no no not at all it would unless
you change the bill to say that this
these organizations would be regulated
I'm not suggesting that I don't think
it's necessary I think the enforcement
regulation the enforcement mechanism of
an individual is adversely affected is
the right way to go we don't need a
bureaucracy to take care of this
relatively small but very significant
issue
other questions for this witness uh yes
representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh
the issue I have with this is uh you're
treating
social media
as a product rather than a service
and uh
you know
these the people that
use the
social media are just that they're not
customers they're they're users so uh
uh it being a free service how can they
that's a very basic question and a very
important question
um
first as I understand it the while it
may be a free service you have to
register you have to sign up for
and once you do that
um
there's no product involved except what
you create the message or the pictures
or whatever it is it's a service
and
the service is
allows you to communicate
this bill simply says that communication
has to be yours yours only and cannot be
censored
I don't know if that's responsive but
maybe you could clarify that's a good
answer I'll accept it thank you
we have other questions
yes representative Oregon oh thank you
um I mean I could defer to any of the
members who have already asked one um so
these Facebook services like Facebook
and Twitter they're uh for profit
companies their business model is
basically that they mix in well
primarily is that they
mix in some some ads in with the feed of
messages from other people and the way
they uh and they also like want to want
you to log on as often as possible and
spend as much time reading it so that
means first of all they have to have a
obviously the advertisers don't
necessarily want to be associated with
you know extraordinarily objectionable
content but more to the point the
if you're a user you might like to see
some things you disagree with but you
know nobody wants to see anything that's
repellent you don't want to see too much
of repellent you know like I don't want
to log on to Facebook and Twitter and
see only like a million posts by Nazis
for example so how do how do you balance
out the business model with the
interests of uh interests of free speech
and of course also freedom of the press
this also includes the authority not to
use your press to print things you don't
want to print some of the so is there
like a decision so does you think this
um infringes on does you think this
still respects their business models so
they can make a profit while also uh
maybe engaging in different practices
than they have been
thank you for the question
representative Oregon this does not
affect their business model
um
all they need to do is continue business
as usual and just make sure that they
don't uh
prevent your particular message from
being heard and my particular message
from being heard they continue to
advertise and put these ads in as you've
suggested this has no impact on that
whatsoever
first where we live in the state of New
Hampshire but these other platforms
are probably out of other states I know
Facebook for example I believe is out of
California and so
I guess two-part question how can this
be enforced and then secondly
is there any bit of apprehension that
perhaps these companies will just say as
part of their signing up that hey if
you're from the state of New Hampshire
you're ineligible because we'd be the
only state to be implementing something
like this so perhaps they just wouldn't
want to
deal with it
I can see the headlines thank you for
the question I can see the headlines
Twitter bans New Hampshire
if if you're trying to make money and
you have a business model that's not the
headline you want to see so while I
appreciate the fact that they could do
that
um I doubt very much that they would
among other things as soon as that
happens should it happen other states
would immediately say oh boy we've got
to join New Hampshire this is absolutely
unacceptable and that in fact if they
did something like that Congress might
even act
um so I'm not concerned I don't think I
don't think that's an issue I'm sorry I
forgot the rest of your question
how it could be enforced you know only
for the State of New Hampshire where
these companies are doing their business
out of other companies and it's not a
platform that we're paying for so how
could how could it be enforced where
they're in another state than us
um when there were customers in New
Hampshire and there are for all of these
platforms
um
the companies are in effect doing
business in New Hampshire they have
customers here they may not have a
physical presence here as you point out
their servers may be elsewhere and our
courts will take jurisdiction of that
to protect New Hampshire customers from
this kind of activity illegal
discrimination should the bill pass
yes sure
I understand that for the business
people the people that are actually
paying for for the people that are using
it as a free platform are they
technically a customer even though
they're not paying anything
I don't know if the right word is
customer but there's certainly a user
and they have a physical presence in New
Hampshire and some sort of a legal
relationship with the company because
normally when you signed up you have to
agree for this this huge list of things
that nobody reads but we all say yes we
other questions yes representative Perez
thank you for taking my question
um
and if you don't know what that is they
block you for 30 days so that's a
wonderful term I I hadn't heard it
before but I like it um I borrowed that
from someone else so it's not original
um this has been going on for a long
long time since the beginning of this I
just wondered if there was something
in particular that prompted
this bill for now
the thing that prompted me for now is
the article that appeared in the uh Wall
Street Journal that's the immediate
impetus but for me personally over the
years I've I've read about all of these
kinds of activities censoring activities
that the companies are doing or
allegations and I'm saying to myself
this is not right we need to have a
robust debate about these issues
and so I sat and stewed then I saw this
opinion piece with a possible solution I
jumped on it and I'm bringing it forward
to the legislature I think there's a
real problem I think this is a viable
solution and I think this is so in New
Hampshire tradition that I would I would
hope the legislature would take it up
and pass it
yes thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
my question couldn't the harvesting of
personal information by the social media
platforms be considered a payment as the
yes
thank you
other questions uh representative tur
ret
yeah I just want to ask about this
section and and perhaps I'm not
understanding at the 359 u3 where it
says waiver prohibited and it basically
sounds like even if you wave your rights
through I agree kind of Click because
that's how I'm not interpreting it
um I wasn't sure what that
does in terms of of
um giving up sort of the contractual
relationship between an organization and
a user and and sort of down below and I
don't know if this section just
applies to the waiver or applies to the
entire law where it says this chapter
applies to a user Who currently resides
in the state does business in the state
or shares or receives
expression in the state the way the way
I would read that would be essentially
everyone in the United States or maybe
Beyond you know could fall into one of
those three categories and so if it
applied to
um those if it applied broadly and not
just the waiver
um would it would it be the case that
someone from California because they
sent me a Facebook message once would
would be someone who expressed in the
state and we could essentially become
the grounds for everyone who has a
grievance against Facebook
very good questions thank you for them
the waiver is the language is put in for
a very simple reason
as I said before the terms of service
are something nobody reads and everybody
has to sign and we don't read it because
we don't have the time to read it and if
we read it we couldn't understand it
anyway I've tried to read those I'm
reasonably literate I find it extremely
one of the ways that companies would
circumvent this law is to put a
condition in the terms of of service
that says the user waives his right to
bring lost a lawsuit under house bill
320.
obviously that would be very easy for
them to do and would totally uh
undermine this legislation and so
there's a provision that says you can't
and it's
a pretty obvious response that a company
might have and therefore a pretty
obvious response that the legislature
ought to have
um
lawsuit is concerned I think you have to
have some Nexus some connection with New
Hampshire to bring a suit in our courts
I don't see the California person having
that right but I do see the New
Hampshire person having that right
somebody who is either physically here
or is is expressing his views in this
state you could make the argument that
the California person is expressing his
views in this state
um
and
if that's a concern
it can be addressed in an amendment
Free Speech was protected as widely as
possible hence that language
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much Mr Kirk great
representative Kirk appreciate your
being here thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee you
know I know we have a number of other
people that wants to testify in this and
I'm concerned that we have a very full
uh docket today so I'm going to ask if
you would please as you come to testify
to do your very best to limit your
testimony to three minutes uh I'm not
going to cut somebody off in the middle
of an answer or something like that but
just be sensitive to the issue of time
so next I'm going to call on
uh Chris Marchesi
um uh Mr Martin if you come up please
yes and I would say if you uh if if
you've got printed testimony whoever
anybody that may have printed attached
to money obviously we're happy to accept
that um I want to again suggest that
um we all have the ability to read and
we will read it so you don't need to uh
um you don't need to uh go into detail
about what you've said in your written
testimony thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee my
name is Chris Marchese and I'm here
today on behalf of netchoice a trade
Association based in Washington DC our
members include The Usual Suspects like
Google meta
Etc as well as some of the uh platforms
that we use every day but don't
necessarily think of as social media
like Pinterest eBay
um and Etsy so I'm here today to testify
against Bill 320 and the reason why is
because it is unconstitutional in fact
the state of Texas tried this exact same
bill and it is currently on appeal to
the U.S Supreme Court in fact tomorrow
the court is expected to rule in our
cert petition both the state of Texas
and US as the plaintiffs have agreed
that the Supreme Court needs to weigh in
sooner than later and clarify some of
these legal issues and my testimony the
written testimony goes into detail about
why this is an unconstitutional bill but
here I'm just going to focus on the
highest level concern which is that if
you want to protect the First Amendment
you do so by preventing violations of
the First Amendment not by actually
violating it yourself and that is
exactly what this bill would do because
it forces private companies remember
they are private even if they are large
they are still private companies and the
idea of 4 forcing them to carry somebody
else's speech it should be Insidious to
all of us the First Amendment doesn't
just protect the right to speak it also
protects the right to remain silent and
it certainly protects the right not to
have to carry somebody else's message
even in the marketplace of ideas we
can't have the government coming in and
saying you know what we think that all
viewpoints should be heard or else no
viewpoints will be heard and that is
exactly what we heard from the sponsors
of this bill you can ban content
categories but you can't ban viewpoints
that's going to leave us with an
internet with basically no content
because at the end of the day there is a
vile viewpoint on just about every
everything imaginable somewhere in this
country there is someone with a very
nasty view that wants to share it on the
internet and to be honest with you as
our lawsuits have discovered there is
very scary vile content on the internet
it is
astounding what people can come up with
and yet this bill would say if you want
to talk about the Holocaust then you
also have to allow Holocaust denial
if you want to have an educational
seminar about you know Hitler you must
also allow pro-hitler content
so this is a a very practical concern
it's either we're going to have no
content and therefore be safe from vile
content that parents don't want their
kids to see and quite frankly I don't
think anyone in this room wants to see
or we're going to allow all viewpoints
including the viewpoints from people who
perhaps are not actually on the internet
to engage in meaningful discussion
so that's point one the second point is
that this bill will have unintended
consequences even if somehow it were
rendered constitutional you know earlier
it was mentioned that data is very
important to tech companies that is true
but this bill would actually require the
collection of even more data think about
it in order to comply with this log tech
companies every single website covered
by it would need to know where content
is coming from is this user in the state
of New Hampshire or are they in
California are they in California trying
to reach people in New Hampshire
that is going to require even more data
collection and that would be sanctioned
under law it would be required by law
and then the third thing to say here is
you know net choice we are a
right-of-center trade Association and we
fully agree that it is inappropriate if
not outright unconstitutional for the
federal government to be weighing in on
content decisions
you know it is one thing for the federal
government to work with platforms to
remove child pornography and content
harmful to Children it is quite a
different thing for the federal
government to be weighing in on vaccine
information
or misinformation whatever you want to
call it that is inappropriate and that
is why we support a federal Bill
currently pending in Congress that is
due for a vote I think either next week
or the week after that would prohibit
every Federal bureaucrat from weighing
in on content decisions it is sponsored
by representative Jim Jordan Kevin Comer
and Kathy McMorris Rogers and that bill
would prohibit exactly what we heard
earlier about the Twitter files and you
know President Biden's disinformation
board
so it is simply not true that this bill
hasn't been tried it's been tried in
Texas and it is currently pending before
The Supreme Court it's a similar version
was also tried in Florida and the 11th
circuit unanimously Struck it down as
unconstitutional
so to support free speech that also
means that we need to
accept the fact that some private
businesses will do things with their
free speech that we don't like it
doesn't mean that we don't have recourse
it just means that our recourse is in
the court of public opinion rather than
in the courtroom
thank you Mr chairman questions for this
Witness
es
there are more coming around oh they're
more coming around bro I'm sorry no no
problem apologies I'm not very good
accounting right
do we you know do you um I wonder if
okay great thank you so all right we'll
get that all right uh other questions
for this Witness
right I just have one question
um the fifth circuit that you said the
case is up to the Supreme Court the
fifth circuit rule in your client's
favor or against you against us two to
one so so it's uh so the the status of
the of the law so to speak to the extent
it's been decided is you won one in the
11th circuit and you lost one in the
fifth and you're hoping the Supreme
Court is gonna go your way on the fifth
circuit case well Mr chairman out of
every federal court to review our cases
every single one has been in agreement
that these laws are unconstitutional
except for the fifth circuit and in that
instance it was a two to one decision so
two judges thought that the K that the
Texas law was constitutional although
one said perhaps it's too soon to tell
and we need more hearing or uh more
litigation about it and you know I think
given the weight of the Precedence given
what has already been said in the 11th
circuit we are confident that the
Supreme Court will agree with us and
it's also worth noting that when the
fifth circuit ruled against us we went
to the Supreme Court asking for an
emergency injunction and the court
granted us that injunction so that is
kind of a preview that at least a
majority of the Supreme Court thinks
that this law is unconstitutional
other questions for this yes
representative match
good morning do your members agree that
you are common carriers
no we are adamant that we are not common
carriers
representative Horrigan
um and
um I guess is it accurate what I said
earlier that the business model of uh
Facebook and Twitter and these other
things just basically provide people
with content which they actually want to
see which may include some content that
they don't agree with but people don't
want to see anything that's like totally
repugnant they don't want to see a feed
full of things that they totally hate
and don't want to look at are totally
repugnant to them and also advertisers
or probably want to be somewhat
selective about what sort of content is
appearing alongside their ads too is
that is that an accurate summary of your
uh of your business model of your
clients it absolutely is and just to
give one very brief example when hb20
was in effect in Texas and interestingly
enough there sounds even the same hb20
uh when it was in effect in Texas we had
the massacre in Buffalo occur and as you
may recall the murderer posted a vile
Manifesto on the internet explaining why
he did what he did and technically under
hb20 our members were not legally
allowed to remove that content
so even though it is a vile violent
disgusting Viewpoint it is
constitutionally protected speech and
the only reason why our members were
able to remove it is because we were
able to have the law enjoined meaning
not enforced but otherwise the manifesto
as well as the video of innocent
Americans being gunned down would have
been left up on the internet at least in
the state of Texas
other questions yeah
one one specific practice I'm curious
which like well Twitter in particular is
often being accused of Shadow banding
conservatives and I've noticed even with
things that I tweet that sometimes I
tweet him and only a few people see them
is that is anything Sinister going on or
is that because their algorithm thinks
that there aren't that many people who
want to listen to what I'm saying so
well I'm assuming the algorithm has it
wrong if you're not getting a lot of
I will say that I am not too uh familiar
with how Twitter does
uh content promotion and how it decides
in what order tweets will be shown but I
know that Elon Musk would not be able to
do what he's doing at Twitter today if
this were law and that's because Elon
Musk has been you know operating in real
time to experiment with new things at
Twitter it's actually kind of
interesting to see you know the CEO of a
social media company engaging with the
public in real time on hey what do you
guys want to see with this platform that
you're using and he goes back and forth
with users under this bill some of those
changes would not be allowed thank you
very much any other questions all right
thank you very much sir
thank you
um next we have uh Christopher
thank you chairman Lynn members of the
committee I am delighted to be here for
uh my first New Hampshire testimony of
the year
um I will be uh very brief as I know we
are running up on time I did uh submit
written testimony electronically
um I do not have uh copies for the for
the members here but uh I uh hope that
you will get it
um
so uh my name is Chris gilray and I
represent TechNet in the Northeast we
are a trade Association comprised of
over a hundred companies uh in the
Innovation space uh including uh
platforms that would be covered under
this legislation I'm here in opposition
to HB 320
um because it would completely undermine
content moderation practices that keep
your constituents safe online
uh social media companies review
millions and millions of pieces of data
daily to filter and remove content that
violates Community standards things that
are legal and constitutional uh but
represent things that we don't want to
see bullying harassment hate speech
scams spam and other objectionable
content
HP 320 would create a perverse incentive
for companies to stop removing
objectionable content in order to avoid
the risk of lawsuits created by this
legislation
the bill exclusively allows companies to
remove content that violates federal law
as we've heard there is a massive
Universe of things that we find
repugnant that are nonetheless legal
under federal law and would be required
to be hosted on these platforms
it would present uh a harmful online
experience and create real world dangers
for granite Staters uh as I read it the
bill would also circumvent parental
controls uh as the bill prohibits
content from being received by all users
puts New Hampshire in the position of
dictating to how a private Enterprise
can run its business and enforces it
with the blunt force of a private right
of action
uh it would create uh as uh
representative Smith identified a burden
on New Hampshire's courts uh if it were
not in fact enjoined uh by uh a previous
uh lawsuit but uh the courts would be
flooded with these kinds of lawsuits and
it does not serve to protect the free
exchange of ideas but instead would fill
these pages with so much filth as to
render the platform's functionally
useless I am here uh to uh in the real
physical Public Square uh to address my
elected officials and ask them not to
advance uh this legislation all right
thank you very much questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you Mr chair
uh next
um
Elaine uh I'm I know I'm gonna torture
this this this uh word uh this name
Elaine or young comms
um
um good morning chair and other members
of committee thank you for having me
here uh my name is um Alan Sean Combs
um I'm a director of state and local
government public policy for uh chamber
of progress which is another technology
trade Association
um we're a center left leaning Tech
um we represent like uh the other two
Chris's you know the Googles the
Facebooks of the world
um and I'm here to urge your command to
oppose this bill
um the other two Chris's have made a lot
of the points that I would like to make
and I want to be conscious of time so
keep things very short
um but I'd like to make uh two at least
two quick points
um first consumers and constituents uh I
don't think actually want this type of
Bill out there we've done a set of
polling my organization a national poll
and we found that 67 percent of Voters
said that social media companies and
online platforms should be able to block
violent and offensive content in fact a
majority of social media companies uh a
majority of Voters want social media
companies to actually do more content
moderation and this includes pluralities
of Democrats Republicans and
independents so across uh the entire
political Spectrum kind of uh the
majority of constituents and voters
think that there needs to be more
content moderation uh not less
um the second point I want to make is a
point that uh the other two Chris's have
already made in that this will result in
more
um obscene and unsavory content on the
internet and I think it will also make
Spam a major problem on the internet and
Thai companies for hands against toxic
and incendiary content third and finally
this law will almost certainly face and
perhaps lose a court challenge under the
First Amendment
um and no no one wants the internet to
become you know a cesspool of offensive
content and consumers have consistently
told us through the polling that we've
done that they want more content
moderation not less so we urge you to
listen to the concerns raised by voters
fellow lawmakers in the Constitution and
reject this Bill thank you very much
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you sir
thank you Mr chair and I will submit um
some written comments and documentation
so I'll make this um even briefer uh
this is not unconstitutional the fifth
circuit has also an essentially issue to
stay pending appeal
um the first amendment in free speech is
known as the marketplace of ideas this
is applied specificity specifically to
Common carriers having 50 million people
I did uh some recent research looked
like Facebook has 240 million people in
the U.S representing about 70 percent of
the population the Texas law similarly
had 50 million people in regards to the
common carrier question uh the Texas
Bill specifically to find common carrier
as a social media platform uh
with the largest number users or common
carriers by virtue of their market
dominance I would suggest that 70 is
effectively a market dominance
commercial speech is a type of speech
it's a type of speech that is giving one
of the lowest protections
um amongst various types of speeches on
the other tan political speech is given
typically the most protection of any
speech in regards to political speech
this is Viewpoint discrimination courts
have pretty much possibly unanimously or
if not near unanimally near unanimously
prohibited Viewpoint discrimination
every um there's been a lot of comments
talking about violent offensive speech
similar this bill specifically allows
Facebook and every social media
organization to still prohibit all that
content if you look at page three of the
bill
um chapter well it's uh lines 27 through
30.
um this specifically allows them to
block unlawful expression that harasses
people incites violence obscene Lew
lascivious filthiest excessively
violently and harassing and other
Behavior so things that people don't
want and that poll that they mentioned
would still be prohibited under this
bill I'll add that I have also been in
Facebook jail for numerous times uh
Facebook Shadow bans me
um and what that means is they
essentially limit my contacts to certain
people
um
essentially I don't think Facebook
should be the one fact checking things
Facebook is and others are blocking
opinions I believe
um
Zuckerberg at some point in front of the
Supreme Court in front of Congress or
someone told them essentially the fact
checks are an opinion by Facebook they
don't want them to be legally binding I
suggest that because of their market
dominance this is a limited bill it does
not violate the constitution and is a
good thing because Facebook should not
be the one deciding what is true speech
and what is not
thank you question for this Witness
so you know I guess I I just I in light
of one of your last thing I just have
one question I noted the the language
that you read on page three in section
2C says and I'm quoting any expression
including obscene lewd lascivious filthy
excessively violent harassing or
otherwise objectionable so if I'm Pfizer
and I think that people who have a view
that the difference in mind about the
efficacy of the vaccine can I say under
that section
um
this is objectionable and therefore
Facebook or Google or whatever take it
down
I guess the court would decide who on
that one um
I guess different language were proposed
um I guess I don't think
this is a difficult question I think it
judged my in Facebook at the end of the
day be the one deciding that
other questions for this week
thank you very much sir thank you
all right do we have any other Witnesses
all right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on HB 320. and I'm going to
open the hearing
on HB uh 171 give me just one second
and I will recognize uh representative
foreign
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate it
and good morning uh to everyone again
um to um through your honor to my
esteemed colleagues of the Judiciary
Committee my name is Bill Boyd I
represent uh Hillsborough District 12 in
the town of Merrimack and I am
presenting to you house bill 171 which
was presented to me by request by my
constituent Robert bevel who's sitting
right behind me
um the goal of 171 is to clarify
language in the existing statute 507 B
seeking to do one of seeking to do two
things one is it relates to New
Hampshire case ever versus General
Electric it's going to codify language
that was used in that decision you'll
see that in reflected on lines 9 through
11 of your bill and then it seeks to
redact language that was in the city of
Dover decision which you're going to see
on lines 16 through 20. the perp purpose
of these particular changes is to add
Clarity to to the St to the statute to
to better provide
um intent of what the of what the
statute is meaning to do uh as it
relates to its Authority
um
on Tuesday
um a stakeholders meeting occurred
trying to gain Clarity and consensus on
on the language in this in this bill
reluctantly
um neither of that occurred
um not for the want of trying the
process was certainly collegial so we're
here today with the bill as is for your
for your review I'll do my best to
answer any questions my my knowledge is
limited I would defer to my constituent
um but I'll leave it at that Mr chairman
thank you
questions for for this Witness
I guess I do have one uh questions
report it it does seem like at least
from the
elimination of the language that is
currently in 507 B2
that this would
uh and that that language generally
limits
um uh the circumstances in which
liability can be predicated against a
correct municipality to uh vehicle and
property this would eliminate that which
would it would seem to me at least
initially would sort of
pretty significantly expand the basis of
Municipal liability that would be
correct
and I take it you you have no concern
with doing that or you think that's a
good idea that I I don't have an opinion
oh I as I as I said at the onset I'm I'm
presenting the bill on behalf of my
constituent okay I was here to explain
more about about the reason why he chose
to add and redact as it relates to the
statute right thank you okay any other
questions for this witness thank you
very much representative your honor
um
and I'm sorry I in light of
uh Mr bevel you're you're the person
okay why don't you why don't you come up
next please we'll hear from you next
good morning your honors uh Judge Lynn
and chairman and the rest of the
committee thank you for hearing me again
got a haircut since yesterday if you
don't recognize me it's a lot a lot
lighter thank you so uh I'll start off
my name is Bob bevel I live at 12 Blair
Road Merrimack New Hampshire I'm coming
for myself but I also work with a
network of parents of special needs
children I'm not legal counsel for any
of them but they have addressed some
concerns let me answer your question
first judge in that um
yes that would open up the floodgates if
we move the the portion regarding
vehicles and premises but in my opinion
this particular spot in the statutes and
all the statute this is the improper
place for this because it's trying to
accomplish two things one is that the
statute is supposed to be
protecting you our legal our
Representatives when you make decisions
it is in what's called a discretionary
function you're making a decision on
whether the highway is built on the left
side of the property or on the right
side of the property
and in such you should be protected for
full immunity for making those decisions
because you're making decisions in the
interests of the people
however there are state and local
employees who do not make discretionary
decisions they are doing ministerial
tasks uh sweeping floors uh filing
papers that kind of stuff that do not
fall under what the intention of this
bill was a lot of this is because uh was
in response to a case back in the 70s
where that the court the Supreme Court
was looking at eliminating the state
created and the Judiciary created
position of Municipal liability or
Municipal immunity and there are so many
flavors out there I won't get into that
I can more answer your questions but the
purpose of Merrell versus Manchester was
to chop that down and to go more to
what's already codified
in response to that the uh the
legislature created 507 B2 and then
later on the court in city of Dover
found that to be unconstitutional and
struck it down and then again uh the
legislature tried to put something back
in to cover uh uh things having to do
with arising out of ownership occupation
maintenance or operation of all motor
vehicles and all premises
so I will be submitting written
testimony later because I just didn't
have time you can't see this here but um
there are many parents that are
concerned with special needs kids that
are coming through I guess I kind of
dropped the ball when I was talking to
the stakeholders on Tuesday in that I
started off talking about it having to
do with the bullying statute that was
more of as an example of many parents
have gotten very involved in their
legislature and are advocating for their
kids last year one of the new things was
to add to the bullying statute 193 f a
section which allows for a private right
of action If the parents see that
something's not going forward they can
file a private right of action but
because under the way 507b is already
written just because you have a right to
that summary judgment is still going to
go against you because in some cases the
judges put together the indemnity in the
first part of
507b2 with the part of five and say
practically unless you run somebody down
with a truck or something falls on them
at a premise no one has the ability to
peer uh Municipal liability and and
that's why I'm I'm here is to to deal
with that so I looked at the the
definition of the methodology that was
written by the committee um support
staff and it's a very good definition
it's basically pointing out that this
opens up the door for the ability for
live lawsuits against ministerial
employees that's already the case what
we're doing with this legislation is
codifying what are the exact uh Court
decisions that support that so there are
several cases that are out there for
example Everett versus General Electric
tilted versus Doherty shop versus city
of Somersworth and hacking versus town
of Belmont one of the best examples of
this I'd like to read from hacking
versus town of Belmont elevating the
decisions of a referee and coaches in
the course of an elementary school
basketball game to the level of
government planning or policy formation
would indeed undermine the rule of
Merrell establishing immunity as the
exception accordingly we hold that the
trial court did not air in denying the
motion to dismiss on the grounds that
the decisions of the referees and Coach
were not entitled to discretionary
function immunity several times the
Supreme Court has already signaled the
legislature please fix this law it's
hard to understand we're having trouble
I presented this with Bill Boyd's help
last year under house bill 1034 some of
you may have remembered that I see
there's new members on the committee
what we're trying to do is not take away
the rights of the people who are already
entitled by law what we're trying to do
is eliminate the confusion for who is
entitled to it so the difference being
discretionary versus immunity the
language being added as Bill Boyd aptly
said uh in lines 9 through 11 come from
the decision in Everett versus General
Electric and the portion from 16 versus
20 comes from the Dover decision thank
you for your time
questions for this witness yes
representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um my concern or is on line 10 the the
ad that says is not made in one in
Reckless manner want to Reckless Manor
is a violation of a right of another
person correct um so my question is if a
planning or zoning board makes a
decision
um it perhaps an uneducated decision
because they don't know the proper
um like RSA or or like direction from
the legislature would that qualify as
wanting a reckless Manner and then
um compel the person whose rights are
violated to sue the town for that thank
you I'll do my best
um I try not to to overburden people so
uh
under under Prosser the decision under
Section 132 for that is that the usual
meaning of willful wanting to Reckless
is that the actor has intentionally done
an act of an unreasonable character in
disregard of a known or obvious risk
that was so great as to make it highly
probable that harm would follow in your
situation no that would not follow that
yes so would you be opposed to adding
intentional somewhere in here or do you
think it do you think the language is is
explainable except itself I'm amenable
to whatever the committee thinks again
what I was trying to do was that the the
court has signaled several times to the
legislature this needs to be fixed and
again I'm not opposed to the language of
of liability
um protection for things on premises or
vehicles but having it included in 507b
adds to the confusion because when you
read from the top down
you can naturally put them together and
that is not the purpose of this one is
about
exemption from being sued by an
individual for whatever job they're
doing is versus something that would be
uh
ipsilocators you know something falls
off the building or you know somebody
slips because the floor wax is a little
too too much those are things you don't
expect to happen what's driving me for
this is the parents parents are having
their children
in seclusion they're having restraint
used against them they're being bullied
when things don't go the way of the
school district and some decisions for
the school they call dcyf on parents and
they don't have any reaction there's no
teeth to protect parents when actions
are happening against their kids uh so
for the example that I found
recently was that a school principal and
a special ed teacher didn't like a
response from a special ed kid and they
dragged the child on his back the length
of two football fields through the halls
of the school it was captured on video
the principal tried to delete the
evidence she admitted to doing the
charges and then she was suspended it
took the school district two years to
fire her and in the meantime the little
boy's parents uh missed out on a lawsuit
because of the governmental immunity
that exists in Tennessee this is a
problem in many many states is that the
liability that is meant for you as our
elected officials who are doing the
discretionary functions of setting
policy and making decisions are being
benefited by those who it's not at
purposes so I'm also going to anticipate
the question is wasn't this going to
open up The Floodgate Of lots of
lawsuits and lots of costs
school districts already play into a a
primary pool with primex they have
insurance for it so
if we're if we're not going to be able
to sue them based upon the law why are
we paying Insurance anyway and the
second piece is if if it's open there
then you be start to have a financial uh
incentive like whoa now we've opened the
flood dates our insurance is going to go
up because now we're getting the
lawsuits maybe we need to change our
method that accomplishes the same thing
thank you your honor
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much
um
Marissa Chase
from New Hampshire I believe the New
Hampshire Association for justice Mr
Chase
all right all right we'll pass over her
come back to her then
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for allowing me to speak today
I'll try to keep this very brief as I
know you're probably already behind
schedule
I represent the New Hampshire Police
Association and the New Hampshire
Troopers Association today as a former
uh detective Sergeant with the New
Hampshire State Police Our concern that
we have with this bill is obviously that
it might be overreaching and what I mean
by that is uh as the constituents said
opening the floodgates I think there's a
potential for a lot of unintended
consequences as a result of this
uh the other concern I also have as a
taxpayer and as a property owner here in
New Hampshire if you're a municipal
insurance rate goes up who pays for that
that's going to be coming under my
property taxes and I don't know about
the rest of you but my property taxes
are pretty high as they are right now so
that's another concern that we have I
think this uh could more easily be
addressed if uh under
um another statute such as 193 uh if
that's the bullying issue that he's
concerned about or issues with liability
within the school system and not having
it overreaching over all public
employees so those are just some of the
concerns that our associations have and
I just wanted to bring that to your
attention with that I'm willing to take
any questions you might have questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you uh you know I
guess I do have uh I'm sorry
I am very conscious of the time and but
you said something that
interested me
um in that you talked about the fact
that your taxes are high and you don't
want them to be any higher
um Are there specific expenses that you
think it's appropriate
um that you have to pay taxes for if not
one to provide insurance coverage for
certain categories of public employees
no absolutely I I think uh you know you
pay taxes in order to have a government
and the government to run and for
services and within your town uh the
town that I live in uh we do have great
Services we have great schools however
uh you know there's that saying you know
Death By A Thousand Cuts you know if you
raise something over here and then you
raise something over here and yeah in it
of itself it's not a big deal uh I
believe it then thank you it is
appropriate to have insurance
um but you know we should try to do the
best that we can at mitigating the
expenses
uh representative Perez
thank you
um you said you thought it was
overreaching can you give me an example
of what you mean by why you think it
might be overreaching
well I think it's overreaching because
this affects if he's if the constituent
is truly looking at just a school issue
and School Employees I don't think it
needs to apply to all employees uh also
concerned with the language that's being
struck uh which uh would open up some
liability uh when it comes to the areas
that you can file a lawsuit under
um you know when you take out take away
that particular language
other questions I do have one question
I'd be interested in your I mean one
thing that
I I'm not I'm not so clear that the
prior witness who said that the Supreme
Court at least in recent decisions has
been saying you ought to change the law
we in this area I'm not quite sure
unless they've said something very
recently that I'm not aware of but but
beyond that the one thing that I think
is
very true and I'm wondering what your
view on this would be
the law is different
um at least to some extent of the
circumstances under which state the
state or its employees can be held are
subject to immunity versus Municipal uh
municipalities and Municipal Employees
and I'm wondering if you think
um it would make sense to change the law
to eliminate that so in other words the
immunity the immunity statute would
apply equally to both the state and its
actors state police officers you know
for example the Department of
Environmental Services and to
municipalities and their actors
selectment planning board members local
police officers
all I can say uh in reference to that is
uh the concern uh specifically in law
enforcement that we have at this issue
is the attack on official immunity right
now you have a recruitment and retention
issue within law enforcement we're
having a hard time bringing in new
police officers and we're having a hard
time retaining the ones that we have
um I can tell you if there was something
that we're going to negatively affect
official immunity in that in that
respect
that would get even harder you know as a
police officer I was willing to put my
life on the line to protect others I'm
not willing to put my family's life in
their livelihood on the line for that
and so that's one of the main concerns
we have is law enforcement I don't know
if that answers your question but I
think that you know you'd have to
obviously study this and look at this in
a sense that if you're going to combine
the two you don't want to have any
unintended consequences that come out as
a result of that so I I guess I'm not
opposed to it but I'd be very careful on
how I do it sure no I understand other
questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you thank
you members
um Marissa Chase
from the New Hampshire Association for
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee um I apologize it's a Thursday
at the beginning of session so bopping
around a little bit for the record my
name is Marissa Chase I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice which is a
euphemism for the trial lawyers we have
about 400 members Statewide who practice
across the board with a small collegial
bar like New Hampshire you can imagine
most Law Offices Encompass many
different practice areas that includes
personal injury medical malpractice
family law workers compensation this is
kind of all to say that our members
would love to be a resource I myself am
not a lawyer so if you have a question
for me that I cannot answer I can
absolutely find someone who can
um so we worked on this bill a little
bit last session with representative Mr
attorney Beville and representative Boyd
and I believe our intent was aligned but
the language last session and I
apologize for not having the house bill
off the top of my head
um did not accomplish it and that's all
because this area of case law and the
statutory framework that has been
interpreted by case law
is extremely confusing and complicated
um
we are in support of this bill today and
I'm passing I passed out testimony that
Attorney Megan Douglas had emailed you
the kind of lays out
how we got here and why
um I want to note I won't go through her
testimony as representative Lynn said
earlier I know you all can read and can
follow up with any questions you may
have the one thing I would note is that
immunities are
pretty much why our organization exists
to oppose them
our belief is that the only immunity you
need is to act responsibly lawyers
especially in this state do not
file lawsuits frivolously or without
careful thought it's a business decision
for them lawyers take personal injury
cases on contingency fee which means
they front the cost of litigation before
filing a suit I'd also note that about
99 of cases in New Hampshire settle
pre-suit before a lawsuit is even filed
as I said it's an economic decision so
unless there are damages that exist that
are going to make it worth all the time
and cost of litigation a lawsuit's not
going to occur it's kind of a
self-correcting problem to negate that
fear that some Floodgate Of litigation
would open I just don't see that
happening so that's all I have to say
for now again if you have any questions
I will do my best to answer it and if I
don't have the answer now I will follow
up
questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you
next I would call on uh
match uh I keep either your handwriting
has to get better or my or my ability to
read that's crazy
I'm certain it's my handwriting Mr chair
well I don't know it may be my eyesight
too it's uh it's nature like nature gray
is like the color
um I know we're a little behind
um so I just want to
um say that I agree with everything that
that the detective Sergeant set up here
um we we at the municipal Association do
oppose this bill
um I just note that 507b has coexisted
for decades with other immunities
granted by the court and the case that
is uh supposedly being put into the
statutes here is about 15 years old
um and our reading of it is that uh
the
essentially what this bill would do is
not just add the uh that language from
that case into the statute but it
broadens the scope of Municipal
liability and that could open up the the
gates to additional lawsuits
particularly in property and vehicle
related incidents because we're dealing
with ministerial immunity here
um I believe Mr chair you you asked
whether
um
we thought you asked the detective
Sergeant whether um it was true that the
the state and Municipal line immunities
don't quite line up
um I would I would agree with that
um it's a very complicated issue as
we've heard from other Witnesses today
we want to make sure that there's no
unintentional consequences uh from any
sort of changes because this is a
complex area of law both because of the
statutory language and because of the of
the cases
um
to the extent you may have suggested
that the Supreme Court uh whether
they've been asking that the law should
be changed statutorily or not
I would say they have not been
um I think the law as as is is
appropriate
um and the example we heard for the
impetus for this change really comes
from an example from Tennessee if I
understood correctly about a principle
and another
um teacher dragging a student down the
hallway by their foot to me that
certainly seems like a crime and should
be referred to the criminal justice
system
um it would not
fall in the realm of the Civil Justice
System which is what we're talking about
here with with immunities so
um I'll keep my testimony short I'm
happy to answer any questions than
anyone might have
thank you thank you very much
is there anyone else here who desires to
testify on HB 171.
seeing none I will close the hearing on
HB 171
and I will turn to
um HB
314.
and
I think I saw representative erf come in
I
my son's gonna
um representative
am I waiting for you no no you're we're
all you're all set well my apologies I
was standing outside no no no no problem
so thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee
I am Representative Keith irf Hillsboro
district 28 representing the town of
whale
I'm here presenting a sponsor of HB
314 which is the Privacy bill
and actually just know
to interrupt you for a minute Mr just
because I'm a co-sponsor on that bill
I'm going to turn the chair in the
meeting for this purposes of this bill
over to uh uh Vice chair Wallace I can
still refer to MS MR chair though
correct
okay thank you
so I'm sure we're all familiar with the
Constitutional Amendment the state
passed in 2018 with a substantial
majority
that states an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion in
private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent
this like the Constitution this
amendment is aspirational and I believe
that there I don't believe there are two
ways that we can put flesh if you will
on this there's the judicial approach
where a court case comes up and if it
impinges on the Constitutional Amendment
or statutory law they'll rule in some
way the other approach which I think is
a better one is a legislative approach
where we try to Define what this
aspirational uh
statement means
so with that as some background I'll go
to the to the bill and try to go through
it with you and at a fairly high level
and before I get to the goals of the
bill I want to touch on the definitions
since they're very important to both
simplifying and clarifying the
underlying language of the bill
so the first definition is personal
information and this is things like your
name you address your social security
number but more than that it's things
like what a phone company keeps in terms
of records that relate to your phone
calls so they keep records for building
purposes that include who you called how
long the call lasted and that sort of
thing so those that's one example of one
of the things that comes under the
notion of personal information
the next definition is third party
providers of information and services so
this is basically those phone companies
and and others that build up databases
of information that's related to their
business
um but that's related to their business
the third definition and this is a one I
added we added in conjunction with the
last hearing this bill hat or similar
Bill had last year
the notion of government entity
previously the bill included lists in
various places related to government
entities and that was confusing to folks
is you know what's the do we have the
total list here is it there and that
sort of thing so the government entity
is basically any state
our County or Municipal entity and their
employees and then we'll use that term
through the document and the AG's office
helped me to work with AG's office to
help me develop that
that definition and usage
so the goals of the bill are twofold the
first one and I'm going to read it it's
line 24. except as otherwise provided in
law
an individual shall have a reasonable
expectation of privacy in personal
information including content and usage
given or available to third-party
providers and of information and
services and not available to the public
so right there you can see the use of
some of those definitions so that the
language of the statement is fairly
simple and straightforward once you
understand the definitions and the
intent of this is going back to that
phone company example
under current law and court rulings
the phone company can provide that
information to law enforcement or pretty
much anybody
this statement in conjunction with the
Constitutional Amendment
we believe uh precludes that now there
of course will be exceptions to that and
I'll come to that because obviously law
enforcement that's probably one of your
questions we'll come back to that one
but otherwise it's fairly
straightforward statement regarding the
who that personal information belongs to
and it's basically the person who made
the phone call or what other other uh
uh information is being held in
databases
the second goal of the bill is to
preclude governments at all levels
government entities from maintaining
databases uh personal information that
are not relevant to their statutory or
constitutional responsibilities so just
just read that one as well on line 24 no
government entity shall acquire collect
retain or use any personal information
of any individual residing in New
Hampshire from any third party provider
okay now obviously that would preclude
the government's doing a lot of their
jobs so there need to be exceptions to
in the case of both of these goals to
acceptance to them so the government can
perform their jobs and I won't go
through each of the exceptions but they
continue from the rest of page one on
down to line 20 on page two and these
were worked out in conjunction with the
state agencies and other agencies of
government over the last four years
uh most recently so I worked with the
Department of Health and Human Services
I worked with the banking commissioner I
worked with fish and game and other
agencies of state government and most
recently I worked with the Attorney
General's office so I mentioned earlier
that helped me to find a government
entity and they also indicated that the
inquiries by Grand Jury the exception on
line 20 was important as well so we
added that one in there
foreign
as previously uh
presented was what are you guilty of and
what are the penalties for being guilty
of that so and again here's where the uh
Attorney General's office is very
helpful to me and first of all
separating those two issues and then
clarifying how they're expressed so line
21 talks about what are you guilty of
what's the infraction and essentially if
you're a person like me or you
um it's a violation if you're other on
any other type of entity it's a
misdemeanor so not particularly serious
uh crimes but to put some teeth into the
bill itself so there's so there's some
consequence for violating the terms of
the bill
um now we get to the Penalty and this is
an online 23 I'm just going to read it
because it only applies to government
entities
a person who suffers injury as a result
of a violation of this chapter shall be
titled to damages from the government
entity responsible for the violation of
not less than a thousand dollars for
each violation and so on
so it's only penalizing government
entities who know oh I should have added
in I was not careful to point out in
line 21 any person who knowingly
violates the provisions and that's
something else that the Attorney
General's office pointed out needed to
be in there so if you're accidentally
violating it you're not guilty of
anything
the online 26 and this goes to the
business Community
um previously the bill listed out some
some things here and folks said well I'm
not I don't know what kind of you know
you didn't list my business so as before
I defined government entity the AG's
office said well just use the term
non-government entity so that will refer
to everything else whether you're a
for-profit not-for-profit sub chapter S
Sub chapter C sole proprietorship you
know whatever and it states this chapter
shall not be construed to create a cause
of action against a non-government
entity for providing information to a
government entity so this is not
intended to impact the business
Community other than the goal number one
which is the information or about your
phone calls and that sort of thing is
private to you
uh and lastly I'll touch on the
regulation biometric information just to
tell you why that's there when OLS uh
reviewed this bill a few years ago they
recognized there's a relationship
between this and RSA 359 and colon 2
Roman numeral IC so they added that in
to account for that relationship
so that's my overview of the bill I
would just point out that I did upload a
more detailed in-depth description of
the underpinnings of the bill to your
representative greeson thank you Mr
chair and thank you sir for uh answering
our questions just for clarity can you
define
uh in in lines 21 and 22 of page two any
person who knowingly violates the
provisions of this section shall be
guilty of a violation if a natural
person or guilty of a misdemeanor if any
other person is this a
is this the crime against Aretha
Franklin who feels like a natural woman
or what are we talking about here so is
this play on words is that kind of your
question
um so I'm not an attorney okay I'm a
lowly software developer but this is the
legal language that I was instructed was
appropriate to use and my understanding
just my understanding that if some
attorneys speak later perhaps they can
qual confirm this or not a natural
person is a you or me an actual what I
would call a person
um and any other person it would be a
corporation for instance someone more
more important than us there you go if
representative Horrigan
um
my question is probably more properly
directed to the
chairs and the clerk's office but um you
did mention the butler did mention the
online portal and I've used it to submit
stuff but um how do we retrieve that
stuff do you know how we go about
actually seeing this information that
you submitted through this online portal
you're killing me so unfortunately I'm
on the finance committee and we don't
even work who the people that I think
you're responsible for that I just
assumed you can get access to it if you
can't I would be happy to
if I could just the chair is can't do
anything on this bill so
um if I could just point out to
representative hargen and to everybody
else new systems have glitches both old
and new and there is an information
technology office and representative
hargen is very familiar with that office
and if you are having problems reaching
any of these sites that supposedly exist
to help us but that doesn't necessarily
work that way they should deal with
information technology to help get them
to where they have to be
could I just since I have the microphone
um follow-up
my mind is going I have to admit that
um I read this bill and I keep on
thinking of situations we had before
this committee last year
where
um entities came in and wanted to use
information that had been collected for
a particular purpose
but use that information for another
purpose
is that
covered in this or am I being too
general for you to be able to answer
um last year there was a question having
to do really with um specific property
boundaries
not for others that could violate
privacy
so I'm not familiar with a particular
issue you're talking about first of all
you're talking about government or
non-government
it was
government information
that other government agencies wanted to
use even though the information was
available to agency one for very
particular purpose
well I guess my answer would be and if
it needs to be clarified I'd leave that
in your hands but I guess my answer
would be if the other government agency
needs it for a statutory or
constitutional purpose then that comes
under the exceptions that are included
here I I that would be my
contention I'm not a lawyer thank you
it's a very unfair question I didn't
mean to do it that way that's okay
representative tour
yeah thanks
um just looking at uh it looks like sort
of the active parts of this are uh
uh 507 H2 one and two the first one says
that you should have an expectation of
privacy and information held by third
party providers the the sort of active
part of it says no government entity
shall acquire collect retain so I'm just
wondering where is the onus of this is
it on the companies that hold the third
party information not to just turn it
over to government entities or is it on
the government entities not to ask or on
the government entities to keep track of
why each piece of information that they
happen to have came to them and what
it's there for so if that makes sense it
makes total sense so it's on the
government entity and if you go to page
two line 26 this chapter shall not be
construed to create a cause of action
against a non-government entity for
providing information to a government
entity
if that answers your question about the
business side of things being impacted
yeah I think I think it does and so the
government entity then needs to maintain
some sort of justification about why
they so then are they are they
prohibited from asking for the
information are they prohibited from
maybe related to what representative
Smith was asking using it for some other
purpose or not knowing why they have it
is who prevented prohibited from asking
the government entity yes yes
yes I mean they need to know and and
consultation with government entities
Department of Health and Human Services
PG's office the banking commissioner
they know what they need what kind of
data they need to fulfill their
constitutional or statutory
responsibilities so they should not be
asking and they have never and they have
not expressed a problem with not asking
any other questions for representative
erf
chairman Wallace and members of the
House Judiciary Committee my name is
John Williams I am the legislative
director for the New Hampshire
Department of Health Human Services and
it's a pleasure to come before this
committee today uh uh to speak on the
bill HB
um 314 is a work product that
representative erf and others have
committed some time and energy
representative former representative
Neil Kirk actually you may recall
brought similar legislation before this
committee you could look at this bill
that in terms of a purpose statement the
adoption of the state of the importance
of the protection of privacy and private
information of individuals is extremely
important not only to our agency but to
the state and it has been codified or
rather rather put into the state's
Constitution as it relates to personal
Bill of Rights so in an effort to
creating good legislation it is when a
legislator does their homework and I
will say in this case representative erf
and representative former Representative
no Kirk invited uh various state
agencies into the process to work with
them to ensure that it honors the
commitment to protecting personal
information but at the same time
allowing New Hampshire's state agencies
to deliver both at a regulatory level
but also an administrative level the
services that benefit our state citizens
and I would say that representative erf
has done that and accomplished it at
least to our state agency's perspective
on page one starting on lines 26 through
29 which sets forth the first exemption
within the legislation under a sub uh
paragraph a it's very clear that there's
two connections here it applies to State
agencies in their Regulatory and
administrative functions but then in
terms of the collection retention and
use of that it has to be for a purpose
that that state of Aging see I will
Undertake and it has to be specifically
for its functions either regulatory
investigative rather investigative
adjudicatory or administrative functions
there's also a recognition here on a
federal preemption which we think is
also very important and I would perhaps
think that a conversation with the
Department of Justice probably was had
with representative Kirk and I'm kind of
looking back for knowing not on why that
was included so what I would say to
other entities that are out there who
would like to collaborate with the bill
sponsors that they have done a really
great job in making themselves very open
and available to at least the very state
agencies in terms of participating to
ensure the balance of protection of
privacy and the ability to do our job uh
meaningfully here in the state so I'd
invade anybody who probably might be
coming after me who might have different
perspective than I'm articulating before
this committee that uh I would encourage
them strongly to work with the Bill's
sponsor they've been open to this
process throughout for the last several
years most recently in the prior bill
that this committee passed out on an
18-3 vote back in 2021 it was a retained
Bill eventually made its way through
2022 that was houseboat 597. we think
that work product that was worked there
has been carried over to this bill and
we want to thank the sponsors for
bringing this important bill before you
again we're not taking a specific
position on this bill but as it relates
to our agency we're fine with
legislation
foreign
thank you thank you
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for holding this hearing today
just for the record my name is Ross
Connolly I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire here to voice our support for
HB 314 as was mentioned by the previous
speaker this has been a bill that has
been fine-tuned over a couple sessions
now and really uh give a lot of credit
to to representative erf and uh
honorable Neil Kirk for for really
finding a way that this bill Works to
protect uh the the granite Slater's
right to privacy but also that balance
with how uh state agencies work so in
the respective time I'll try to be be
brief and not not repeat uh but as uh
representative erf mentioned in 2018 uh
Granite Slater's overwhelmingly uh
supported a an amendment to our
constitution to protect uh privacy
specifically from from government uh and
there's uh not much right now in statute
backing that right up so this bill seeks
to achieve that goal of really trying to
protect uh Granite stater's right to
privacy
as was mentioned this bill does not uh
ban the collection of data by government
agencies or private entities that simply
puts in guard rails in place uh to
ensure that that those Technologies are
not being abused since as we've seen
over the years especially the past few
years across the world that uh use of
data and and collection of data can be
abused in in enormous ways and and
violate individual rights
to Representatives representative erf's
earlier uh Point uh that this can be
achieved through through the courts or
through legislation uh I'll just
reference that we we think that
legislation really needs in in this
space especially needs to be Forward
Thinking and uh responsive to
constitutional changes and and changes
in technology and we think this this
bill achieves that we want to make sure
that government can do its important job
but also respecting those those
individual rights and as former or as
current uh U.S uh Supreme Court
associate Justice Alito stated in Riley
versus United States uh in 2018 he said
in these developments it would be very
unfortunate if privacy protection in the
21st century were left primarily to the
federal courts using the blunt
instrument of the Fourth Amendment
legislators elected by the people are in
a better position to assess and respond
to changes that have already occurred
and that uh almost certainly will take
place in the future
so for these reasons uh you know we
think that this bill and bills like it
are really the best Avenue to to back up
this this right to privacy for for
granite Staters uh and we encourage the
committee to to move this bill out to
pass and I'd be happy to take any
any questions for the witness
seeing none we thank you thank you very
much
thank you again members of the committee
Mr chair uh I was informed that I may
not have been close enough to the mic
last time so uh we'll Endeavor to do
better
um again I apologize I did rely on the
online portal to submit my written
testimony
um but I can make sure to uh to get that
to the to the rest of the committee
members
um again my name is Christopher gilraine
I represent TechNet in the Northeast we
are a trade Association of companies
throughout the Innovation ecosystem
privacy is uh of major importance uh to
my members uh we support clear statutes
that allow our customers to understand
their rights and our companies to
establish compliance structures that
make sure that they are within the
bounds of the law
to that end uh we I appreciate uh the uh
concept of putting some more statutory
meat on the bone to back up the
Constitutional amendment to provide more
uh information and more definition
um I am here uh simply to express my
members concern that in their opinion uh
the bills requirements are still not
exclusively limited to government actors
or data provided to government by Third
parties specifically
H2 Roman numeral one the expectation of
privacy it's a broad and subjective
standard that's usually applied to the
right of individuals to be protected
against unreasonable search and seizure
by government it's unclear if this does
in fact apply to the broader private
sector how that can be interpreted and
created uh into a compliance structure
that anticipates every individual's
expectation of how their data is is
being used
um again this is with the understanding
that
um you know despite the additional uh
changes that have been made uh and the
uh sponsors Clarity on this um that we
do believe that that uh Roman numeral
one still does apply to the broader uh
private sector uh and we are concerned
about how one would a company would come
into compliance with that expectation uh
if that is the case then the private
right of action uh enforcement mechanism
uh becomes really really difficult when
you've got a statute that is vague and
difficult to comply with enforced via
class action lawsuit you see massive
liability for New Hampshire companies uh
you see companies pulling back on these
kinds of services that they will offer
in the state in order to try and avoid
those lawsuits and ultimately it's a
Payday for class action firms and very
little benefit to the residents of New
Hampshire capture and this is not
speculation we've seen seen this in
Illinois with the Biometrics uh privacy
statute small businesses uh facing class
action lawsuits for unwitting or
unknowing violations of a vaguely
defined statute
companies pulling back uh in in Illinois
case uh it's uh smart home features
things that are available to the rest of
the country but not Illinois for fear of
running into this Statute in New
Hampshire under this statute I I would
imagine since there is not a exemption
for uh fraud prevention and security
that we see in most Omnibus privacy
statutes that you'd start to see those
kinds of services being curtailed
um
New Hampshire has a uh you know
well-earned and well-deserved reputation
as a business-friendly state
um there's few things that are more
toxic to business than a vague statute
enforced via class action lawsuit
um again this is all predicated on our
Our concern again that is it is not
exclusively limited to government actors
and data provided to government so we're
happy to work with the sponsor and with
the committee um to to get some more
clarity on that we want to be a resource
in that regard
thank you
representative
like in opposition is because you feel
that there's too much third party
ambiguity and if that
were fixed in an amendment
that you wouldn't be opposing the bill
yeah I think our key concern is that
that Roman numeral one the expectation
of privacy applies broadly to everybody
who handle like all entities that handle
data
um so we you know we've been involved in
Omnibus privacy statutes uh in other
states
um and what we seek is some clear
definitions you know what are the
consumers rights what are the
responsibilities of the entity that
holds the data and that way you can
create a compliance structure that that
keeps you in compliance with the law and
protects consumers uh in the case of you
know a expectation of privacy it really
hinges on an individual's uh what they
believe should be done with their data
or not done uh and it's an it's hard to
create a compliance structure that that
anticipates that
thank you
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair
um so the the words expectation of
privacy literally are now in our
constitution right so
I'm confused because I'm I'm looking on
page two line 2627 accident action
against non-government entity
it's it's saying it's very clear right
that you cannot be sued
if you provide information to a
government entity so I'm I'm really just
trying to understand where where is the
vagueness in this bill yeah so that that
uh that exemption
um the way that I and people smarter
than me read it um was that it it
applies exclusively that exemption
applies exclusively to government uh or
to data provided by a non-government
entity to a government entity and then
that is exempt from from the class
action but the overall expectation of
privacy
um
is not exempt so if a company fails to
live up to an individual's expectation
of how their data will be handled by a
private Corporation it is our
understanding that that is not exempt
any other questions for this Witness
saying none we thank you
thank you Mr chair We Now call Rick
Fabrizio
okay
foreign
members of the House Judiciary Committee
I am Rick Fabrizio director of
communications and public policy for the
business industry uh business industry
Association of New Hampshire or New
Hampshire Statewide Chamber of Commerce
Commerce and leading non-partisan
business Advocate Bia strongly opposes
House Bill 314 which is essentially if
not virtually identical to HB 597 that
the Senate sent to interim Study last
year
the belief is that HB 314 is built on
the same
um
big and overly broad definition of
personal information and features the
same troubling language regarding
constitutional and statutory
expectations of privacy
the ambiguous term content and usage of
personal information is one of the most
troubling aspects especially as the
legislation would Grant a right a
private right of action
um remaining a problem is the inclusion
of third-party prop providers and
contractors as it appears to extend
coverage to non-government entities
despite the Bill's intent
um
h3314 creates a new right to an
expectation of privacy for certain
conduct and types of information for
which there is no definition
it doesn't clearly State what
constitutes a violation nor does it
provide a reasonable right to cure a
violation before a cause of action is
instituted
uh HB 13 314 much like last year's
version uh lacks expected exemptions for
entities and types of information
already subject to federal law and
regulations
um it uh the belief is like last year's
version this bill is too flawed uh to
advance and we ask that you do not move
this bill forward
I'm happy to take any questions at this
time
are there any questions for this witness
seeing none we thank you thank you
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
municipal Association apologize for you
having to see me so many times today
um we do oppose this bill as written
um we're concerned with unintended
consequences uh that that may arise from
the language as it exists now
um particularly within the realm of law
enforcement
um obviously businesses and law
enforcement share information and we
want to make sure that any legislation
that gets passed does get it right so
that we don't end up in a situation
where we cannot get Justice for victims
um and I do want to thank representative
erf he has reached out we have been
talking with him we are hopeful that we
can come to an agreement on how to
resolve
um some of the issues that we've
identified
um so I I really do want to thank him
for that uh we are hopeful that that we
will end up coming to some sort of
compromise but as written we we do
oppose this legislation I'm happy to
take any questions that you that you may
have
representative Smith
thank you um representative Earth and
representative Lynn have submitted this
bill to the Judiciary Committee so it is
now in our control
um would you be willing to share with us
the changes that you would like this
committee to make in order to get your
support since in fact neither
um all the representative Lynn will have
a vote and will be able to participate
in the executive session
um he cannot participate today in
representative Earth will not have a
vote
uh sure so we were um concerned
um
one of the one of the concerns we had
was there wasn't a definition for what
is publicly available
um so one of the questions that came up
was there are situations where something
might be behind a paywall
um and therefore you know if I'm a
member of the public I can go pay 14 for
the information
um is the government allowed to do that
so we'd like it to be clear that that
would not be a barrier to the government
getting that information and I
understand that the concerns that
representative erf would would have I
don't want to speak for him
um but I understand obviously his
concerns are he doesn't want a company
that has gathered information for a
specific purpose providing a service to
an individual to provide that to the
government because that's what he's
trying to protect so
um I don't have exact language available
for you about how we would work that out
at this moment in time but I'd be more
than happy to share that once I if we
can work something out
thank you
any other questions
saying none thank you
thank you
major Joe Eber New Hampshire State
Police
good morning members of the committee
both chairman uh
my name is Joseph Ebert it's e-b-e-r-t
I'm a major with the state police I
oversee the Investigative Services
Bureau which is your state police
detectives
so I come in to testify today uh
in agreement with the principals that
this bill was submitted on we truly do
uphold the right to personal privacy
uh however I would as the prior speaker
pointed out I would
call some caution to the effect that
this may have on law enforcement
and as a member of law enforcement and
somebody who oversees the investigation
of numerous numerous uh horrific crimes
and crimes against persons I never want
to take uh something away from one of
the investigators that may bring Justice
to one of the victims and although I
don't think that's the intention of this
bill
what I would say is we would be
certainly agreeable to working with
representative and The Honorable Neil
Kirk to amend this bill uh
representative Smith you had asked
specifically what what would uh cause
the prior speaker to be in support of
the uh I believe that we could achieve
that support
um if there was uh uh a definition given
to that line 23 on page one and not
available to the public we share some of
the same concerns as the prior speaker
also within line 27 on page page one
where it talks about a state regulatory
or administrative agency and we would
ask your consideration of putting in a
state investigatory agency
those would be the the two items that
would cause us to come to a level of
support for this bill and I'm happy to
answer any questions at this time that
I'm saying none thank you thank you very
much
thank you Mr chairman
um good afternoon to you and to members
of the committee for the record I'm Neil
Kirk I live in Ware and I was a former
um
as has been indicated in prior testimony
this bill has been before the
legislature a number of times and it's
passed the house in various forms
and
the reason why it's brought back is
the bill protects an individual
informational privacy from government
and other intrusion
it it does this through this concept of
expectation of privacy which is
something the court system federal and
state has developed
and it only applies to situations where
an individual is dealing with a
third party provider of goods and sorry
of information and services not Goods so
this wouldn't apply to Amazon this
wouldn't apply to Walmart but it would
apply to
um
a streaming service or
a telephone company
social media providers
the concept is
and this is the situation we're all
faced with in order to take advantage of
many of these Services we give
information about ourselves and that's
defined in the bill the personal
information your name your address your
telephone number maybe your social
security number in some cases it may be
biometric information
and we give it to them so that they can
provide us the service the telephone
service or the internet connection
service whatever it might be and we
expect them to use that information for
that purpose
but it seems that they are using this
information for other purposes
and government is able to access this
information at the discretion of the
provider
either on a simple request or even by a
subpoena which of course doesn't require
the same element of proof as a warrant a
warrant requires a proof of
probable cause which is a pretty high
pretty much higher standard to meet
the question I think because some of you
are new and perhaps have not seen this
bill before
um the bill addresses an issue that's
come before the courts and the courts
both federal and state are really in a
state of confusion over this
in the United States the Supreme Court
has said based on the fourth amendment
search and seizure
that
there is no expectation of privacy
with respect to
personal information in third party
providers of information and services
so that means that the police if they
want to go and get your telephone
records can go to the company Verizon
and say please give us Neil Kirk's
telephone records billing records and
whatever else they might have not the
content of the calls to the extent that
they may have recorded them but only the
information where the call was made when
it was made what number it was called to
and everyone I called
that's the situation now under federal
law and the reason is that if there's no
expectation of privacy then the
provisions of the Fourth Amendment
against search and seizure don't apply
so the police can or any government
agency can go to these organizations and
get whatever they want from them
whatever the organization is willing to
give
in the case of a subpoena the
organization is required to give it
so
the Supreme Court of the United States
in 2018 in the carpenter case
slightly changed its concept of
expectation of privacy when it found
that
there was a reasonable expectation of
privacy and cell tower location
information
okay so general rule no expectation of
privacy and information you give to a
third party provider except when it
comes to cell phone or cell tower
so what that means is that third party
providers can do what they want with
your information sell it to information
Brokers give it to a government official
Etc
what about New Hampshire
again there's little statutory guidance
this legislature is not told not
established a policy as to what to do
with this information
and so what has the courts done
well the Supreme Court and state versus
Goss in 2003 said
along with a minority of other states
that there was an expectation of privacy
in black plastic bags containing garbage
left within three feet of the street for
collection
so that the police could not open the
bag
look for its contents and use that
contents to get a warrant to search the
okay
pretty good if you're interested in
protecting privacy your garbage is
private you put it out on the street
your expectation is that it goes to the
dump and nobody's going to search it and
use it we all know that of course kids
and others will sometimes go through it
but from a legal point of view the
expectation was
you were disposing of this in a secure
manner
then in 2005 in the State versus
gibatosi
the court
in an interesting decision held that a
subpoena to Verizon for telephone
billing records
did not create an expectation of privacy
and therefore the state could get those
records without having to prove that
there was probable cause for them to
need them no warrant was necessary
again this is only the record of the
call not the content
that was a 2-1-1 decision two judges
says yes there's no expectation of
privacy a third judge said yeah I agree
with them but
and then two other judges said no there
is an expectation of privacy and
telephone records
the majority in its opinion said quote
nothing in today's decision prevents the
legislature from closely regulating
subpoenas for phone records
and the concurring Justice chief justice
Broderick at that time said quote I
would encourage the legislature to
examine whether telephone billing
records should be protected from the
reach of a prosecutor's subpoena not a
warrant a subpoena
the court has yet to consider the
implications of the recent privacy
Constitutional Amendment
article part 1 article 2B an
individual's right to live free from
government intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent
in effect the court in the absence of
legislative guidance
is all over the place
both at the federal and the state level
and so with all due respect to those who
might oppose this bill some guidance
from this legislature is truly essential
so what does this bill do
it clarifies the Constitutional
Amendment with the legislative
determination that the third party
Doctrine will not operate as an escape
hatch for third parties providers of
Information Services to access personal
information for purposes other than
providing the service promised the
individual
number two it provides that the police
need the consent of the individual whose
data is sought or a search warrant
supported by probable cause
in order to
get that personal information the
legislature would be protecting the
privacy of that information
there are exceptions in this bill State
agencies if the information is necessary
for them to fulfill their statutory
responsibilities
obviously a warrant if there's probable
cause 9-1-1 calls emergencies where
there is physical danger of death or
severe physical injury
if there's some other statute that
happens to deal with this or where the
individual consents but only for the
purpose for which he consents and for
grand juries and there's a provision in
the bill
that a violation of the bill may bring a
civil action
we can only we can always improve this
legislation and I'm sure that if it were
to pass there would be changes that
would come in the future
but this represents a very solid
starting point for the State of New
Hampshire to protect the Privacy the
informational privacy
of its citizens
there is one technical correction to the
bill Mr chairman that I'd like to bring
to the committee's attention page one
line 18.
where it talks about government entity
means online 18 after the after the
third word or the word it's its no
apostrophe should be placed so that
employee elected official and contractor
mean employee elected official or
contractor as part of a government
entity
and not private sector
that completes my testimony Mr chairman
I'd be very pleased to answer questions
representative Lynn my understanding is
since I didn't I'm allowed to either
testify or ask questions since I didn't
testify I think I'm allowed to ask a
question so
um Mr chairman the tradition has been
that a member a a member of the House
who is a sponsor of the build
does not participate in any way in the
um public hearing on the bill but may
participate in every way in the
committee's executive session voting
providing amendments and making
statements and I stand correct I thought
that I had read somewhere you could do
one or by one or the other but not both
works then okay all right
here it is so nice to hear a former
Chief Justice say I stand corrected you
are there any other questions for
representative Kirk
seeing none we thank you for doing what
you've done over the last decade for
privacy in New Hampshire thank you sir
and with that we'll conclude the hearing
so
now we're up to Yes uh so we'll open the
hearing then on HB
149.
foreign
good morning Mr chairman and my
distinguished colleagues on Judiciary it
is wonderful to see you from this view I
can see everybody it's terrific
um and I am here to introduce uh House
Bill 149 FN relative to the handling of
requests made under the right to no law
I believe
um that this is the first right to know
Bill to come before
um this uh 2023 session of the Judiciary
Committee let me assure you that there
will be many more to follow
the state has tried over many years
to develop a right to know system that
in fact
is uh uh accessible to the public
understandable to the public that is
transparent and accountable and because
it is a very difficult task
as difficult as protecting privacy as we
heard before
there are constantly needs that arise to
refine and clarify
the law for right to know in the state
of New Hampshire
this bill comes forward not because of
Any idle desire to just have another
right to know Bill but because over the
years
we see patterns on and practices that
might not completely reflect the
underlying purpose of right to know
and one reality is for whatever reason
um legitimate or not and there are
legitimate reasons it is not always true
that a public agency
responds in a timely accurate and
thorough way to requests for information
under right to know
it is a complicated business if it
weren't we could have settled this in no
time at all
therefore this year's
contribution at least from me is one
that says
agencies experience problems in getting
all the information out in a timely way
we can understand that there are reasons
legitimate or not but there are reasons
for a delay all that this bill does is
say that if the agency has not been able
to respond in a timely way it must
explain
why and do that in in a written report
so that there is a record of why the
agency had not been able to answer the
request under right to know and it also
says that
um a 30 a 30-day limit seems to make
some sense but if you're not going to
honor that 30-day limit then you have to
uh
the agency has to let the concerned
individual know so it's just again a
question of fine-tuning
a very complicated issue that in the end
we'll never be able to be fine-tuned
completely and thoroughly but each time
that we see a problem we try
to narrow the um the effects of that
problem and I therefore present House
Bill
149 to you and ask that you added to the
long record of the house Judiciary
Committee on trying to make sure that
the citizens of this state can in fact
feel comfortable knowing that right to
know is Alive and Well in New Hampshire
thank you very much
thank you representative uh questions
yes representative Greece thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative Smith
for this bill I do have one one question
here at the end you have if statement of
time exceeds 30 days uh then they can
request another 30 days
is there would you be open to some
amendment that would say that would
prevent the stonewalling of just
continually asking for 30 more days say
you've got 90 days max you've got no
matter what you better get your act
together within 90 days or whatever but
something that just prevents the
Perpetual stonewalling of uh we need 30
more days I am completely sympathetic to
what you say I understand the reality of
what you say
but my purpose here is not to
um say my way or the highway my purpose
here is to try to move us
however slowly towards a more perfect
union and so I would
not per although I'd only have one out
of 20 votes and when this committee
considers this bill I'm not interested
in setting up
um
uh boundaries that do not allow for a
particular circumstance where it might
in fact be legitimate for there to be a
delay
questions uh representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair
thank you
thank you for taking my question uh I
noticed on the uh towards the tail end
of the uh the change that the public
body uh
whenever it's uh the 30-day time limit
has exceeded that are they required or
uh
to submit another uh
rationale as to why they can't provide
the information
thank you um the language
um on uh uh line 18 says shall provide
it does not say may provide so
um they are expected to provide and
because it's written if what they tried
to is someone in not acting in good
faith just had a whole stack of
um forms that said sorry we can't
um
we can't comply with your request you
know come back to us in 30 days
uh it would be a very short period of
time where that approach would be
challenged
follow up please
yes please okay so uh so there's uh
there's no requirement on the person
that asks the initial request to
make another request
to for the 30 days oh no they I I
believe that the burden at this point is
on the agency not on the individual
making the request
thank you representative Perez
um
right now there's a five-day business
day correct
um that they have five days business
days to respond my only concern about
the possibility of stretching it out 30
days is um do you foresee any problem
with things that really need to be
obtained in a timely manner because if
you have something that you need to
receive in a timely manner for perhaps a
a meeting or a hearing
um
this really could eliminate that
um so do you see any problem with that I
mean some 91 A's are submitted because
you find out that you need that for a
particular
thing that is going on and to wait 30 or
60 days just you've lost the ability to
obtain the information you need
representative Perris yes I in all of
right to know requests I see danger I
mean if I were you know a children's
book author I would
um I would have dangers of denials of or
delays of writing our requests just
filling the bedroom
um
but
we're adults and we're trying to do the
right thing and we're trying to
understand that sometimes there is a
legitimate reason and uh we hope that
agencies will understand that right to
know isn't going away and we hope that
individuals will understand that
sometimes there is a legitimate reason
for a delay but in fact the agency would
have to write
in writing
what the what why why there is a delay
and
um
uh
in the fullness of time this all might
work
please
reasonably necessary
is there any way to tighten that up
do you foresee anyway reasonably
necessary
um well representative Perez I would
suggest that you go home and tonight
instead of dreaming about right to know
dream about reasonably necessary and
prepare an amendment
that and and we can talk for freshmen we
can explain how to get an amendment done
because that I don't think has happened
yet and we want you to understand how to
do that and bring it into the committee
and say this is my Improvement on the
bill and you'd be earning your 200 that
way thank you thank you very much are
there questions for this Witness
yes representative Alexander thank you
this is um thank you for taking my
question
um so I've served with you for four
years now on this committee and
um I'm not going to speak for what the
committee is going to do but I do know
in the past with right to know
issues we've kind of aired on the side
of not specifying too much and not
making everything so like written into
the law in the effort to allow
um
litigation to occur so we can build up a
case maybe a case file on right to know
or you know allow an ombudsman to make a
decision about
a right to no issue so my question to
you is do you think that this
would ever or could ever be
hurting kind of the efforts we've made
in the past to make sure that it's broad
as possible
to allow for
litigation if necessary
representative Alexander thank you for
the question I think it's a good
question as it's likely to be good
coming from you I think of the work that
our colleague representative De Lorenzo
has done on on getting an ombudsman in
place
in issues relating to right to know and
I would be very interested in in hearing
either from the Ombudsman or from from
others about whether this would rather
than try
to do what we hope it will do which is
to encourage movement that it might
interfere in some way and if so we ought
seeing that thank you very much thank
you Mr chair
I'm going to next call on uh Giles
Bissonnet and you know I should note
um and I'll ask a record uh just in
regards to the last to the last hearing
um uh representative uh
check the house rules and apparently
rule 106 does say that a member that's a
sponsor or a co-sponsor May either
testify or ask questions but can't do
both so
um and this house rules in this session
it was one of the Amendments that had
come up
that was my understanding I mean it's no
so shall we reopen it no no no I'm
absolutely not asking that the Committee
hearing be reopened no absolutely not
no no problem whatsoever we all make
mistakes so that's for sure and I make
more than my share I'm sure
oh microphone that's great is is it on
now oh it is great
um it's nice to be here uh again gilpa
legal director at the ACLU of New
Hampshire I couldn't help but chuckle at
that moment because like um any lawyer
and judge knows you you go back to the
rule book whenever questions are raised
which certainly happened
read the rules
um I'm Gonna Keep My Testimony very
brief we support this legislation
um
uh we want to indicate our support you
know I do want to note that it is not
uncommon for there to be delays
sometimes even significant delays with
respect to when a requester
obtains a substantive response so you
know a month or two can lapse even then
only to obtain a a blanket denial citing
an exemption and so there can be delays
in this process
um but I do want to note that frankly in
in my practice
um I there is a tendency as a litigant
that's kind of a replete a repeat player
in this space that I do tend to get
periodic updates not always but I do and
I think why I think this bill is a good
bill and why I support it is that it
makes sure that everyone gets that
benefit not just lawyers like me you
know who routinely go to court in public
records litigation and I think it's a
really important service for government
agencies to provide just to timely
communicate what they're what they're
thinking what issues may be coming up
when they're responding to a request if
they're going to be delays why they're
going to be delays how long I think that
really is a good thing because I think
the more communication that happens
between government agencies and
requesters in fact the less likely there
is to be a fight or dispute down the
line the more communication that happens
the greater there is a chance that
disputes can be resolved amicably
without litigation so I think this is a
a good bill that really Fosters that
level of communication and transparency
it makes sure that it's not just my
office that gets that that every every
member of the public gets that whether
they have a lawyer or not so for those
reasons we support this bill I do want
to know with respect to the five-day
issue that was raised this actually
doesn't change the five-day response
requirements I just wanted to flag that
a municipality or government agency
would still have to respond
within five days but what this bill does
is just make sure thereafter in the
event that the documents aren't produced
at the five-day mark that they're just
again regularly regular check-ins with
the requester about the status of the
request so with that I'll conclude my
testimony and it's great to see familiar
faces and some new ones as well in the
committee thank you thank you Mr
President I have questions for this
Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
municipal Association
um so I I do have a handout today with
uh a proposed amendment so I think that
the uh the sponsor raises a great
question here so under our current
system what happens if you make a right
to no law request the agency has five
days to respond and they either give you
the information they deny the request or
they provide a written statement saying
how long they need to figure out what
they're going to do
um and the sponsor raises a great
question of okay well what happens if
they provide you that written statement
and it turns out that their estimate of
how long they need to figure out what
they're going to do is wrong
um and so I really think we're resolving
this issue makes a lot of sense
um and
we would propose a slightly different
solution than the sponsor has put in
front of you
um so under the existing statute and
under
the bill as proposed as I understand it
is essentially the government would
respond and say hey we need however long
it is so for example you make a request
that you want all the emails from your
account administrator for the last six
months your town comes back you and says
hey we think that's going to take 90
days
90 days is coming up they realize they
need a little bit more time
um and we think that the appropriate
response is really that the municipality
should and the people responsible for
responding that request should look at
how long it's realistically going to
take and give you that update along with
an update of well what have we done so
far so you know that they're not just
sitting on it they know you know that
they're working towards responding to
your request
um and that would be different than the
30-day update and there are two two
reasons that I'm proposing this the
first is that
the purpose the right to know law is to
get information to the hands of people
who need that information as soon as
possible and I think making
making the government look at the
request and make a realistic Judgment of
how long it's going to take makes sense
and the second is I'm very afraid having
answered many many legal questions about
how the law works that somebody's going
to look at the 30-day thing and say hey
I missed the first deadline I said I
needed 90 days I get an extra 30 days
when it doesn't actually take them an
extra 30 days so I think by
realistically leaving the onus on the
government to make that estimate
and make that estimate accurately with
the update makes sense and so that's
what my proposed amendment would do and
I'm certainly happy to take any
questions that anyone has questions for
this Witness
I do I guess I do have one question
about uh Mr Grace the the thing I it I
mean one significant difference between
your
a proposal and the way it's written now
is if I'm understanding your proposal
constitutes that there's ju if you can't
provide the information
um
uh
in the time estimated in the initial
written statement then there's only one
you the municipality only has an
obligation to provide one
one report saying it's going to take us
longer there's no obligation to continue
providing updates is there under yours
if I miswrote that there should be a
continued continual obligation and
that's what we advise
um okay so you don't have it in other
words you don't have a problem if we if
if your proposed language was tweaked a
little to say that
it you you gotta you gotta if you don't
right if you don't meet the what you've
said you're gonna do right you have to
provide more responses right so when the
ACLU makes that request and they get
some information and they get the update
of here's how long it's going to take if
they miss a second estimated deadline
that's totally fine understandably the
ACLU and who or whoever else should get
an update of here's where we are
um and so they know that we the
government are working towards
accomplishing the request
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Tripp thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question
uh
I'm a little slow sometimes so uh please
bear with me uh
I believe that when a right to know
request is made there's
three
suitable responses by the government
agency they can make the record
available
they can deny the request
or
give you a statement saying how long
they think it'll take for them to
fulfill it
uh
I believe that
the the
bill
makes the assumption that uh if there's
the third option is the one selected
that eventually
the requester will get the information
uh would it be possible should that the
government agency
you know in the time used to
you know prepare the
response determines that uh the
information should be denied
is is that a something that could be
written in the response
so I think that's inherent in the law so
here's let me give you a realistic
example so if you make a request for the
last six months from your town
administer's emails
while the IT department can probably run
and capture all of those emails fairly
quickly
someone in the government's going to
have to go through those and determine
you know if it's a governmental record
which is the first question so if your
Town Administrator wrote you know me an
email and said hey Nate it's your
birthday happy birthday that's not a
governmental record because it has
nothing to do with with the business of
government
um so those aren't going to be included
they can exclude those there might be
information about
pending litigation so they might have
sent their Town attorney an email and
said hey you know
the ACLU is suing us and we want to talk
about settlement here's kind of some
numbers and obviously that's not going
to be released because that puts them at
a disadvantage when when talking about
those settlement investing in settlement
negotiations so that might be denied but
as they go through it if you know if
that's a later email as they're going
through like periodically day by day
someone is reading through each of these
emails they might not know that email
exists until
day 89 of 90 in which case they're going
to say you know we're going to redact
that email because it has it there's an
exemption that applies but they won't
necessarily know about that at the
75-day Mark when they thought that they
were going to have all that information
ready
does that make sense I hope that
it'll do thank you other questions I
thought I saw another question over on
the side but I'm a co-sponsor but I may
ask a question correct you didn't
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um so the example that you gave about
you know going through the emails and
finding um you know information between
the lawyer and one of the parties um
at the public agency
would that be covered by your attorney
client privilege
as well
yes okay um
I'll leave it at that I was just thought
that would be an easy example to use so
other other questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you
but a call on representative uh Peter
Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for your attention
for the record I'm Peter Schmidt
representative Ward one in Dover
um and I am a co-sponsor on the bill
because I I have uh been looking at this
situation for quite some time I've been
in the house now for 20 years and I was
on the Dover City Council for a couple
years before then so have a fair amount
of experience with governmental issues
and my concern is that in most cases
these requests can be acknowledged very
quickly
they can be complied with very quickly
but sometimes the request is uh is
constructed in such an open-ended
fashion that it that it can require uh
the the efforts of the legal department
of the city of Dover in some cases and
I've conferred with our City attorney
and some other people who do this kind
of thing for the state
um and the the bottom line can be it can
it was alluded to a moment ago by Mr
Gray's uh that sometimes it's a request
for a review of correspondence over a
long period of time that that just can't
be done in a couple of days you can
start it perhaps you can give some kind
of a partial uh thing but if you want a
a review of
five years of Correspondence between the
City attorney hypothetically or any city
of official
and uh and a group of other people this
can turn into a doctoral dissertation in
terms of the amount of work that's
required and that that's one of the
concerns that I really want to bring to
the committee uh the idea that uh that
the people who are doing this in many
cases are the legal department and they
can be literally spending virtually all
their time
now they've got competing requirements
of their position
for what whatever the town may need
and so they're Torn Between the this
inexorable machine of the right to no
request that says you got to do this
within certain number of days or respond
to it with a denial and so forth It's it
can be a very very difficult request
aspect to re to respond to legitimately
as I say in most cases the the thing can
be acknowledged and responded to
quite simply and quite quickly
and the the bill does say every
reasonable request and to make a
reasonable effort
one of you brought up the question of
what does reasonable mean
and I I serve on the joint legislative
committee on administrative rules
together with your chairman and I've
been on the administrative the gel cars
it's called for
um 16 years I think so the word
reasonable appears in the statutes more
than once and it's as as the Judge Lynn
knows uh that that's the devil in the
details what what does reasonably mean
um and and trying to make the word more
and more precise can be uh really
devilish so uh without wanting to
prolong my testimony too much longer but
the thing is that I urge the committee
to look at seriously at that this
conundrum of the not simple request
especially something for a a long period
of time some kind of a review it can't
be done in a short period of time any
more than you can pop a seed in the
ground and pour you know 800 000 gallons
of water on it and expect you're going
to have the plant next day it can't be
done
so please do uh you know do your
reasonable best to look at this language
and see if if it does not improve the
situation in those instances in which
the request is not a simple one and
therefore can't be responded to a
immediately possibly partially but you
can't get a full review of something
that requires months of work and it's
extremely expensive one other aspect I
do want to to address here and that is
that not every requester is uh is a an
ordinary citizen who wants to have some
bit of information acknowledged or refer
referenced in a short period of time and
it can be
you do have in some cases malicious
actors who do want a hamstring the
municipality by requests which can be
extremely expensive and they tie up
people who need to be do who need to be
doing in some cases more important
things so the malicious actor is is one
that is causing a lot of problems so
I'll answer any questions you might have
if you have questions for this witness
yes representative Staples thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
these uh
exceptional circumstances that consume a
lot of time and are very costly to the
municipality is there any way to assess
some type of fee recovery for those sort
of things either to discourage or enable
the the delivery without such a heavy
impact upon the municipality
well that is an excellent question
representative Stapleton and the reality
is uh that that's one of the problems is
is kind of a kick me sign
um uh in some requests in some
situations uh that because there is
essentially minimal cost involved to
make the request uh that it it it tempts
the malicious actor
um or even the the unfamiliar citizen
who doesn't realize that his request is
so open-ended that it's going to be very
expensive but he ain't going to pay it
uh so it encourages uh you know abuses
in my opinion thank you
follow up sure so basically the answer
is we have no recourse against those
malicious actors or the Unknowing
uh request that's too extensive to be
handled expeditiously
I I think that's one of the problems
that that the committee has to be aware
of this and and perhaps some testimony
from uh uh a City attorney or there are
there are people who in the at the state
level who also deal with these requests
this type of requests and uh and hearing
from them might be beneficial for the
Committees I don't know whether it's
going to go to a subcommittee but
um or whether it's an early bill but but
that is an aspect as well very
significant question thank you
oh thank you other questions for this
Witness
thank you very much representative Smith
you're more than welcome Mr chairman
thank you members
our next uh Carla
sure she represents right
that's right oh sure yes sir if you come
up and just tell us uh are you Miss
cockle Keiko Catherine Coco Coco I'm
sorry
please
so I can still say good morning
honorable members of the Judiciary
Committee
um and and your honor my name is
Catherine Coco I am the acting president
of right to know New Hampshire we are a
citizen-based organization that provides
advocacy education and assistance to
those seeking access to public
information and increase transparency in
government operations our priorities are
threefolds to keep government records
access free and open to the public in
compliance with the New Hampshire
constitution in part one article 8 which
stresses and uses the term
accountability twice to improve the
enforcement of New Hampshire's right to
no law and to improve government
transparency you'll be hearing from me
today on a number of proposed bills so I
won't repeat my introduction
um
right to know New Hampshire views hb149
is an incredibly important piece of
legislation this year this is one of two
pieces of legislation that our members
chose to really focus on because it
addresses a critical issue that is
raised in many of the inquiries that we
receive from the public this bill
provides clarifying language that makes
it clear that a public body has ongoing
accountability for every right to know
request until such time as a decision is
made and the records when available are
provided
currently the only response required
under the law is that within five days
the public body must do the three things
that were one of the three things that
were mentioned before provided denial
provide a provide the record itself or
provide a written statement of the time
reasonably necessary to determine if the
request should be granted or denied and
that reason
note that there is actually no
requirement to ultimately provide a
final determination and the records
themselves when the public body selects
item three
unfortunately we see immediate responses
or denials from public bodies far less
frequently than we see a standard
legalistic response outlining an
anticipated wait time for records when
someone makes a request
as a predictable result the most common
inquiry that right to know New Hampshire
receives from the general public
regarding these inquiries is regarding
extended time frames in which the
requesters have been waiting for
information without receiving updates on
the status or the completion of their
request
based on the current language of the
statute
the only advice that right to know New
Hampshire can provide to those
individuals is that the public body is
only required to provide them with an
anticipated time frame for response it
does not actually provide for any
further update on the status of the
request the efforts being made to
respond or actual completion of the
request this loophole does not serve the
public interest and weighs the balance
of power in favor of the public body who
may have reasons of its own to wish to
delay or withhold information
various Court decisions have made it
clear though what constitutes an
acceptable time frame for consideration
or fulfillment of requests can depend on
the size and the scope of that request
and I think that speaks to some of what
representative stapleton's question was
I can speak to that a little bit later
as well
this revision doesn't change that fact
and the language that is written here is
not designed to be punitive despite the
fact that public bodies do not really
have a motivating disincentive to
delaying their response instead hb149
could provide the future right to know
Ombudsman which we are very excited
about and the courts with relevant
information about the public body's good
faith efforts to honor the request and
adhere to the intent of 91a
and I think in response to
representative Alexander's question we
anticipate that the information provided
in these updates will allow for a more
objective evaluation of the public
body's efforts when those are in
question at the court or through the
ombudsman
we would also argue that once the
request is made the burden of justifying
a lack of response should fall in the
public body it is asking for an
exception and the public body should be
accountable for actions it has or has
not taken and this this language
achieves that without creating a
punitive disincentive we also think the
30-day window is a reasonable period of
time would not place an undue burden on
the public body and it aligns the
expectations of both parties involved in
the request process and hopefully
alleviate some of the current demands on
the public body that are that exist
because there's already a lack of
guidance regarding follow-up so
individuals will be following up the
community or public body doesn't know
what their requirement is to respond
there's a lot of back and forth if you
have an established process for this it
should help clear some of that up
our hope is that adding these simple
reporting requirements will assist
citizens public bodies and the courts in
establishing whether or not reasonable
efforts have been made to address those
requests and I'd like to add a couple of
things to my prepared testimony and I
will send a copy of this to your staff
person I did not come with copies um but
I know how to submit them electronically
um to answer a few questions that have
come up I have had a couple of
situations where I personally have put
in a request and that request has been
I've been given the time frame for
response and at the end of that time
frame from response I have been told
that certain elements of my requests
were were being denied at that point so
yes that does happen
um
I think that we need further
clarification on the amendment I didn't
quite follow quite honestly the
significance of the change that nhma was
requesting it seems to me that what
we're asking for
um in in this particular bill is uh
already
what what nhma is saying that they want
except that there wouldn't be any
additional follow-up after the second
update and I think that leaves a pretty
wide loophole but I need to make sure
that I'm reading that correctly so I'll
weigh in on that in writing as well
um
and finally I would add for um
representative stapleton's question
that language that was mentioned by rep
representative Smith is that correct I'm
sorry not Smith um Schmidt great okay
um the courts have determined that there
is a um what the boundaries of
reasonable are some that case laws and
that information is already out there
and so there is some leeway for a public
body to determine whether or not a
request is reasonable or unreasonable if
not in the statute but based on the case
law and so that provides the basis for
responding to the kinds of overburden
some concerns that that you've raised
and with that I will question welcome
your questions
being none thank you very much oh well
oh I'm sorry
representative Lorenzo thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question Miss Coco so you know just to
follow up on what you had just said that
there's sort of a Judicial remedy for
you know abusers of um you know right to
know requests yep um how does it get to
the point of um a judge how does it get
there
so at this point because the Ombudsman
does not take office until January 27th
an individual would have to file
something with the court in order to
to have an action come forward
is that
answer your question or
I need to think about her a little more
it would need to be
so I I believe if the public body feels
that it's being overburdened it would be
their responsibility to file something
or it's through usually I mean I would
say Town Council or their own Council
but I mean
unfortunately until the Ombudsman is up
and running that is that is the reality
Where We Are
close to follow up I I think that um
public officials
um
kind of back away from
um I feel that they should
back away from you know getting into
contentious you know fights with the
public so I think that's that's
um
it's sort of like walking on eggs
you know because I mean public agencies
are there to serve the public
thank you understood all right any other
questions thank you very much uh Carla
uh Rocky is that correct Jericho sorry
all right
hello committee my name is Carla Garrick
I'm from Manchester New Hampshire I'm
here representing both myself because I
do file a lot of right to no requests
and I also serve on the board of right
to know New Hampshire right to know New
Hampshire is a Statewide nonpartisan
group of concerned Citizens We're just
people who really care about the issue
of as it's stated in the New Hampshire
Constitution open transparent accessible
and accountable government I think I'm
here in support of this bill and it's
kind of nice to be on the same side with
people I'm sometimes on the other side
of so uh that probably tells all of us
this is a good Bull good for the people
so um
you know I think the important takeaways
here to remember is the way the bill
right to know is currently written they
the public agency would have to respond
within those five days this is really
just providing a broader exception in
those cases where they don't respond
within those five days in my experience
it's actually really good if the public
body just you know gives the information
but there are situations where there's a
big request and we understand that
people do need a little more time I
wanted to make a point to representative
greeson's point I think it might be
valuable to add in to the end of this
that 90-day period so that we're looking
at you know the law says you've got five
days or you have to deny it now we're
saying well sometimes it seems
reasonable that you might need some
extra time here's 30 extra days but you
have to tell us when you think you're
going to get to this and you know what
you're struggling with but then let's
not make it this sort of open-ended
thing I can give you a very concrete
example
um recently in Manchester there was a
move to rip out a community garden and
put in a Boys and Girls Club it was done
in a back room deal there was a sale of
a public park without any input from
anyone in the neighborhood I filed
several right to no requests I was I
mean I think everyone knows me by now so
I got a lot of the requests back very
quickly but then with regard to the
emails I got the the they said hey it's
going to take us about 30 days to get
those emails back and then since then I
never heard anything back on those
emails so this would be a concrete way
to really help concerned citizens to be
able to hold our government accountable
to the point about costs I don't think
that's relevant into this bill at all
there are other bills that will be
coming in front of this committee and
that is something we should talk about
but also just as a last point a lot of
people who are filing these right to
know requests there isn't a malicious
intent what there is is an intent of
concerned citizens to hold our
government accountable the only way we
can hold government accountable is if we
know what is being done in our names and
so that is the goal and I asked the
committee to please consider this bill
favorably I'm happy to take any
questions questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on HB 149 FM
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on this bill I will note that we
are probably about an hour behind
schedule what I would propose and I'm
open to if committee members have a
different view I'm open to consider it I
would propose that we hold the hearing
uh now on 254.
uh try to get through that and then I
would propose that I open uh maybe
before 254 that I opened the hearing on
289 but recess it until one o'clock does
that seem reasonable to everybody
seem reasonable all right so what I will
do is I will open the hearing on HB 289
and then recess it until one o'clock so
that people that are here for that and
you know if you want to go get lunch you
can go do that but then I will
and uh
don't see a pink card for representative
Simpson
sorry
ah oh is that a stupid four that's
nature oh okay that's that's 254 also
or
oftenberg
all right yes
uh well not quite morning but that's
that's close enough
good afternoon good to see all of you
um
Mr chair and members of the Judiciary
Committee thank you for allowing me to
introduce HB 254 which would allow local
public bodies to meet the needs of their
constituencies more effectively by
allowing more of their members to access
meetings remotely
many local public bodies began employing
remote meeting technology during the
pandemic and community members and
elected officials found that it was
effective and efficient technology that
could address issues they face in terms
of every everyday participation in
running the government
Town leaders from across the state have
asked that we add language to 91a to
make it easier for them to do their work
when members face child care or Elder
Care emergencies illness or disability
issues many local Municipal boards and
committees are struggling to achieve a
quorum in person that they would easily
be able to achieve with an adjustment to
91a these select board members zoning
board members Etc have time sensitive
decisions to make and if they don't make
a quorum there are real consequences
when they're unable to take a vote at a
meeting
in this bill a physical location for
meetings is required but if a quorum is
not achieved at the physical location
having one-third of the local public
body present at the physical location
would suffice the Quorum could then be
met by members participating remotely
this bill focuses specifically on local
public bodies as specified in 3A
so things like school boards and towns
municipalities counties in every case
for these rules to be applied the
governing body of each local public body
can choose to allow this option
access to remote state and local
meetings during the pandemic was
necessary for granted Staters to stay
safe but it continues to be necessary
for those who experience barriers to
accessing in-person meetings under
regular non-pandemic conditions those
who have disabilities or illness those
who have young children who are taking
care of Elders those who are
have all shared with me how important
remote access is to them
excuse me as members of public bodies
this bill gives each local public body
the ability to be flexible for its needs
while still adhering to the right to
know laws
so before I take your questions I need
to ask you to consider an amendment so
it has come to my attention and I
apologize that it at such a late date
um but I've been speaking with
disability rights Advocates and by
making 254 a repeal and replace Bill
we've inadvertently taken away options
for committees who are already meeting
under paragraph three
um RSA 91a to paragraph 3 to operate as
they are now operating so committees
perhaps of the Department of Education
or something like that so there are
already rules for those in place so what
I'd like to ask you to do is consider
this amendment that leaves paragraph 3
untouched but would add this as a new
paragraph under that three a three a a
through H I believe so
um oh can I one more sentence I'm almost
thank you
um so I would add this new paragraph
that would only apply to local public
bodies and it would um Define it for
that case
um and then
it's also come to our attention that we
uh in the drafting of the amendment we
need to add an exception for town
meeting because we think that would be
really impractical
um so that will hopefully I have spoken
to a member of your committee who may uh
change this amendment and bring it to
you as well but I'll answer my question
your questions the best of my ability
um but also there are others here who
will be speaking who may be able to
answer them too
um let me pass this around if that's
all right
um
so
do we have questions for this Witness
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I only have one
question sure is this bill
constitutional is this bill
constitutional we believe that it is yes
we have no reason to believe that it's
not we believe that it's in line with
what is already in RSA 91a
and and you know what I just I guess I
just have a question so you are going to
provide or maybe you already have this
is this is the amendment this is the
cure that yes problems you identified
okay yes that's it that's that takes
care of my question so uh the only thing
I'm going to do to that is add an
exception for Town meetings right after
local public body in the first paragraph
it will say accept town meeting
other than that it's soft it solves the
oversight
I'm just making a note
right
um all right other questions for the yes
representative Perez might I have you
add and school
meetings too because we have a separate
Town meetings and separate school
meetings when you're voting on people
and budget so perhaps that should be an
exception too
let's definitely talk about that I
haven't thought about that or talked to
anybody
um who does that at this point but let
yeah we can definitely talk about that
may I yes when you're talking about town
meeting are you talking about
you know I live in Londonderry we have a
town meeting well it's not really a town
it would be inappropriate to have people
in by
um Zoom or whatever
so I we were thinking of the
of the Town meetings where folks don't
vote in the voting booth where they vote
in a room
so I've not thought about deliberative
session yeah no my town also has a
deliberative session I've not thought
about deliberative session
um I'd have to talk to especially to the
municipal Association who's representing
the towns and municipalities to see what
kinds of conversations the folks who run
those
um and who participate in those have had
already
um the the other piece of this is that
there's already in statute there's
already Provisions for
meetings that allow for remote access of
the public body
um and so the amendment wouldn't change
that it would just change the um Quorum
so right now you'd still you still have
to have a quorum like for a deliberative
um in the pre in the physical location
right
um and so this amendment without an
exception for deliberative session would
say that you'd ha you could have a third
present as opposed to 50 percent
um plus one uh
thank you question representative Tripp
actually I have a question on the chair
since uh we're holding a hearing
obviously we've accepted the bill uh
will the uh the prime sponsor be able to
I think we well we've we've got it right
I mean we've we I I I I
um
during the amendment in uh but I believe
representative Simpson understands that
yeah yes I do and um and have talked to
um representative page has offered to
work with me um to turn it into
amendment that you all could have at
your executive session if that's all
I'll write with you it makes that makes
perfect sense okay other questions
for this way yes uh representative puta
so as
as this was originally written it had
allowed for a public body may but is not
required to yes and this is changing it
to a local public body and then it's
also
um
excluding the fact that it can't apply
to the general court was that
intentional
um that's a great question the general
court makes its own rules so we have
only been focused on the local public
bodies for this piece of legislation so
if you look in the definitions for RFA
uh 91a number five is for public body
and then it has a list of different
kinds of public bodies and Part D is the
um
would include like towns Municipal
corporations School District school
administrative units
um and so that is where the idea for
let's just call it local public bodies
so that we can just deal with the towns
the municipalities the folks who are
um
really
strongly encouraging and urging us to do
this legislation yeah so the general
court is not involved in this at all the
drafter told me it was not necessary to
have that line in there that it excludes
the general court already
because of the definition of local
so it wasn't your intention then to
actually exclude the general court my
concern is that right now the way that
the law stands if the speaker wanted to
due to an emergency or something like
that he could allow because 918 is
allowing it but if you're removing that
from this paragraph and there was an
emergency for some reason then
he wouldn't be he wouldn't have the
power to allow that unless we had
amended the house rules and so that's my
concern so he would have the power to do
that under what already exists in Roman
it would just have your
no so that's what the amendment does not
remove it the amendment adds an extra
session section that's though so
it was a repeal and replace and now it's
just an addition so it leaves in what's
already in statute and it makes an
addition
two examples of another it's a music
good okay great no thank you I
appreciate you saying that so that stays
the same yeah other questions for this
Witness
yes representative Andrews
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question is line
14. the two words reasonably practical
what is the definition of those two
words in here and should it be listed
what is reasonably practical
so
my first answer is it's really for the
governing body to decide and the local
public body to decide what's reasonably
practical
um my second is that um
this is language that of um a former
member of of the Judiciary Committee and
other stakeholders worked at for quite
some time to come up with and felt that
that was a good way to State it so that
you left the towns with enough local
um enough local control but not complete
free reign
okay does that make sense and I think
I'll also ask um that if if Nate Graves
from the municipal Association would
also address that I think he'd have some
insight into that as well
thank you other questions for this
Witness
thank you very much yes thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
for the record my name is representative
Joshua Kella
um from Rockingham 32 Fremont Danville
um I am testifying in support of the HB
254 as I'm a co-sponsor on the bill
um and I have looked at the uh the
amendment and I was part of that working
group that actually drafted
um the original language
um and so uh one of the things that is
being changed
um is that
it is allowing more control at the local
level for restricting if if a governing
body is not handling their remote access
properly then this law would now be able
to
allow for some restriction of that
whereas in current law it's just they're
they're able to do remote access by
right and so there is a
the local public body is allowed to vote
to disallow
um remote options that is one change
also
um regarding the uh town meeting
uh language being added to this
amendment town meeting is uh also
includes a deliberative session and uh
the sb2 voting day that is all
considered town meeting is just
different ways of describing town
meeting and so we will verify that that
school town meetings are this are
covered under the exception and not
allowed to have remote remote access
because that was not the intention of
like you know how would you uh you know
check someone's ID and stuff like that
all remotely and make sure you're
eligible to vote it doesn't make any
sense so we're going to make sure that
that gets cleaned up before your
executive session
um
so this also uh
I do believe that the reasonably
practical language
um as far as uh remote attendance is
already current law as far as like um
people being able to understand uh
whether or not they're allowed to be
doing remote uh attendance to their
meeting and this is also uh and it is
decided by the board
um that that uh so if I'm on the uh zba
I actually did attend a zba meeting
remotely and the board actually the
people in attendance decided whether I
it was reasonably practical for me to
have attended in person and so that is
how the current uh
law is and so um also
I wanted to clarify
that uh
the the quorum
the the intention of this bill was not
to mandate that just because uh the the
members of the board have remote access
that it's also forcing those that the
municipality to force remote attendance
by by uh non-members of the board so
this is just focused on the remote
attendance of the board itself uh and
you know leaving the option open as far
as remote attendance and whether they
are hearing testimony remotely
um based on if they have the capacity to
do so because there are technologies
that you know depending on how many
people are in attendance it costs more
money and so if you have like a smaller
Zoom plan or something like that you
might only be able to
um have the actual members uh be able to
attend and wouldn't be able to control
like the um the
the entire you know population being
able to tend uh remotely
and
um I think that is
all that I had to clarify if if you had
any more questions or detailed questions
about
I'm sorry representative Lorenzo thank
you
thank you representative thank you for
taking my question absolutely so you
know towards the end of your um
presentation you mentioned that um
sometimes it's costly on Zoom to
um you know have a larger audience it's
a lot of participations
um it's a cost really enough that it
would limit
um municipalities of public bodies from
having meetings
thank you for the question I think that
the um the purpose of the bill was not
to mandate that the local municipalities
have that technology or that higher
level plan it's just trying to address
the board process and whether or not
you're allowed to and how many members
are allowed to vote be in attendance
remotely and and the remote
participation by members of the public
was kind of outside the scope of this
bill it was the intention so thank you
absolutely other questions for this
witness representative Tripp
foreign thank you
for taking my question
uh
the
the amendment would would allow
which would uh
uh in in my mind
since uh the meetings have to be uh
the discussion has to be uh
uh people have to be able to listen to
it and everything so so does this
actually mandate that uh if it if the
meeting is being held remotely
that uh people would have the same
technology as is being used by
the uh
thank you for the question I'm not an
entirely sure that I understand it but
I'm going to try and uh
answer both kind of possibilities of the
of your question I think
um it's
I am unclear on whether you're you're uh
saying that whether the bill requires
that the other members of the board be
able to to uh uh discuss things and see
each other and have the same technology
and that is addressed on um line 17 of
the amendment to line 22 of the
amendment where the um
where each member or specifically
starting on 18 each member participating
electronically or otherwise shall be
able to contemporarily when competent
contemporaneously and throughout the
meeting see and hear and be seen and
heard by the other members of the public
body in the meeting so yes they would be
required that all the meetings would be
all of the members of the board would be
able to see and talk to each other and
you know have that full communication
and then you're if you meant that the
attendees be able to see then that is
addressed on line 23 to line 25 which
says that all members
um
shall be Audible and or visible to the
public in attendance
at the meeting's physical location so
it's not mandating that everyone that
attends the meeting actually have a zoom
but that they be able to hear or see the
people that are attending in Zoom let's
say for example having a TV set up in
front of the
um that is just pointed at the audience
so that everyone would be able to see
that is in the audience but not
necessarily attend remotely right
thank you other questions
for this witness the only question that
I have done representative ukella is um
will you and representatives we probably
will I'm not we haven't agreed on this
yet but I'm thinking we probably will
exec this bill in about two weeks and
will you be able to have the amendment
with the town meetings this sort of
stuff to representative page transition
time for us to do that thank you for the
question yes I'm I'm in frequent contact
with the representative and the
municipal Association and so I'm ha I'm
I mean I could have done it much sooner
than two weeks so I am have strong
confidence that it will be ready for you
great thank you very much thank you all
right thank you uh next I uh represent
I'm sorry not representative but Karen
Hill
okay
good afternoon you know we have a number
of other Witnesses on this and and uh
the clock it's lunch here so I guess
what I what I would say is I don't want
to inhibit anyone from testifying but I
would you've all heard sort of what
other people have said and so I I would
hope that you will tell us new things
that we haven't heard rather than just
kind of repeating what other people have
said Thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Karen Leo Hill I am a city
councilor in Lebanon and I'm here to
voice strong support for this bill on
behalf of the city and also to request a
one-word Amendment
um if someone would be willing to bring
that forward the city of Lebanon um over
I have served as the city councilor and
also the former mayor over the last 18
years and so I have seen varying levels
of participation I have seen almost all
of the potential ways that people can
participate or be prevented from
participating and what I have seen over
the last three years
um during the pandemic is that the
remote the ability for people to
participate remotely has been good both
for the city council
just last night we had a city councilor
actually two city councilors were in
covid quarantine and they were able to
participate in the meeting
remotely and so we were able to benefit
from their contributions when there's
only nine of you
each voice is really important to the
deliberative process and in some
communities there can be as few as three
people who are responsible for making
decisions and so the city of Lebanon
strongly believes that this bill is
beneficial for good government to be
able to continue
despite weather despite illness despite
any of those things that can come up
this bill is consistent with local
control it is enabling it does not
mandate that communities must do this it
merely provides the option so that if a
local community feels that it is
appropriate for them they can go ahead
and adopt it and it does have safeguards
in place by having the requirement that
a physical meeting does take place with
at least a third of the board that
ensures that public meetings as they
should while
meeting the need or meeting the desire
to have people be able to participate
remotely lastly I'll just address the
amendment you may have heard about the
community power Coalition of New
Hampshire this is a
this is an effort of cities and towns
local governments including counties to
pool efforts to get lower prices for
energy it is an instrumentality of local
government and there are more than 20
communities that are involved so far
stretching all the way from each corner
of the state and so I'm here some of you
may have served with Clifton below who
is currently our assistant mayor and
he's also chairing the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire and he has
asked saying that it would provide
really be very helpful in order to meet
Quorum issues and to allow the
functioning of this and entity
if the word instrumentalities of local
government could be added so that it
would address the community power
Coalition it would be a very narrow that
is a very narrow addition that we're
requesting and I bring that to you today
at the request of Cliff below and the
question uh yes representative Tripp
thank you mister
chair uh thank you for taking my
question is instrumentality defined
someplace
yes I believe it is and I'm happy to
have um Cliff below provide some
additional language he is very well
versed on these matters so if
representative page is open to
considering that in the other amendments
or I can provide it to
um the chair that's great thank you
other questions for for this Witness
great thank you very much
thank you Mr chair hello again
um I'll jump right into it right to know
New Hampshire is opposed to Bill HB for
uh 254 which is designed to alter the
requirements for remote participation by
public officials we recognize the
advantages that remote access has
provided to engage citizens and public
officials everywhere but there are
challenges that are posed by the use of
technology and many of those still
remain to be resolved to explain those I
have actually attached an additional
backgrounder to my testimony that I am
happy to share electronically and answer
questions any questions about our
position on that it provides some
insight into right to know New
Hampshire's concerns and considerations
about remote meetings in general and
many members of our group have testified
in Concord on this issue for several
years in a row now our membership did do
specific to this bill a full comparison
of the existing and proposed language
and I believe that even with the
amendment these comments still stand
the first issue is that by saying that
the low and I think now the language has
changed from governing body of a
political subdivision to local
governments
um may may be authorized to participate
in remote meetings this bill effectively
creates a distinction between how local
and state-level public bodies are able
to make use of remote meeting technology
political subdivisions are well that I
don't think applies anymore under the
amendment the political subdivision
piece but it still raises a question of
what's the authorization Authority at
the state level and the language as it
stands implies that state bodies may not
allow remote participation second there
is contradictory language in here that
requires the members of the public body
be Audible and visible to each other
under item C but not to members of the
public to whom they must be audible or
visible which is under item D this
creates an imbalance of the information
that's available to members of the
public body versus those that are in the
public it also raises questions about
the technology that's to be used does
this language now require video
conferencing is that video able to be
used only between public officials but
not be seen by the General Public
third this bill removes critical
requirements that the location of the
meeting must be given in the look in the
notice meeting notice and that all votes
taken during a remote meeting must be
taken by roll call vote I think some of
the changes from the original statute to
the draft you have in front of you were
not necessarily intentional but when you
do a line by line comparison there are
changes like that that are substantive
finally item C provides an alternative
to the Quorum requirement for meetings
to be able to move forward
instead of a quorum it requires that
only a third of the public body if that
number is less than the Quorum would
need to have a physical presence the
language and item C is very confusing
and I'm going to get in the weeds a
little bit about this the main question
is why would we provide an alternative
definition of a quorum a quorum can
often be defined by the public body
itself or by the governing body that is
over it so if they wanted to have less
than the current Quorum number they
there's usually a mechanism for making
that change
item C is further contradicted by a
later statement that says a member
participating in a meeting by the means
described in this paragraph is deemed to
be present for all purposes including
for determination of a quorum
if the physical participation is being
used to determine the Quorum then those
who are remote are not being counted in
the Quorum despite what that sentence
says
the term all purposes is also
exceptionally broad the power of a
public body typically lies in its voting
power which requires a presence of some
kind using the phrase all purposes
raises a question about what other
purposes does the public body being put
to Beyond voting
the reference to the Quorum requirement
is also confused by the fact that item G
below provides an exemption for
emergencies but much later in the
reading of the bill within the right to
know law itself the language
consistently used to note exemptions to
a requirement prefaces that requirement
by saying accept in an emergency comma
and later it goes on to Define that
emergency shall mean and explains that
this standard language would be much
clearer
there are elements of this bill that
right to know New Hampshire does support
giving the governing body the authority
to determine whether or not a public
body can allow remote participation
helps to clarify a consistent process
for its use while the bill still allows
for more stringent conditions if the
local entity wants to consider those
right to know New Hampshire and its
experience leadership many home of whom
have testified here long before me would
be happy to discuss concerns about
remote meetings with any legislator
we've testified previously on that issue
unfortunately the language of this
proposed Bill does not appear to be
ready to legislate today we urge you to
oppose this bill as inexpedient to
legislate tomorrow we encourage the
creation of an ongoing conversation and
an analysis of the challenges we face
when we're balancing the use of
Technology with the public rights
Public's right to know
thank you questions for this Witness
thank you very much
Carla uh
thank you uh chairman and the committee
uh Carla Garrick for the record uh again
testifying as myself and as a board
member of right to know New Hampshire I
know everyone wants to go to lunch so I
will make this very quick I concur with
the previous statement
um you know I'm very torn I'm a techie
person I love technology so I definitely
understand that this is a direction we
want to move in but I don't think this
bill is the right way to do it so I
would encourage you to itl this and then
to start a conversation I think it's
important to note that the conversation
and the testimony in favor of this bill
only talked about how it would be easy
for the people who serve and of course
we appreciate everyone who serves but
you serve on behalf of the public and so
these bills need to accommodate the
public and not make it easier for the
people who are serving the public but
indeed for the public I would also say
that as we explore floor this area an
important thing I noticed that is
missing from this is I would encourage
us to put in language that talks about
these kinds of remote meetings then of
course being recorded and also being
subject to the right to know bills so
that we just make sure as we move into
this direction we're actually creating a
greater public body and public work for
the public because that is actually why
we are all here I haven't looked at the
line items on the amendment yet but I
would encourage this committee if you do
proceed for whatever reason I do think
there needs to be a very close reading
of the language to the bill and there
has been testimonies submitted uh
electronically via email from some other
right to know members that would help
you with that so I encourage you to go
look at those emails so I would say due
to the shortcomings of this bill I would
like you to oppose it now but but again
we are open to and we understand that
there is a need for this but let's do it
right from the start so that we don't
make a mess and then we spend 20 years
trying to fix it thank you
any questions for this week
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
municipal Association we support the
bill we support the amendment
um I know there were a couple specific
questions committee members had asked um
uh so representative Perez had asked
about school meetings I don't know off
the top of my head whether those were
included
um as part of the exemption from
people uh meetings where where remote
participation could occur
um it that was not meant to be included
so we'll make sure to get that language
correct
um
the term town meeting does cover as
representative yokella indicated
the whole event no matter what structure
your town is so if you have a
deliberative session if you have a
traditional town meeting whatever your
structure is that's that's the term as
defined in the statutes elsewhere
um
uh I believe representative Andrus had a
question about what reasonably practical
means that's already in the statute
um that has existed there uh for a long
time and it really captures the idea of
you know why can't you show up and it
has to be a good reason it can't be I
didn't want to get off the couch and not
drive to town meeting in town hall it
has to be some legitimate reason like
I'm in quarantine or you know something
that that actually matters
um
uh representative Tripp asked a
clarifying question about uh kind of the
process so I just want to reiterate that
this does not authorize totally remote
remote meetings there still has to be a
physical location at least one third of
the public body has to be present at
um and there are additional requirements
for anyone who is participating remotely
so that
information from them can be shared with
other members of the board and the
public so it's not an entirely it's not
entirely remote meeting there's still a
physical location for people to go to as
already as required
[Music]
um
other than that I just want to say since
you've you've seen at least uh you've
seen one Municipal official uh We've
also heard from quite a few Municipal
officials about their desire for
something to go into effect to allow
them greater flexibility with meetings
um because they recognize that
um with the advance of Technology it is
important that the government can
respond in a similar manner to as
private business to events that occur
and allow the participation of people
who've traditionally been excluded
such as the elderly who may not be able
to drive such as the disabled such as
people who you know rely on others for
transportation and we have seen uptake
in that type of participation over the
last few years and we want to continue
to provide greater access for
participation as members of the
government because we are a government
of the people and we want to continue to
promote that for all the people thank
you happy to answer any questions
questions for this week
meetings as a whole
um
have made improvements to Public Access
for people
absolutely so when I've talked with
municipalities
um they've said as they've done things
like streaming their meetings as they've
done things like opening it up to uh
more remote participation they've seen a
pretty marked increase in in the public
generally and especially people who
wouldn't ordinarily be able to come down
to town hall and sit through those so
people who have young kids you know
they're not going to get a babysitter
for the night people who you know for
whatever reason don't can't drive there
or too far away or there's bad weather
or whatever the case may be and they can
continue doing the business of
government so I think it's been a great
Improvement on on how government
functions thank you thank you are there
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you you may step down and I'm uh
Karen Rosenberg please from the
disabilities rights Center
good afternoon welcome thank you I'm
Karen Rosenberg the policy director of
the disability rights Center I know
you're all starving so I'll be quick
um in general we support the concept of
this bill because
um there you know we want to encourage
Civic engagement in this state but we
also don't want to thwart our public
body's ability to get their work done
Civic engagement can include people with
disabilities people who have experienced
illness now we've learned about covid
and need to quarantine so expanding the
ability of public bodies to function
despite some of these bumps in the road
for participants that would encourage
participants is a good thing from our
perspective but only if the bill is
amended to create a new section that
would not obliterate the current
Protections in our current law that
apply to other types of bodies that
wouldn't be covered by this law so
current
91a2 Roman 3 which I'm sure I'm going to
butcher your name representative cutoff
astutely pointed out is really necessary
so that when there's an emergency or
reasons that other public bodies can't
meet or in person or not all their
members can that they can continue to
function if they meet the in-person
Quorum requirement so as a member of the
state advisory committee for children
youth with disabilities this has been an
issue getting you know allowing parents
of children with disabilities and
parents with disabilities to participate
by allowing them to access our meetings
remotely if necessary so one other thing
I wanted to encourage you to think about
is how if there is going to be a remote
option for public body particip members
that that the public also be able to at
the very least view those meetings
contemporaneously again it's about Civic
engagement encouraging engagement from
people all over the state regardless of
whether they have a disability or not or
a communicable illness like covid that
we've seen recently it's about making
our government open and accessible to
more folks so thank you great questions
for this Witness
so can I just can I just ask one
question are you comfortable with at
least that's the first point you raised
are you comfortable with the proposed
amendment which would basically say
we're not repealing the existing section
three we're just making this what is
referred to as section three in the in
the uh in the bill section 3A yes my
heart skipped a beat when I saw the
repeal so yes are there any other
questions for this Witness thank you
very much thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill 254.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that bill
um and now long last it will be time for
lunch I know that I said that we would
have we would uh resume the hearing on
uh 289 at one o'clock it's obviously
you're not gonna have enough time for
lunch if we do that I will be back here
at one o'clock to recess that until but
can I say 1 30 does that give everybody
enough time to come back by 1 30. all
right so if you would all be back by 1
did I say I thought this let me go oh
now it's actually actually a couple
minutes after one and I said we were
recessing the hearing on HB 289 so 1 p.m
so for the record
um it's a little after one we're gonna
uh continue we're gonna recess that
further to 1 30. so at 1 30 we will
begin with uh HP 289 and then we'll go
through uh the rest of the bills you
know as quickly as possible after that
Bill we have for hearing is House Bill
289 uh originally scheduled for one 11
30 but we recessed the hearing first to
one and then to 1 30.
um
yeah representative Corcoran let me not
hear
um
all right
um I guess maybe uh
I guess maybe I will I'll I'll recess
the hearing on that
um
for now and move on to 3-0 House Bill
right
unless this is representative no it's
not all right all right all right three
oh we're gonna move on to 307 and
um I'm gonna represent uh recognize
representative McGuire
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire I represent the
town of Epsom
this bill makes a small change to the
right to know Law 91a
related specifically to
attorney's fees that may or may not get
paid
um after the conclusion of a trial so
um so we're in a situation where
somebody asked for a certain amount
certain kind of information they were
denied by the public body and then they
filed a lawsuit took it to court and won
and then the question is should the
public body
um cover their attorney's fees or not
and So currently in current law it says
that only if
um the court has to make a judgment they
have to say uh should they have known
that they should have given this
information and if so then they would
cover the attorney's fees we're changing
it simply to in this case you you you're
denied you go to court you win then your
attorney's fees will be covered right
and it's basically pretty simple you
know we want public information to be
available to people and we don't want
the the process to be the punishment you
know so somebody who needs information
they go through all of this they get it
finally at the end of the day it
shouldn't on top of that cost them fees
so it's it's that simple thank you Mr
chair
I'm sorry representative Wallace did you
um
so uh I guess I do have one question
representative McGuire and the the
language you propose is the court
renders a final judgment in favor of the
requester so
I mean this might be a somewhat unusual
situation but
if the a final judgment in favor of the
requester
would not necessarily mean
that the requester got the information
got some information and I guess what
I'm thinking of is this Suppose there
was a lawsuit under the right to no law
that that said
something like
um
you uh
u-town
um eventually you gave me the
information I wanted but you took too
long and so I'm bringing a lawsuit
saying uh I want
uh you know I want a ruling from the
court that you're not going to do this
anymore you're not going to from now on
you're gonna you're gonna you're not
gonna take as long as you have taken to
provide this information and the person
wins the court says yep you know the
town really was
um uh
dragging their heels and and
um so I'm so judgment is entered in
favor of the requester but
the requester didn't actually it had
already gotten the information without
the lawsuit what happens then thank you
Mr chairman
um
to me I think you're stretching it a
little bit too far right I mean to come
up try to come up with an example I mean
um in the case you're saying it it to me
it doesn't sound like that lawsuit was
necessary right I mean this person
their their
just doing a lawsuit just because they
didn't like the process or something you
know what I mean it's it's um they got
they wanted information they they got
the information
that should be the end of it I would
think I mean I don't know
I mean you may be wrong
yeah other questions for this Witness
all right thank you very much thank you
and may I I'd like to acknowledge my uh
co-sponsor representative Smith she she
is also helped us uh put this together
great thank you for sure
all right
um
now let's see uh so next
yes it's cocoa sorry I'm sorry thank you
no it's fine
um
so I'll jump right into it right to know
New Hampshire enthusiastically supports
HB 307 which sets a more realistic
standard for awarding attorney's fees
when right to know cases are won by the
requester
unfortunately due to limitations of data
that's available we're not able to
articulate the number of right to know
cases that might have been fought how
many were won by the requester or the
number of instances where the winner of
the case was awarded attorney's fees I
always prefer to have that kind of
information on hand and right to know
New Hampshire has tried to gather what
it can from available court records but
with few findings what I can say is that
based on the experience of our
membership the general public who seeks
our help and the attorneys with whom we
interact an award of attorney's fees is
incredibly rare not only that but in
most cases municipalities and state
agencies typically outlawyer and
outspend the average citizen where there
is a contested outcome and a right to
know case
the spending power and the knowledge
base of the state and local governments
typically Edge out less powerful
citizens forcing them into a position of
deciding whether to pursue an
enforcement action that may lead to a
financial loss even when they win and
even if they're able to do that a
citizen who makes rational economic
decisions and I admit that not all of us
do that is unlikely to invest in an
action that does not confer a personal
benefit the public good rarely outweighs
a personal pocketbook the playing field
needs to be evened out so the average
citizen has a shot at coming out if not
completely whole at least partially
compensated for the public good that
they are fighting for otherwise they're
further disincentivized to raise the
issue at all
if our current law didn't rely on
private actions for enforcement maybe
this strategy wouldn't be necessary but
it does I think this Reliance on private
action is one reason that New Hampshire
ranked 34th in the nation and received a
d-minus in public Integrity as evaluated
by the Center for Public Integrity in 19
in 2015 not 1915. in the category of
public access to information New
Hampshire received an f and ranked 49th
the report stated that the bar for
recovering attorney's fees and other
costs is dauntingly high here one
related driver for that score was that
in practice the entities to monitor the
application of access to information
laws independently are not initiating
investigations or imposing penalties on
offenders we got a score of zero
in helping to create the right to know
ombudsman's office the Judiciary
Committee has tacitly acknowledged the
financial deterrent that prevents
citizens from bringing their right to
know issues to court and I think that's
very important but even the creation of
this office will not change the scored
factor that I just mentioned because
investigations still have to be
instigated by private action and
existing penalties for violations of 91a
are limited but HB 307 would make it
more feasible for those who do find
themselves in court to consider pursuing
the right to know enforcement action
since those actions take the place of
independent monitoring in New Hampshire
they're contributing to the public good
and a healthy discourse around the
implementation and enforcement of RSA
91a
I'm going to preempt what I think I
might hear in the opposition which is
that public bodies do not want to have
to pay costs associated with clarifying
gray areas of the law unfortunately this
works to the advantage of the public
body as long as those gray areas exist
the uncertainty they create is and will
be exploited to the benefit of the more
powerful public body and sometimes the
only way to gain Clarity on those gray
areas is to bring a challenge to the
system that judicial clarification
benefits the general public and I would
argue that sometimes even when the right
to no case is lost and I've lost some
the clarification found in the case law
is a benefit to the General Public
I can provide an example of that if we
wanted to talk about a gray area but
given the extremely high upfront costs
that are associated with attorneys fees
this legislation is not likely to
precipitate frivolous actions what it
will do is improve the chances that New
Hampshire citizens will be able to
fulfill the role that's assigned to them
as independent enforcers of New
Hampshire's right to no law and
encourage them to pursue cases where
their position is obviously or very
likely to result in a winning case and
changes to the behavior of public bodies
um
and I will end there thank you
so I guess I I do have a question the um
you've you've removed from the current
law
um language that says fee shall not be
awarded if the parties agree to that
that's that's that's taken out I
shouldn't say you but that's taken out
of the language of the of the uh of the
bill and so my question would be
um
I I
would it be your understanding that even
though that under the under the proposed
uh bill with the Amendments that it
accomplishes to current law
there would nothing there would not be
nothing that would prevent the parties
to
a right to know litigation from agreeing
that in this particular case no fees
thank you Mr chair
um
I I will clarify this is not um
legislation that right to know New
Hampshire drafted so
um I I'm weighing in based on my opinion
and my read of this but I do not think
that this prevents any kind of agreement
from being able to take place that was
my reading aspect okay okay I'm sorry
other questions for this Witness
uh Lori
sorry thank you
foreign
good afternoon Lori ortolano
um I didn't come with anything prepared
in writing just came to speak
um I'm I'm a member of right to know New
Hampshire and I speak in favor of this
bill as a member and also as an
individual that's been involved in right
to know litigation in Nashua
for almost three years
um
I think it's time
to remove this standard that we have as
part of the language and make it easier
for attorneys fees to be accessible to
people filing suits and I think it would
have helped me in my cases tremendously
to come to resolution and close them
down without having them spiral a lot of
control and become what I would call a
dumpster fire
and
um
the as it stands right now the cost of
litigation is very high I took a right
to no lawsuit into court for assessing
records I spent two hundred and thirty
thousand dollars I won a portion of my
fees I removed my lawyer after I got
through the order but the city appealed
to the Supreme Court the cost of the
appeal was going to be a hundred grand
so I went on my own and
um you know it's hard to be a pro say
litigant doing this but you know I filed
a right to no lawsuit with an attorney
under the assumption that they're
handled you know a priority case they're
simple I was told not a big deal I told
my husband I'm gonna do this I'm
frustrated I've been trying to get
records for a year
and he was all on board
but we had no idea it was going to be a
quarter of a million dollars and if I'd
stuck with it it would cost four hundred
thousand we just had no idea and it's
frustrating to me that
um that's what I learned
um I did two cases after the one with
the attorney actually while the attorney
was representing I filed two more on my
own in Superior Court pro se
and I won those cases and I did it to
just I wasn't going to go through the
legal fees I went through I won the
ruling for the records and the city has
appealed all three cases up to the
Supreme Court
so they're challenging the the in the
case represented by the attorney that
was so expensive the court did award
fees and he awarded information that the
city would not provide
um they're still withholding the
information and they're fighting the
fees I may not win these high standards
I may not win and they might be reversed
and it's going to have cost me a quarter
of a million dollars and it upsets me a
great deal that the constitution is
written such that our records are
supposed to be open accessible
accountable and our government is
supposed to be responsible and we're not
supposed to have unreasonable
restrictions and you can't be a single
digit millionaire and take these cases
into court as a citizen anymore you
can't your billing rates are 500 an hour
and you're just being raked over the
coals and municipalities have big
pocketbooks with taxpayer dollars and
they were able to fight me like a beast
I stayed in the game
um but it's been really eye-opening and
since those three cases are done I went
in with another one because the city
just won't shape up and I know that if I
tried to get legal representation that
case in Lower Court would cost me four
hundred thousand dollars with a lawyer
and I'm not paying it
that shouldn't be the cost for
information you know we've lost our
media coverage now Nashua no longer has
a newspaper really of any doesn't cover
any political things Manchester is very
minimal
the Press played a big role in right to
know in opening records and taking place
cases into court and that was great they
had them Corporation behind them in the
money but I think you're seeing it shift
to Citizens trying to do it and we're
getting smoked and our ability to win in
court is pretty poor I think
I feel like the courts don't like these
cases they're burdensome to the court
they're busy they have bigger fish to
fries they've got criminal cases we've
got drug problems we've got serious
problems that have to be looked at and
your little information request isn't
very important but it is because it it
allows government to operate in the way
government is supposed to operate and
when you make it so difficult for
information to be obtained you have no
press That's checking municipalities can
go really off the rails and there's no
way to pull them back on
I think that's happened in Nashua and it
is it is brutal and it becomes so
personal it's not just a request for
information it's the associated
gaslighting of citizens that goes on in
trying to get it
and I think if fees were awarded the
cities and the towns would sit back and
go oh you know we don't want to play
games here we want to be clear we want
to try and get to the bottom of this and
we don't we don't want to be paying fees
and I I think it would have helped me
I'm not certain it would have fully
helped me but I think it would have
definitely helped me and
um you know
sort of get control of the nonsense
um
yeah these this was a really eye-opening
experience to me for me and very very
painful for my family and it goes on and
when they can appeal and go to the
Supreme Court I won't see responses and
information until 2024 2025 and by the
time I get them
it's it's all a waste of time and I
wasted you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars to get really nothing
it's very disappointing I I wish the
state and the government and the courts
I'm frustrated with the courts had done
more to get a hold of this before it
became this the Ombudsman office is
terrific the work done
by representative dilorenzo and right to
know New Hampshire I think it's a great
move it's a step in the right direction
but when you go into court and you need
to access Court let's let's allow some
of these fees to be obtained you're only
going to win probably 30 percent of the
time citizens aren't going to do great
but
um you know give us an opportunity to
recoup these the
very expensive thank you thank you
questions for this Wednesday uh yes
representative Brees thank you oh well
I'm sorry okay sorry thank you Mr
actually this may be a question for you
and your legal expertise and you could
clarify for all of us
do we have the ability to restrict a
public body from being able to appeal a
decision unless some newly discovered
evidence would show that the original
ruling was unjust so to play The
Stonewall and the expensive Stonewall of
well we'll just appeal it because we've
got deeper pockets they can't do that
unless there's some way they can prove
that the original ruling was unjust
by some new evidence can can we do that
because the private citizen can appeal
their decision against them that's out
of their pocket but the public body is
just playing a game
I mean I I mean I I guess that we we
probably could do that although I would
I guess what I would say is I'm not I
any time the the
anytime the municipality appeals I
assume that
somebody has made a determination that
that the lower that the trial court
decision was wrong I mean you know I
maybe I'm being maybe I'm being too
generous to to attorneys but I think
that in a for example if an attorney
where if an attorney knew that a case
was that a case was sort of frivolous
let's say and they would and was just
taking an appeal for the purpose of of
costing the other side money I I think
that attorney would be subject to
discipline uh under the under the rules
of professional conduct so I I assume in
you know in most cases that that
uh some you know an attorney who
representing the municipality has made a
determination that we have some issues
here that we have a reasonable chance of
prevailing on not necessarily we're
going to win but but but it's not a
frivolous kind of issue
oh I hope that answers your question
could I respond to that as well his
question just
um
from my perspective
you know you hope they wouldn't do
things frivolously but I think in fact
in my situation there have been some
frivolous things done and
um representative Lynn is correct you
know you can file a complaint through
the professional conduct committee
but let me tell you how difficult that
is
you can't get a lawyer to assist you
because lawyers don't like writing out
other lawyers and guess what the the
city does they lawyer up
and you go in there it's brutal your
chances of getting through that group is
beyond discouraging I am A1 disgusted
with what it takes to take a complaint
to a professional conduct committee that
is
and you're sworn they tell you you're
sworn to confidentiality you don't sign
any agreement there is no complaint I
could file in any other group that I I
as a citizen am not allowed to share
that complaint if I file against
assessors in the Department of Revenue
it's a public complaint it's all public
they tell you it's all private so you're
just stuck in a hole with no
representation and citizens can't write
them well enough
if they give you a book of like 10 point
print with 200 rules to figure out which
one they violated it's it's very
difficult
you can't go up against it it's it's not
a good system
representative Lorenzo I believe you had
a question all right any other questions
for this witness yes representative
Perez thank you for taking my question
see this seems very black and white to
me remember I'm not a lawyer but you
asked for paperwork you weren't given
How can there be appeals to if the judge
said you should have your paperwork
if I I I'm naive in the legal system
although so was I so was I but they have
it right that's the process the judicial
process they have a right to challenge
the decision of the Court the lower
court and they have an appeal process
that takes it to a higher court so this
was black and white I asked for
something I didn't get it I'm going to
court to get it right and then and
what's even more frustrating in one set
of Records I asked for a year and they
they said they were giving them to me
we're sending them we're redacting them
we're looking at them we're sending them
went on and on and on
and then this was asked for in December
of 2019 in October 30th of
2020 the letter came that they elected
to deny them
so you wait 10 months and you're told no
after they looked at them
and and you know then you could get a
ruling to win and they're up there
appealing it
you know it's just
it's maddening
I other questions uh representative
Smith
it's so good to see you again thank you
um the whole issue of attorneys fees is
a very complicated issue there are very
few areas where attorney
's fees are granted by the court
when the uh
when the client prevails we've seen it
in the area of special education and it
was in that area because there was a
clear there is a question there is a
question here I promise because
um there is a clear pattern of school
districts having attorneys whose Revenue
came from saying regardless of the
merits of the case saying do not Grant
what has happened is we've been aware of
that in the area of special education
for a long time but we have not been
aware of it
this bill though has two provisions and
I want to ask you about the second one
the first is if the requester prevails
the court can then go and Grant
attorneys fees
but the next paragraph says if the
the court can then require them
to meet the attorney's fees
of um of the agency
uh
do you see I think I think it's a little
bit more restrictive
um I think it has to show
um
like the language now for Citizens I
think it has to show an intent to to
um try it out
um be malicious or unintendent not just
um a favorable ruling against the
citizen automatically grants the fees to
the city the other thing is it would
change because the cities would have to
start keeping fee records and they don't
the cities I'm required to hire an
attorney who maintains contemporary
contemporaneous records of their fees
the city it does not maintain any fee
records at all
and so I've been opposed to that because
I think they ought to track them it
shouldn't just be us
that they can throw out a lot of things
and stand in a meeting and say God that
lady's made us waste millions of dollars
show me the records but they don't track
them at all if I could follow up what it
says is in bad faith frivolous unjust
the vexatious wanton or oppressive those
are all very unpleasant terms but
they're also as both specific and vague
in terms of of definition
um and so do you have any problem with
that section being included
no because I do think those words in
front of it put a higher standard than
just losing and I also think those words
are vague but there are legal
definitions to them and they have to
abide by a legal definition and a legal
standard
yes representative yes I I just dawned
on me as you were asked as that question
is being asked and I guess I'll direct
it at you but it may be maybe more
easily answered
um
uh buyer chairman
if a lawsuit is one of those things uh
frivolous or unjust or vexatious would
it be dismissed
and would that dismissal
be different than rendering a final
judgment
uh
well I mean you said you're asking you
to you're asking it of me but uh that's
a hard question for me to answer I mean
I think that one way or another a judge
has to make a ruling it might be part of
a case that you submit a pleading on
that you're trying to look at versus the
whole thing I think it doesn't it
probably would be hard for a judge to
dismiss it without hearing it the case
in its entirety you're looking at all
the evidence that's being
um you know provided so in that case
time gets wasted potentially and that's
what makes it you know a problem and
frivolous but so I'm not certain that
they can that they would or do or that I
see often where they just a judge just
dismisses something as frivolous they in
my opinion are investing a good bit of
their own time and effort and the
resources of the court to determine that
other questions for this witness thank
good afternoon hi my name is Brendan
McQuaid I'm the president and publisher
of the New Hampshire union leader I
would like to start with disagreeing
with Miss ortolano that the media is
gone we're very much here
um I'm here representing the New
Hampshire press Association and we
support HB 307
um the New Hampshire right to no law as
you know plays a crucial role in the
transparency of state and local
government
the log currently supports broad
disclosure of documents but we continue
to see instances like in Lori ortolano's
case where documents are wrongfully
withheld and they're withheld in
violation of the letter and the spirit
of the law the current provision for
awarding attorneys fees is that the
public body public agency or person knew
or should have known that the conduct
engaged in was in violation
we would expect that public agencies and
public officials should have known that
they were in violation uh in practice it
proves to be a rather High bar and HB
307 as proposed gives much more leeway
for the court to award attorneys fees
which have to be reasonable according to
the language
um
and it would create a financial
incentive for public bodies to be more
responsive to valid requests for
information that they
ought to know that the public has a
right to
the New Hampshire press Association
represents many media Outlets throughout
the granite state from small one-person
online news Publications local weekly
papers large daily newspapers and
broadcasters the right to know law is a
critical tool for all of our members
to inform the citizens of this state
what their government is up to a public
agency that refuses to comply with the
right to no law backed up by publicly
funded attorneys is a daunting obstacle
especially for some of these smaller
outlets and it's a daunting obstacle to
generate quality local news we hope that
by making recovery of attorney's fees a
bit more attainable HB 307 will help
level the playing field in the important
work that our members do we
wholeheartedly support HP 307
all right thank you uh questions for
this Witness
good afternoon I'm Margaret burns with
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
and we are here this afternoon in
opposition to house bill 307.
under our legal system the general rule
is that parties to litigation pay their
own fees and costs there are some
exceptions to this Rule and the current
RSA 91a8 is one of those exceptions
the plaintiff or the requester is
entitled to fees and costs if the
lawsuit is necessary to enforce
compliance with the right to know law
or to address an intentional violation
of the right to know law
fees are awarded only if the Violator
knew or should have known that the
conduct was a violation of the law there
is logic to having these exceptions
where there are intention intentional or
egregious conduct that justifies
awarding attorney's fees and costs to
requesters or plaintiffs in these cases
but under the bill the law would say
that if a plaintiff is successful in a
right to no law case and the lawsuit was
quote necessary to enforce compliance
the plaintiff will get fees and costs
making this a dramatic change to the
right to know law
this would apply even in a situation
where a public body or a public agency
took reasonable steps to get legal
advice acted on that legal advice was
sued and ultimately the plaintiff or the
requester was successful
Shifting the burden of Defending that
lawsuit based on reasonable legal advice
to the taxpayers
the second section of the bill does
allow the public body or the agency to
receive attorney's fees and costs in
certain situations where the lawsuit is
vexatious frivolous and other terms that
are listed in the bill
nhma does not support this section
either we do not have a policy to seek
out attorney's fees or costs from
residents or citizens who bring right to
no law cases our legislative policies
with ex with respect to the right to
know law are to oppose additional
burdens and to support the intent and
purpose of the law as well as to support
legislation that clarifies the law and
makes compliance and Public Access
requirements easier and less burdensome
for public officials and employees and
less costly for taxpayers
the legislature has recently taken
significant action in this area to make
right to no law actions more cost
effective and more accessible to
Residents and citizens with the creation
of the Ombudsman position
for these reasons we are opposed to this
bill and we would ask the committee to
vote as an expedient to legislate thank
you thank you thank you questions for
yes representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony so if I understand your
your testimony in the in paragraph two
the addition of the clause and provided
that the court renders a final judgment
against the requester
you don't think that needs to be in
there because current law ends with the
period after oppressive
no our position is that current law
should remain in RSA 91a8 as written
right so
put a period after the word oppressive
not have the what's bold that's correct
that's where the period is thank you
sorry for that for not being clear thank
you
other questions for this Witness
yes representative thank you Mr uh good
afternoon Miss Burns um
you know
listening to to the testimony
in this hearing I feel like
you know there are two opposite poles
kind of going back and forth is there a
middle for instance you know if um the
plaintiff files in court can the Judge
order
um
an injunction Aristotle or something
like that so it doesn't get to that
point where I believe it's RSA 91 A7 a
different section from what we're
dealing with now that does allow for an
injunction so it's we're not always
talking about
um in we're not always talking about a
specific scenario as as was referenced
earlier about the records or not the
records sometimes there's an injunction
not to repeat this conduct in the future
sometimes there's a requirement even
that the public body members undergo
right to no law training so those are
different types of orders
um that you can see in these types of
cases
thank you other questions for this
witness say none thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman your honor it's
good to see everyone again uh today my
name is Jill Bissonnet I represent the
ACLU of New Hampshire we're here
strongly in support
um at this bill
um I've been doing this job now for
around 10 years and a core component of
my work has always been government
accountability public records work to
try to make sure that the public has
access to what their government
officials are up to and it's frankly
been among the many things I do probably
the most rewarding work
in my in my legal practice and just by
virtue of that experience I am asked a
lot by Advocates who cares much about
transparency
um as I do you know what would be
like the the single greatest thing you
could do to make New Hampshire more
transparent and my response has been you
know absent a wholesale rewrite of the
statute which is hard and cumbersome and
requires so many stakeholders
it would be to have mandatory fee
shifting it would be to do what this
bill does and I want to explain why
um
mandatory fee shifting it allows
requesters again who who Prevail in
public records lawsuits to recover
attorney's fees and costs and it is
critical
to ensure the Public's right of access
because it what it really does is create
a set of incentives where government
actors are more likely to produce
records they are more likely to err on
the side of disclosure and that is the
whole point of chapter 91a
chapter 91a creates a presumption in
favor of disclosure that is to say the
scales are already tipped
but we operate in a system now where
um you know I I work with Municipal
lawyers they're great but they're very
talented you know they know all the
exemptions they can raise exemptions and
there's no disincentive to just forcing
a requester to go to court
for the ACLU I mean we you know have
more resources right we're able to say
no we think you're wrong and we can file
the 280 filing fee spend you know the
tens maybe even hundreds of hours doing
it
um because that's our job that's what
we're paid to do
other people don't have that benefit
Miss ortolano who you heard from doesn't
have that benefit
and that I think is why we really do
need to change this law and I really
hope this committee considers
um considers this change because chapter
91a isn't an exemption law even though
there are many exemptions in the statute
it is a transparency law that every
government body that gets a request
should start from that default position
and I fear that we have kind of gone in
another Direction and I think this will
reverse that particular trend
mandatory fee shifting is important
because when a requester successfully
goes to court the requester has brought
a lawsuit that confers a social good not
just for that particular person but for
the community at Large
but without mandatory fee shifting a
member of the public
like Miss ortolano like anyone else who
doesn't have the ability to hire a
lawyer
they're left to weigh the relative value
of the requested records against the
cost of litigation
the result is a of this calculus is that
many successful lawsuits frankly to
remedy a government's violation may not
be brought particularly when you're
dealing with prosely litigants who know
they're going to be faced with a
municipality that has lawyers on
retainer so the result is those lawsuits
aren't brought
the public loses out on important
information
so again I think when you so when we
switch that balance when we create
mandatory fee shifting now a government
body needs to think well if I get if I
get sued and lose I'm going to have to
pay fees so I think they are going to be
more likely and more inclined to produce
the particular information and in fact
some some evidence bears that out and
I've cited that in our testimony in
states that do not have similar fee
shifting Provisions in their public
records laws the financial risk of
litigation is often deterrent to
requesters footnote 2 has some data on
that and agencies in states with
mandatory fee shifting Provisions tend
to demonstrate better compliance with
public records laws as one study has
found findings indicate that states with
higher public records
public records request compliance
include mandatory attorney fee shifting
Provisions in their state laws so that
is really the goal here
I do I do want to note that we actually
used to have this in New Hampshire law
believe it or not
um we had mandatory fee shifting in New
Hampshire by virtue of an amendment to
our public records law back in 1973.
it was then modified in 1977 and then in
1986 we landed in the regime that we
have now which is that you only get
attorneys fees unless the government
body knew or should have known so I do
want to reiterate that there is there is
precedent here in New Hampshire for this
and frankly I think we have now endured
a 30 plus year experiment
with this attorney fee regime and I just
don't think it's been successful
but when we did have this uh this
language this this mandatory fee
shifting back in the in the 70s the
Supreme Court uh said something that I
think is pretty cool and I just think it
really embodies why we need this again
in New Hampshire law and this is a case
from 1976 called Bradbury versus Shaw
I'm just I I hate to just quote things
at length but to me it is very powerful
and demonstrates why I think this is a
good bill
the provision for Award of attorney
speech is critical to securing the
rights guaranteed by the statute without
this provision the statute would often
be a dead letter for the cost of
enforcing compliance would generally
exceed the value of the benefit gained
in some cases the plaintiff May gain a
financial benefit by the invalidation of
government action taken in violation of
the statute but it will frequently be
impossible to place a monetary value on
the interests protected
by the right to no law the attorney fee
provision was enacted in this case 1973
so that the Public's right to know would
not depend on the ability of individuals
to finance litigation
and we lost that in the 80s and again I
would submit that we need to get back to
that there have been some questions
about just um some of the language I
know you had an excellent question your
honor about absent a final judgment but
if a lawsuit compelled information to be
produced would there still be a
requirement for attorney's fees and I
don't think so this language actually
deliberately does not use the Catalyst
Theory so the Catalyst theory is if you
file a lawsuit and it compels the
government to produce something but you
don't yet have a final judgment and some
jurisdictions you may be able to get
attorney's fees not here you need to you
need to go that extra step and get a
final judgment so if you file a lawsuit
if you spend twenty thousand dollars
filing a lawsuit and the government then
decides to produce it you are out of
luck I actually don't think that's ideal
but there's discussion about a middle
ground I actually think this is a middle
ground because one potential proposal
here would be to omit the Judgment
requirement altogether right
um but here that exists and I think that
that is a a middle ground position uh in
my view
I do also want to note
um again I just I said just a few
moments ago you know we've we've lost
we've lost our way over the past 30
years since this language and I just do
want to give some examples
I want to just give a shout out to miss
ortolano who just testified
because
um
I hope it's going to be a just a very I
have 30 seconds and I I want to say
number one other states do this it's in
the last page of my testimony but lastly
in response Miss Orlando didn't say this
but in response to her work in the
months this is from the union leader in
2021. in the months that followed her
disclosures the city ordered the
national city of Nashville ordered a
management audit if it's assessing
Department replaced its longtime Chief
assessor retained a lawyer to
investigate the assessor and was subject
to a review by the State Board of land
and tax appeals that's why our chapter
91a exists for government accountability
we still have examples where the
government is not producing documents
including police records in a case I'm
about to litigate at the Supreme Court
even though the Supreme Court has said
police records for the most part should
be released so I think for all these
reasons I would request that the
committee vote this bill allowed to pass
and I'm sorry for talking for
questions for members of the committee
saying none thank you very much thank
you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for holding this hearing today
uh just for the record my name is Ross
Connolly I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity in New
Hampshire
here to voice our support for HB 307 uh
New Hampshire we really pride ourselves
on the transparent and open nature of
our government every part of our our
government is accessible and open to the
public but as we've heard in recent
years there's uh when it comes to our
91a records uh requests there's been a
suffering of lack of lack of response
and really a timely manner uh and and uh
not as transparent as it should be uh
but this bill provides really a simple
solution as we've heard uh to to bring
more sunlight and into into government
and have more of these these records
requests be be honored and respected
um
so
really what we view this bill it is a
powerful powerful incentive that if a
lawsuit is going to be brought that it's
it's uh respected and taken more
seriously uh when when it's there's
there's skin in the game for both sides
so we we want to make sure that that our
government records are open to the
public people can't access them they're
not being hidden uh because when that
happens people
find distrust in government breeds
conspiracy theories and results in a
very negative view towards government
employees and agencies and we want to
make sure that that is uh not happening
and that uh that the these things are
are brought out in into the the open
because in our mind sunlight is the best
disinfectant uh so for these reasons we
urge the committee to to move this bill
ought to pass and be happy to take any
questions if there are any questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thanks
so much
is there anyone else uh here who wishes
to testify on HB 307 FN
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that and I would like to um I
had recessed the hearing earlier on HB
289 we were looking for representative
Corcoran
um
and I don't see him here I'm concerned
I'm I'm wondering if maybe I could ask
you Mr Walla could you just introduce a
bill and the reason I say that is we
have a witness here Miss Burns
is here I believe
who was going who wanted to testify in
opposition to the bill and I don't so I
don't I think we need to have the
hearing on this bill but I wonder if you
would mind Vice chair just introducing
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
representative Scott Wallace Rockingham
County District 8 the town of Danville
and I'm here to introduce House Bill 289
FN an act relative to consultation with
legal counsel under the right to know
law
this bill prohibits a public official
from retaining legal counsel for the
purpose of evading compliance with the
right to know law and makes violation of
the requirement a misdemeanor
and I'll take no questions all right
thank you very much representative
so
I'm going to call um uh Margaret Burns
I'm going to ask you uh if you'd uh
thank you again I'm Margaret burns with
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
here in opposition to House Bill 289. we
think we understand what the bill means
and that its purpose is to state that a
government official can't hire an
attorney to help them violate the law I
believe that is what the language in the
bill is getting at we agree that a
government official should not hire an
attorney to assist them in violating the
law or that any person should hire an
law and we believe that rule 1.2 of the
rules of professional conduct would
already cover this situation that rule
states that a lawyer shall not consult a
client to engage or to assist a client
in conduct that a lawyer knows is
criminal or fraudulent for this reason
we don't believe this language being
added to this provision of the right to
know law is necessary and would ask that
the committee recommend the bill as in
expedient to legislate thank you
questions yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking our questions isn't the fact that
although some language already exists
and yet the behavior still continues to
occur that clearly something needs to be
done to address the fact that despite
what's in the law
it's still occurring
thank you for the question there are
already serious penalties for
individuals that take action to
intentionally violate the right to know
law or take other actions especially in
their governmental capacity to violate
the law engage in fraudulent or other
misconduct obviously misconduct occurs
in every industry and every faction of
government and I think we would see if
we tried to reiterate and address every
possible piece of misconduct that could
happen we could see an endless edition
of Provisions to the law to put into
place those particular situations that
have occurred so I would suggest that
the law already covers this situation
and it's simply not necessary to put
more language into this provision in the
statute
again I believe I understand the bill to
mean what I think it means
questions yes uh representative Lorenzo
thank you attorney Burns who gets to
decide
um
um it could be as the result of a
criminal prosecution
um it could so in in the situation of
governmental misconduct you could see a
criminal prosecution or you could see a
civil lawsuit being brought and both
could occur for the same conduct
criminal and civil action
it's a follow-up so that would be that
would be um
after the fact correct
that's correct con misconduct would have
to occur for there to be
Crim a criminal proceeding taken against
Defender and I'll call
um
looking to defend their
I don't know I mean
would that be like a violation of the
United States Constitution as far as
point of
I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand the
question I I don't see a constitutional
this bill prohibits a public official
from retaining legal counsel for the
purpose of evading compliance with the
right to no law and makes violation of
the requirement of misdemeanor
I don't know I'm just having a hard time
with this I'm sorry
the bill says that it prohibits
public official for retaining legal
counsel oh I I apologize I see I
understand what you're saying
um I don't think it certainly prohibits
a public official in general from
acquiring legal counsel it is trying to
Target an already improper reason for
retaining an attorney which would be for
illegal purposes
so you know if I could just that raises
am I understanding correctly that
this the
subsection
L that this amends the purpose of that
subsection is to say these are the times
when you don't have to have a public
meeting right and so one of them is if
you're going to talk about something
that you've consulted with Council and
what this is designed to say is if
you've just sort of created when there's
no real reason to be Consulting with
Council but you've just done it so you
can have your meeting in private instead
of in public then you're in trouble then
you're thank you for that clarification
if you do exactly what you just
described you were already violating the
right to know law
um you this is a provision that deals
with consultation with an attorney to
receive legal advice and you can't use
an attorney improperly or for some other
cover to be able to evade the right to
no law so I think that would not only
violate principles relative to rules of
professional conduct but it would
violate another provision of the right
to no law which prohibits local
officials from in looking for ways to
evade compliance with the right to know
law
thank you very much is there anyone else
here who wishes to testify on House Bill
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on 289
um
and we will we've already done 307 so we
will turn to house bill 308.
foreign
good afternoon
I'm
my two colleagues who are going to
testify just went upstairs to testify in
another meeting we understood I know the
whole legislature is busy we understand
so no problem thank you um uh I am
Francis Nutter Upham Hillsboro eight
um this is my third term on Health and
Human Services
I've recently been appointed to the rare
disease Council and it's because of
their meetings that I'm here today
um
I have an amendment
that will replace the former bill
so originally
the 308 bill which you looked at was
broader reaching than just the rare
disease Council and having sat here in
the morning I realized that a house bill
254 covered a lot of the same territory
better
so
um that's why I'm offering this
amendment which would allow
remote Quorum access for the rare
disease Council
there's many reasons that they need to
meet remotely
most importantly is that some of them
have chronic forever rare diseases that
they just cannot be in contact with
other people so we realize that covid
quarantine and contact kind of goes in
and out but some of the the parents or
parents of children with rare diseases
that make up this Council it's just not
really possible for them to come the
committee the council does have a
physical meeting place Hazen drive and
they run you know so it meets that
stipulation if 354 was to pass the
minimum
Quorum requirement was one-third and I
just don't know that it's reasonable for
this committee to be able
Council be able to meet that the
the people on this committee are
um medical researchers doctors up at
Dartmouth Hitchcock and other places
throughout the state that I am grateful
that they're able to give an hour of
their time to come in remotely but to
expect them to take maybe five hours out
of their remarkable schedules to come to
Concord to give a a monthly report is is
not reasonable so I'm willing if there's
something about this amendment that
bugs you or think we could be tweaked
better I'm I'm willing to uh go forward
with that
um
and I just think it's it's an important
it's important medically for our state
that this Council continue to operate
and they haven't been able to vote on
their minutes in over a year
I also have um I'll leave a pile there
but I brought the original Bill about
why the council was formed and for your
reading you would kind it would be
better than me reading it to you so but
I'll leave a file there
so that's
uh Dr kanurk has I think sent you all a
letter and representative Wendy Thomas
also had testimony that she was going to
give so I can ask her to uh
uh yes are you are you ready to take
questions
this seems like a little bit of a
non-germaine Amendment here was the
original intention for
this bill to only Encompass this one
Council
well so
uh office of legislative Services is new
and so when I I mean they're
not the office but many of the new
lawyers on it are new so when I said I'm
I'm looking for a way for this Council
to meet
Quorum and
um they didn't write it narrowly they
wrote it broadly they just wiped out uh
some so my intent
was that
this would cover this Council and if it
was able to cover other councils with
special needs like this that would be
okay
yes thank you um yeah because I think
also the special needs advisory Council
had voiced earlier that they had similar
issues however in looking at this
council's makeup I see that it's made up
of about 11 members and I see that two
of them are House Representatives and
one of them's a member of the Senate and
one of them is a commissioner of the
Department of Health and Human Services
so that would be four of eleven that
would be one-third
that would seem like they would be able
to be present
um the rest of them I could see perhaps
if there's a reason why they couldn't be
but those people there I'm unsure
why on a regular basis that they
wouldn't be able to be in person
the represent well um for instance last
year no appointments were made so we
went a whole year with a missing member
but um the speaker seems to be
um proficient at that this year and and
we're getting the letters about who's
appointed on so that was a problem last
year that may not be a problem this year
um
certainly I'll drive up from Nashua you
know whatever so they haven't appointed
the other uh State Legislature
to this committee yet so but I hear your
point other questions for this one yes
representative Alexander thank you my my
questions kind of um pivoting off the
clerks in the in the question of if it's
if it's only 11 members like what's
stopping the 11 members from meeting in
a socially distant way
um in the New Hampshire house for
instance in the chambers I mean I'm sure
the speaker would be willing to
accommodate there's only two members
that are from the house and one from the
center I'm sure that the 11 members
could use the chamber for purpose of a
meeting well I think socially distant
way right yeah I don't think that's good
enough for some of the ailments that
these people suffer for that that
wouldn't be safe enough even to come
into a public building just wouldn't be
safe enough
um but good point I I hear you
yes I do remember oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
too sorry I do remember this bill from
um last term and the issue was that a
lot of the folks on the council were
very disabled yes and had trouble you
know getting out and so this bill or the
issue was to make an accommodation to
them because of their um inability to
I'm sorry
um did somebody else have a question or
no representative go ahead please
so perhaps I'm a bit confused so I'm
hoping to get clarification what I'm
seeing is that the members are only two
persons living with a rare disease and
then one parent or guardian of a child
with a rare disease the rest are again
legislators or a physician or a nurse
practitioner so I'm only seeing that
less than one-third of those people
would have a rare disease am I looking
at the wrong thing I just wanted to
clarify no I think you're correct but
the other point I made was that it it's
um
to ask one of those doctors to drive two
hours here for an hour meeting and then
what other yes representative Perez
how long has this group been in
existence um 2019
so that was during it came about with
covid
so you really haven't had an option to
meet much together how often do you meet
uh once a month once a month so not
always in the summer I've attended so I
just formally got my letter that I'm on
it last week but I have attended four or
five meetings over the last three years
and approximately how many members have
shown up over these meetings in the past
couple of years uh about eight out of 11
and there's 11 in it yeah okay thank you
thank you yeah other questions for yes
representative Alexander just just
pivoting off that if the eight have
attended the meeting how can you not
vote on minutes before the previous
meetings to vote online
or their interpretation
you've had meetings in person with me no
no they were all on Zoom they're they've
all been on Zoom thank you so if they
were allowed to vote the minutes on Zoom
they would gladly have done so perfect
thank you okay
any other questions so you know yes
representative Tripp
so um this was a public meeting
it can be uh it's noticed in the uh in
our calendar and a public could come
all right so
it being a public meeting there were
no no I think
well I think we had a a visitor by Zoom
but we haven't been in person they've
all been zoomed so we've had visitors
via Zoom attend these meetings all right
so which is encouraged and welcomed
track of my question so I'm gonna be
quiet we have thank you representative
Tripp we have other questions so I I
guess I do
oh yes I'm sorry certainly
so so is this a need of the state
um for these um these people that are uh
disabled and I can't get out is this a
great need for
um you know the constituents you know
out there
that this committee this council is able
to meet
is of great need for everyone
dealing with all kinds of rare diseases
I'm grandmother of a young man with a
rare disease a survivor of an odd cancer
myself
and it's it's so important that um
people doing research are able to talk
to each other and and you know follow up
what's the latest what's coming up what
other states are doing what a it's
crucial that's why they passed this bill
in the first place I mean not my bill
but the bill to form the council
so can I follow up and just say in
um I don't know how this so I'm new to
this but I just want to say could we
make an exception to
um as we discuss things and to go
forward to allow them to have a remote
access if they needed to they cannot
come physically to the meeting that they
could but again well that's kind of what
I'm asking is for uh that the remote
Quorum be
allowed for them because of their
special circumstances and
you know if 254 goes through
we're we're almost covered here except
for maybe the Quorum but if 254 doesn't
go through I need this bill to go
through so that this Council can meet
so
um yeah
as a nurse I'm just I'm concerned as
well so that's I just hearing about this
um any other questions for this witness
so I guess I do have one question I I'm
I'm a little troubled by the idea
I mean that the the bill
before the amendment seem to
seem to be a more General bill that
would allow remote participation and
I
um
I guess I'm I'm a little troubled by the
eye with your proposed amendment would
limit it to just this uh the rare
disease advisory Council and so I'm
wondering
I mean what would be
what would be our justification I mean I
understand you have you have two people
that are on that Council that have that
have some kind of condition but or more
or maybe more but I'm wondering what
would be the basis for uh singling out
that advisory Council I mean if we were
going to pass a law like this wouldn't
we want to make it generally applicable
what if there's you know what if the
board of realtors has uh two people that
are that have are either ill or you know
have some kind of condition or have some
other reason that they couldn't be there
well in a more perfect world I'd be very
happy for that I mean a broader one but
it seemed that I that uh the original
308 would be competing somehow with 254
which seemed more thought out and
um nuanced right so in other words in
other words in my understanding what
you're saying is you may have drafted
the bill to be just for this one board
but you don't have a pro you wouldn't
have a problem if it was made more
General to no all boards no and I I you
know after this morning hearing 254 I
had to make a pivot in the hallway like
when I used to act and somebody gave you
the wrong line from the wrong scene and
you just had to kind of go on with the
scene like all right we're finishing the
play a little early today you know
all right so oh no got it okay any other
questions for this Witness
thank you very much
thank you
uh and I I'm available for you know
rewrites questions you have my number
thank you
Mr chair and members of the committee
and representative Wendy Thomas I
represent Merrimack Hills 12.
I am going to testify in in support of a
general
allowance of of remote meetings uh times
have changed in 2020 we were introduced
to zooms which are remote meetings
very quickly after that we all became
burned out on Zoom meetings but we
realized that remote meetings allowed
less less travel time it allowed parents
to join meetings and it allowed people
who are sick those that don't have much
left in the tank to attend
in 2023 we are finding out that one in
10 people will develop long covid after
exposure to the virus long covid can be
debilitating however people can
participate with accommodations we can
still benefit from their expertise
remote access is no longer a convenient
way for people to participate in
meetings it is now simply a necessity
for much more than one-tenth of our
population to actively participate in
leadership and decision-making
opportunities thank you any questions
for this Witness
saying that up yes representative
Staples yeah thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I'm
sorry but I didn't clearly hear
those Afflicted with covid will develop
a kind of an Affliction it's it's it's
called long covid for lack of a better
word I mean the the medical community is
calling it and that's where um
persistent um symptoms of of the covid
infection
um continue as an example I'll I'll give
my example
um in 2020 in November of 2020
um I was I had a lot I had covid
and
um it it didn't hit my lungs it hit my
gut
um I couldn't taste I couldn't smell I
had no appetite I had no thirst
that persisted for two years
the gut portion at some at some points
became so severe I literally couldn't
leave my house I mean I had to be it's
like that commercial where the people
are looking for the bathroom
it's it's gotten a lot better A lot
better but it's but I had it for two
years
unfortunately where I work they're very
they allowed me to work remotely and to
participate you know remotely and that
that saved my job
so I mean that's work is a different
issue from this this is this is
attending meetings but we're going to
have to be very aware that that one
tenth of our population is going to be
disabled because of covet
thank you for that explanation you're
welcome any other questions for this
Witness
thank you very much thank you
um uh former representative Jerry
nerkner he's upstairs
all right well let me go on then uh
good afternoon again
um
right to know New Hampshire is opposed
to HB 308 I will admit I'm trying to
catch up on the Amendments that are here
so I'm going to speak to the original
Bill and to the extent that I'm able to
with the Amendments again we recognize
the advantages that remote access has
provided to engage citizens and and
reiterate that there are challenges that
have not been addressed in terms of how
to conduct remote meetings both for
members of the public body and attendees
in their presence as well so much of my
prior testimony on HB 254 applies
regarding the kinds of safeguards that
we feel need to be put into place I did
have the privilege of speaking with
representative Nutter Upham and I
understand that the motivation from this
bill comes from a sincere desire to make
participation in Statewide meetings
easier for committed volunteers and
stakeholders who wish to contribute and
to conduct business the body she
represents does face some unique
challenges and just as an added
background on myself I have a master's
in public health and was doing pandemic
planning as far back as 2004 and using
the term social distancing law before
anybody else probably in this room
I'm very much an advocate for the use of
remote technology and have been
self-employed and using that for a long
time but this proposal as it currently
stands in 308 in the original version
really does remove a lot of the guard
rails that are currently in place with
the deletion that it suggests most
notably the need for a physical meeting
location which is now added back into
the amendment which is why it's getting
a little bit confusing
but some of the other issues that need
to be addressed when we're talking about
remote meetings include having a
mechanism for managing problems with
Public Access having a trigger for
stopping the public meeting if the
public can't access it and what that is
and the ability to define the record the
recording as a public record currently
minutes of a meeting officially
constitute the public record and the
video may or may not be made available
to a citizen there's no guarantee that
in the course in the case of a fully
remote meeting which could easily be
recorded that the official record will
include the recording of the meeting or
the chats associated with the remote
meeting as part of that public record
there are a lot of questions about those
kinds of technical issues that are still
floating around out there
as far as the original bill goes and I
realize there's a change in the
application all proposed changes to 91a
should consider whether or not they make
meetings or information more or less
accessible to the public overall and not
in specific cases while Statewide
meetings may be a particular challenge a
change like this if made to 91a would
make it possible for local Boards of
seleckman for example to meet entirely
remotely and that would dramatically
change the participatory nature of local
governance so
I would say that this amendment makes it
a little bit clearer that there's a
reason that it's being applied only to
the rare diseases Council but I will say
that rights into New Hampshire is very
aware of the difficulty that comes in
enforcing something like 91a when you
have discrete
um
changes to the law that apply in very
specific cases and aren't applied
broadly across the board consistently
and transparently and I think that that
would be an issue that our body would
raise if I were to bring this amendment
to them we will be talking about that on
Saturday
um
because of those changes I just want to
take a look at this
or
a couple of the other things that we
think are important that virtual access
should be provided and the information
about that should be provided within the
meeting notice
and that
there should be a oh so and if during
the meeting a member of the body informs
the public body that there's process a
problem with that access those problems
should be stated in the minutes as well
so that it's documented that there was
an issue with somebody gaining access to
it and those are a couple of pieces that
right to know has identified as key to
being able to put together truly
accessible public publicly remote
meetings so again like with 254 we would
urge you today to oppose this bill is
inexpedient to legislate what we really
need is an overarching guidance on
remote meetings that applies across the
board and if there needs to be a
particular exception
maybe to the Quorum requirement in the
case of the rare diseases Council maybe
that one piece could be something that's
put out there as an alternative but
tomorrow we would like to be able to
have that conversation and put something
that's more comprehensive together
questions representative Tripp
uh
in uh being able to uh
justify not attending the meeting
somebody wants an exception one of the
things that the uh the sponsor said was
that well it's just too much bother for
the for the doctor to drive two hours
each way do you figure that that would
I think that that puts
much of much of the volunteers that are
involved in in supporting these kinds of
bodies between a rock and a hard place
we want them to participate we want to
make that easier for them and we want
their input I think we need to find a
middle ground for them to be able to do
it I
I don't know what that is
but I do think that it is important and
right to know has stressed repeatedly
when it comes to remote meetings that
there needs to be a physical meeting
location with a quorum in the room where
the members of the public have the
ability to interact with members of the
public body as much as possible that
interaction is important being able to
read body language being able to see the
screen not simply have someone be
audible it's very different if I say to
you I agree and roll my eyes than it is
if if all you hear on the over the audio
line is I agree
all right other question yes
representative Horgan
um
just on the other hand you're I mean
you're very concerned about uh
things being said which aren't on the
official record but
it's not also a problem with an
in-person meeting people are having
discussions that aren't you know like in
front of the microphone or in the main
room and of course also
this is as much right to know New
Hampshire but other other groups have
also been against remote meetings
because that doesn't get a chance to
physically confront the officials in
person that certainly can lead to
unofficial dialogue that's not part of
the official programs question is there
a question yeah
so is
so you feel like there's more more
chance for like uh unauthorized off
back Channel conversations in a zoom
meeting than there is an in-person
meeting
so
I feel that if I'm sitting in this room
and you all are in front of me I can see
what the body language is between one
representative and another
representative I can tell that you guys
aren't under your table texting at each
other and even so there's there's a
level of
understanding the um the interaction
that's happening do side conversations
happen yes if there's side conversations
that are happening over and zoom chat is
one of those kind of sticking points
with remote meetings they're happening
on a publicly funded system for a public
meeting where people are having side
conversations then yeah those should be
part of the public record if you step
outside and speak with someone in the
hallway that's that's a different thing
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you
uh now let me go back uh representative
uh Jerry can Eric here all right so he's
not here
um I'm gonna we have other business so
I'm gonna close the hearing on this
matter I like I should say is there
anyone else here we wishers to testify
representative has written testimony he
can submit it oh of course yes yes yes
absolutely he did oh he did yeah we had
no we have we do have them we do have a
letter from him yes
um or a memo I would I should say
um are any other Witnesses on HB 308
all right not seeing any I'm gonna turn
then uh to uh house bill
thank you
and the committee calls representative
yokella
thank you uh members of the Judiciary
Committee for the record my name is
representative Joshua Kella uh
representing rocking M32 Fremont
um I'm here introducing uh my bill HB
321 which
seeks to clarify the law or 91a
regarding
um non-public meeting minutes and the
kind of review process and how those get
considered to be
um
subject to public disclosure
right now the law
as it is states that
um these meeting minutes are subject to
public disclosure
um when the body finds that the uh
that the conditions for which they were
were kept from the public no longer
apply and so that assumes that they're
making some decision at some time to
um
to uh
that that one that the conditions are
not forever and two that they need to be
reviewed so that they can um
be subject to public disclosure
and right now
a lot of uh communities because there is
no set guidance for how that occurs it
has fallen by the wayside and that
um especially for someone like me who is
on a board but was not there when the
board was
um instituted I do not know all of the
times that it went into public meeting
non-public meetings and then sealed
those minutes because prior to
this year there was no list of those
meeting minutes
that have been sealed and so
as a board member
um trying to film fulfill my duties to
ensure that the meeting minutes that are
kept from the public are being reviewed
and an unsealed win or subject to public
disclosure
um when appropriate is
um
requires
some negotiation on the board because
there is no clear
um
empowerment by even individual board
member to go and find those non-public
meeting minutes
um and review them and so
what this uh Bill hopes to do is to
create a kind of a guard rails and
encourage boards to make a procedure for
this
so what the proposed language does is
say that you can adopt a procedure that
goes into the um this process for the
regular review
and to vote on the whether or not the
circumstances no longer apply but if you
don't have
um
uh
such a procedure then it is uh the
determination would be that every that
you should review them every 10 years at
least every 10 years and so that is kind
of an outside like obviously you should
probably review them more often than
that but it's kind of just setting up
guard rails and saying this is a
reasonable a reason you can pick
whatever time frame that you want one
year two years five years seven years
even 10 years
um and that the the legislature views as
a reasonable regular review but if
you're doing it every 50 years that
doesn't necessarily
um
constitute a regular review of these um
sealed meaning minutes and so
this uh this bill was uh worked with
with in consultation with the right to
know New Hampshire and with the
municipal Association because the
municipal Association actually does
encourage and recommend to the
municipalities now that they have these
regular reviews
um but and they do encourage people to
or they would like to encourage the um
the legislature to be more clear about
this issue and how this process should
occur and so
um that is why the impetus for this
legislation
came from so I'm happy to answer any
questions
representative Perez thank you so
there's nothing in place now that says
they have to review these at all and
thank you for the question it is implied
by the language of of 91a that that
there would be a vote to determine
whether the circumstances no longer
apply but there is no guidance for a
time frame or that any requirement that
they have a process at all right now so
it's kind of the Wild Wild West and so
we're just falling by the wayside
because it's not required
foreign
why was the 10 years picked
thank you for uh the question and as I
was stating before
um it was kind of the idea is that we
don't want to be burdensen on the local
municipalities and say you have to do it
every single year otherwise it's going
to be
um because maybe they have a lot of
minutes and they need a time to review
them or whatever and
um
uh so it's kind of a discussion uh
between right to know in New Hampshire
which I'm sure would prefer it every
year and even municipality in the nhma
would encourage uh people these boards
to do it every year but
is that reasonable that every single
board in the entire state
have that same thing I think that's
maybe a little bit too strict
um is five years too long maybe maybe
not I was trying to just say what is a
reasonable amount of time and and allow
the municipalities to choose a time
frame that makes sense for them
as long as it's within this reasonable
amount of time of 10 years but I'm
obviously
I have sponsored a bill a few years ago
that was very very much more strict and
so it died and so I wanted to be more uh
inclusive to everyone's uh perspective
on how regularly they could review this
and
um not fall short of the law so thank
you
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I noticed at the end of the bill the
judicial Department of Justice states
there are a number of public bodies
attached to the Department of Justice as
this might create a burden
also when it comes to municipalities and
school districts etc etc is there any
type of information available
as to
how often they seal records because like
I know I go to my school district
meetings school meetings every month I
have them for about nine years now I've
never known them to seal non-public
so I was just curious
thank you for the question
um
I believe that the you know Department
of Justice needs to comply with 91a just
like everyone else and so
um if it's you know if the so the only
people that are able to seal
or or keep minutes from the public are
are boards that
so I'm not exactly sure what which
boards are in the Department of Justice
and and how often they're stealing stuff
I don't there's no reason that they
couldn't make a motion to see reseal all
like a entire slate of meeting minutes
in one motion so I'm not sure it would
actually be
um
i i a burden if they now under 91a
um the recent change they have to create
a list of the meeting minutes and so
they already have a list so they know
which meeting minutes need to be sealed
and when they were last voted to be
sealed and so they could just go to that
list and say hey I would like to make a
motion to see it reseal all these
meaning minutes
um and it would not take any specific
you know length of time and so I'm I
think that
um I kind of discount that uh that it
would cost a you know any particular
board a large amount of time necessarily
but I do think that they need to have a
procedure for that and
um as far as your other question as far
as how often boards seal minutes it is
different between each board and now
that we have this requirement that they
keep a list you may find that some
boards like budget committee or zoning
board don't do it
ever and selectmin do it at every
meeting and so it's you may you may um
uh go to your local municipality and get
that list and find out who is going into
non-public and and sealing minutes and
that will be uh the best probably way
for you to know in your municipality
whether who is utilizing that that
functionality
I noticed in the title of your bell
that it states meeting minutes not
reviewed after 10 years shall be made
public but then I don't actually see
that in the bill and I was wondering
if the intention wasn't to have that in
there if that was a mistake
and then I guess as a follow-up to that
that if the intent was to have that in
there
um would you be amenable to adding
something about unless otherwise
unlawful for example I wouldn't want a
school board meeting minutes relative to
a specific child to be
automatically released just because the
school board hadn't had time to review
well I thank you for the question I
believe 10 years is plenty of time to
review but
um
regarding your other statement about
whether or not
um things would automatically be subject
to public disclosure if they weren't
following that that is specifically
stated in line nine
um
uh they need to vote to determine
whether or not uh the circumstances no
longer apply
um more if if it's been more than 10
years
um
otherwise they would be subject to
public disclosure so they need to vote
or it's automatically going to be
subject to public disclosure and then
um
also I in in lines uh 9 through 12 I'm
in I'm
making sure that this becomes uh
retroactive over the next 10 years that
they have 10 years to review and find
those minutes that they currently uh
may not be part of a list or whatever so
that they can go back have that time to
gather the previous
um
meeting minutes so that nothing is being
like fallen through the cracks
representative Church
yeah thanks representative
um
uh I guess I have two questions but let
me let me start with one I think you
clarified it
um in in your previous answer
um there's no specific requirement of
what a review constitutes and
and
um it would be acceptable for a board to
just make a decision that we're just
keeping this sealed without doing any
specific type of of examination of
the contents is that is that your
understanding or intent
thank you for the question
um
my intention is not to micromanage the
boards as to encourage them to have a
process if when they review it it is
inapprop in an appropriate inappropriate
process then that will be done at a
public meeting that is transparent to
the public and therefore they can be
voted
um out if appropriate and so I I think
that you know that they can have any
review process if if it's appropriate
that you have a giant list and you say
I'm gonna I'm motion that we reseal all
of this that you know every every uh
meeting minutes on this list for the
next 10 years
and that is appropriate for their uh you
know their municipality I'm fine with
that I don't I just want there to be a
process in place so that it's that it's
happening
can I ask one thing it's I don't know if
it's a follow-up specific it may be a
different question sure when when you're
talking about
uh voting on these minutes my
understanding if you go into non-public
you can discuss multiple non-public
things in one in one session would it be
possible this is Am I Wrong I'd be happy
to be wrong on that I I thought that you
could
do that and and I was curious whether or
not you could unseal part of
a set of minutes if some of it needed to
stay and some of it didn't
thank you for the question I definitely
think it's a different question
um the the the the
um
you can go into non-public so there's
there's two kind of sections of law
regarding non-public
um and and the ceiling of non-public so
there's there's uh
the statement kind of in public session
for the reasons why you're going into
non-public session and then you could
theoretically you could list whatever
and however many of those that you want
to be able to discuss in non-public and
as long as they are covered under the
non-public heading I don't think you
have to come back out and go in for
another discussion under a different
topic I don't believe that that is the
intention of or the practice of current
law and then there's another part of the
law that says that you can keep you make
a determination after that after you've
come out of non-public
you need to make it you can make a
determination about certain situations
which is a delimited list of the entire
list of the reasons why you go into
non-public that allow you to keep the
meeting minutes of that non-public sep
from the public and so you so it's not
exactly the same list
of reasons that you can keep things from
the public as that you can go into
non-public those are two separate lists
and um
so yes I guess there is
um you can go in for multiple reasons I
believe is my understanding and
um however I don't know of
uh
situation contemplated in the law where
you would be able to unseal part of the
minutes
of the non-public meeting minutes I
think it just says you're either you've
there's something in there that you
don't want to disclose and therefore it
needs to be kept from the public you
have to just make it it's more of a
binary Choice than a like line by line
we're gonna you know strike out this
line kind of a thing thank you
representative
okay
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
absolutely is it true that uh the body
has to be in public session before it
can make a motion to go into non-public
or one of the reasons in 91
a colon 3 2 a through J and that they
have to return to public sessions before
they conceal the non the non-public
minutes
yes
uh do you feel that most boards are
aware of this and and practice this
thank you for the question
um whether or not they follow the law
that is
um I'm not aware of all of the
municipalities
um
uh
in their boards uh knowledge and
practice of the lives
hopefully
they are
other questions thank you for this week
yes representative D Lorenzo thank you
Mr there and thank you for taking my
question representative yokella you know
I'm I'm reading this
um
proposed Bill and it sounds like
the bill
requires public bodies to release by
thank you for the question
um I think that that is a very broad
statement and I do believe that even the
CIA is not allowed to uh seal minutes
indefinitely they can only seal minutes
for like up to 75 years and then they
have to review them again and reseal
them and so you can't I don't believe
that they're um that anything at the
local level rises to the level of of you
know National Secrets as far as that is
concerned and so I don't believe that we
should go you know as far as that so I
do think that you know even you know who
killed GF JFK might eventually become
you know public record
play it's all up yes so um
and my thought is you know it's a 10
year every 10-year process right who's
going to remember 10 years from now that
they have to um
thank you for the question
um as I stated before I definitely would
encourage them to do a much more
frequent basis however under the new law
there is a unknown public meeting
minutes on the list that is required to
be kept it is it is said when it was the
date of the meeting and when the date of
the ceiling happened so there's going to
be a list of so you would know
other questions for this I'm sorry other
questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much
representative thank you representative
Rebecca uh McWilliams
or MC Willett
Williams mcwillis I'm not sure
The Story of My Life Mick Williams M.C
uh thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Rebecca McWilliams I represent South
Concord Wards 5678 you're sitting in one
it's a pleasure to have you in my ward
thanks for coming
um I'm here to also support this very
good bill this is a very small change
but I think it's a very needed change
just to clarify what otherwise the
courts would have to clarify in terms of
a reasonable period of time and so we're
putting a number on it we're putting 10
years that's a reasonable period of time
so if you go 11 years that's an
unreasonable period of time I think it's
really important that we do that as
legislators to put a pin in it if we
don't it leaves things subjective and
potentially subject to lawsuits where we
all Dicker about it spend lots of money
fighting over public meeting minutes in
a court when
we as legislators could simply put a
number on it make it very clear so
that's one of the reasons I support this
bill I think we do need this bill
um certainly there are all kinds of
interesting Concord school meeting
minutes that I would love to see at some
point and so setting a 10-year clock
from now for me personally and for my
constituents would be a good thing
um and so I'm I'm happy to answer
questions but I'm here to say yes please
put a pin in it
questions for this Witness
um
thank you your honor
and this will be the last time you have
to hear from me today
um right to know New Hampshire strongly
supports HB 321 it requires a review
process for minutes that are withheld
from the public and this occurs under a
process that's commonly referred to as
sealing the minutes which can be done
under any of three specific exemptions
that apply to the contents of those
minutes when that happens under 91a3
Roman numeral three the law says
information may be withheld until in the
opinion of a majority of members the
afore said circumstances no longer apply
although 91a3 Roman numeral 3 implies
the existence of a review process to
decide whether or not those
circumstances apply most towns do not
have one the fact that the fact is that
that there's no historical record of
non-public minutes that were sealed and
the reasons why further complicates and
informs citizens ability to review
potentially relevant materials a recent
amendment to 91a that was mentioned by
representative yokella now requires that
listing of non-public minutes beginning
in January of 2022 and has changed the
process moving forward this is very much
for the good but the historical record
remains barred to public review and for
the most part if the minutes were sealed
in 2015 and 2005 or in 1995 they remain
sealed and without review
there was some questions from a few
members of this group about what the
practices are so I can speak to some of
my experience until very recently the
practice in my hometown of Milford seems
to have been to consider almost every
non-public session to result in sealed
meeting minutes those meeting minutes
were often sealed incorrectly on the
basis of the reason for going into
non-public session and not one of the
three legal reasons that you actually
are allowed to seal the minutes that has
since been corrected in part because I
have raised the issue and raised it very
loudly
I have personally had the experience of
combing through several years worth of
past select board agendas to identify
when those non-public sessions that had
been scheduled may have occurred I then
requested those minutes of the not
scheduled non-public sessions and when I
was told that certain minutes were
sealed I asked that they'd be reviewed
for possible unsealing I was told by
administrative staff not the members of
the public body that there was at that
point no reason for the remaining ones
to be unsealed at the time my request
was not escalated to the board level for
a review process
after some back and forth I understand
that they now have a review process
mapped out but to my knowledge
it has yet to take effect and applies
primarily only to the prior Year's worth
of minutes and I have not con but I have
not confirmed all the details of that
just yet I do not know what will happen
when I begin asking for some of the
older materials as background to one of
the two or three key issues that I like
to follow in my community
this bill does not create an undue
burden on a public body it provides
considerable leeway by letting them
determine what their own process is it
sets a minimum threshold of time for
reviewing and confirming the status of
the sealed minutes moving forward and it
gives an exceptionally long period of
time for retroactive review of the
historical record before making it
mandatory to release unreviewed
materials if the public body is
concerned about information getting out
that might be sensitive it now has an
entire decade to decide how it wants to
manage that and I know that
representative yokella provided one sort
of quicker way to try to deal with some
of the issues I think part of the
challenge will be
the and the advantage to it will be that
the communities will have to account for
what minutes they currently have sealed
that are not available to the public and
they now have 10 years to figure that
out
the bill also does not require or create
a new requirement under 91a3 public
bodies should routinely be reviewing
their minutes for information that may
be opened up to the public it simply
hasn't been happening because 91a
doesn't specify any requirements around
that activity this language essentially
operationalizes an existing requirement
by doing so it's meeting its
responsibility to only withhold
information for as long as necessary and
the public itself will gain access and
informed insight into its own history
questions for them to take questions
thank you
yes representative Tripp thank you chair
thank you for taking my question uh I'm
sure you heard me ask representative
yukela uh if he thought that the the
boards follow uh or are even aware of
the requirements of RSA 91a
so I think that the boards do the best
that they can to navigate those
requirements I think there is a
tremendous need for Education around
what is really involved my board was
coming out of non-public and was not
doing the additional step that you said
about taking that vote in public but
once it was made clear that that needed
to happen and that they need to provide
the reason for stealing the minutes when
they decide to do that they've now
started to do that
there's a huge need for Education around
this at the local level
follow-up question please yes uh are you
aware that the land use boards had to
get annual training
you probably not
not specifically the land use boards but
I do believe I've seen something related
to other other boards yes one more yep
do you think that maybe uh it would be a
good idea to amend the bill to put uh
RSA 91a training annual in this bill
thank you for that question
representative Tripp I should have been
thanking all of you for your questions
all along too I apologize this is my
first time testifying on behalf of the
organization
um
absolutely I feel that not only should
local elected officials be trained in
91a effectively and that that is a lack
in my local community that I have tried
to push them to remedy but that also the
administrative staff should be trained
as well because most of the time they
are not I was in court with my town and
our town not administer executive
administrator admitted that she had had
no training prior to she had been
advised by legal counsel as to what to
do and actually stated that after after
being advised by legal counsel and then
um we hired a different legal counsel
she's since learned that that was
incorrect so the accountability and and
being able to have people trained and
understand what they need to do is is
tremendous
thank you other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much oh I'm
sure I'm sorry representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
that's what you what you announced
sounded like a rather
um circular administrative obfuscation
um the the minutes are sealed and we see
no reason to unseal them
well what files what follows from there
can you make a request to the board or
the council
put it on the agenda for a review of
those minutes in absence of the law what
could you do now right so so if I had
chosen to pursue that particular issue
which at the time I did not I could have
brought it to the board and asked them
to please put it on the agenda you are
correct however there were other issues
involved in those minutes and we did end
up in court having some of those minutes
reviewed in camera to determine whether
or not they should be released so the
review process was secondary to what my
initial objective was at the time thank
you yep other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you you know and I'm sorry we've gone
through no no I'm I was just going to
make an announcement I've we've gone
through so many Margaret Burns have you
already testified or
and if you haven't then we want to hear
you feel like I've already testified and
I understand why
um I'm Margaret Burns of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and we
are here in support of house bill 321.
we believe that house bill 321 clarifies
existing law so RSA 91a3 implies that
public bodies are supposed to do some
sort of review of non-public session
minutes to determine whether the reason
they were sealed in the first place
still applies but it gives no real
guidance on that or says anything
further about what that means and what
public bodies should do in order to be
in compliance with that in RSA 91a3 so
the first sentence of House Bill 321
would do something we think public
bodies already should do and have the
ability to do but it would clarify that
by stating that they can adopt a policy
or a protocol to do this kind of review
and determine if non-public session
minutes should be made public or if the
reason for their ceiling should remain
and then the remaining sentences of this
particular bill would put in place sort
of a baseline or a fallback if a public
body does not put in place a process so
that there is some sort of standard for
review
and making non-public session minutes
public I I do appreciate the question
that was asked earlier about the last
sentence of the bill which says if the
review is not done within 10 years then
those non-public session minutes will
become automatically public I suppose
there could be a scenario where I think
the example given was was a student type
situation or some other highly sensitive
situation and we would not want to
penalize the subject of the minutes by
making those non-public session minutes
automatically available just because the
public body did not do its
responsibility of reviewing those
non-public session minutes
um that's a potentially narrow situation
that could happen from passage of this
bill
there was also a question earlier I just
wanted to try to address about how
boards are support public bodies and
boards are supposed to decide whether
minutes should continue to be withheld
from the public Our advice has always
been that when they do a review of
non-public session minutes they need to
determine whether the circumstances
under which they were sealed still apply
so as referenced earlier there are only
a few specific reasons for which
non-public session minutes can actually
be so-called sealed and when the public
body is doing that review if those
circumstances still apply then the
non-public session minutes can remain
non-public but if the circumstances no
longer apply then there would not be a
valid reason for those non-public
session minutes to remain not public and
as representative yokella said nhma has
been advising public bodies to adopt a
process for reviewing and sealing
unsealing or at least reviewing
non-public sessions for years and it's
included in our book on the right to no
law as well as our trainings on the
right to know law so we hope that this
will help clarify if passed thank you
questions yes representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair and thank you
Margaret for um answering Ms Burns for
answering my question
um so is it my understanding that nhma
um conducts annual training
um with their members to make sure that
all local boards are up to date on what
the current laws are so that they would
understand that if there was you know
minutes in there for 10 years they would
know that they'd have to vote to seal
them or not and you currently keep them
up to date on laws that are passed by
the general court yes we conduct
multiple annual trainings on the right
to know law it's our most popular
subject and are probably our most needed
subject and we also try to do a training
shortly after the end of the legislative
session specifically on the right to
know law to make sure they know what's
been passed because sometimes there can
be a very small change to the right to
no law that can have a big impact on the
way that they're operating and it's very
hard for local officials to keep up to
date on their own with changes that
happen at the legislature
other questions for this witness yes
representative Tripp thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
do you provide this training to school
board members school boards cannot be
members of nhma our bylaws allow cities
towns Village districts Regional
planning commissions and counties to be
members of nhma there is a separate
Association just like us but for schools
the New Hampshire school boards
Association and they do provide right to
no law training
I'm surprised thank you other questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
and may I ask you is there anyone else
here who wishes to testify on HB 321
seeing none I will close the hearing on
HB 321 and I will turn the chair over to
representative Wallace because I'm a I'm
okay
foreign
and we'll now open the public hearing on
House Bill 347 FN
and representative Lynn you've got the
floor but I will need a pink card
afterwards oh of course yes I will get
you one for sure sorry about that
um thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm here to testify in support
of HB uh
347 which would uh which proposes to
establish a superior court land use
review docket
um
this bill
um there was a similar bill that was
introduced
um last term by me I believe I mean it
didn't I believe it went to uh interim
study if I'm not if I'm not mistaken
representative I think it went to
interim study but I could be wrong on
that it went to interim study I believe
at your request
was it at my request well I didn't think
it was but but yet you might maybe
something came up that that I didn't
that I'm not remembering now but I
I'm sure your memory is more maybe it
was one of your other bills
it might have been yeah and yes in fact
I think I'll I'll talk to you about that
I think it was but anyway
um this really this bill would authorize
the creation of a superior court uh land
you stock it
um the jurisdiction of that docket would
be all land use appeals from local land
use ports and you'll notice that in the
bill uh there's a there's a specific
provision it says it does not the the
jurisdiction of the docket would not
cover appeals from State agencies even
if they could be considered in some
sense land use
even if they have some land use Jersey
so for example appeal from the uh
Department of Environmental Services as
an example would not uh be subject to
the land you stock and it's it's limited
to uh Municipal
um
uh land use
agencies
it proposes that the governor uh with
and Council would appoint the first
Justice of the Superior Court uh that
would handle that would be assigned to
that docket uh who must be a person that
is knowledgeable in land use and
property law and that it would give the
Chief Justice of the Superior Court
um the if it turned out that more than
one Justice was needed for that for to
to manage the docket the Chief Justice
of the Superior Court would have the
authority to assign other Superior Court
judges to uh the docket
um
the other thing I would note here and
I'm sure there may be questions about
this one which I'm happy to address is
um as you I'm all uh I'm sure are all
aware we uh in 2019 the legislature
created the housing appeals board
it's important to note that this uh that
the docket of this proposed Superior
Court land use socket would not be
limited to housing appeals in other
words the housing appeals board is only
concerned with housing development so if
there's a commercial somebody wants to
you know put in a new commercial
building somewhere the housing appeal
board now under current law does not
have jurisdiction over that it just goes
to the regular Superior Court appeals
process this Superior Court land use
docket would cover all land use appeals
whether it was commercial development or
housing develop
the purpose of the docket is to
consolidate
all cases involving land use matters
before a single judge who is somebody
that's knowledgeable in that area who
would devote his or her time
exclusively if necessary but certainly
substantially to hearing these cases and
the idea would be to speed up the
process to ensure sort of more
consistency
um
uh which is really kind of important as
I think we all know we have uh there is
a housing uh housing shortage in New
Hampshire uh particularly a housing
shortage for affordable housing and this
is designed uh to one of the things that
that
um we hear a lot is that
um developers uh are discouraged because
the process that that
um currently exists if you need to
appeal uh through uh the Superior Court
the regular superior court docket can
take a long time and you know somebody
who who spent I spent 18 years as a
superior court judge I did a lot of of
these land use cases and um it you know
it's those even though the the current
law says the cases are supposed to be
given priority on the docket there are a
lot of statutes that say you know the
courts shall give priority on the docket
and obviously under the Constitution the
Superior Court handles criminal cases
those have to get first priorities so
the the reality is that in the Superior
Court in the regular docket uh land use
cases can take a while they uh and I
think that's the idea of this is to try
to um
to speed things up so to speak
and you'll note that the law
specifically provides that the time
limits it sets time limits it says that
the structuring conference in um in
these kinds of cases is to occur within
30 days
the hearing has to occur within 60 days
of the time that the record is provided
and just so you understand what that
well typically what happens is let's say
a planning board or a zoning board case
in the before municipality
they they will develop a record of their
proceedings what you know what kind of
hearings were were held who said what
what are the plans that were submitted
that kind of thing that constitutes the
record uh sometimes that can involve
creating uh getting a transcript of what
happened of testimony that was presented
at hearings not always but sometimes and
if that has to be if the transcript has
to be prepared that that takes some time
So eventually there will be a record of
what happened in the before the zoning
or planning board and that will be pres
that will be turned over to the Superior
Court
um the uh the this this proposed statute
says that the hearing has to be held
within 60 days of the time the record is
turned over to the superior court and
then a decision by the court has to be
made within 60 days of the time it holds
um a hearing on the matter uh now there
is a there is a good cause exception as
there is in many statutes if the if the
uh if they're uh if there's a specific
reason why things can't be resolved in
60 days the court can grant an extension
for good cause shown but if it's if if
the court does it for that reason it has
to articulate
it can't just be like you know good
cause challenge extension the court has
to articulate what exactly is the good
cause that justifies the extension
um I would note
um that um
this this proposal is modeled on uh
another Superior Courts uh sort of
special docket the business court docket
that this legislature passed God it's
it's over 10 years ago I mean it's it's
probably more like 15 years ago
um where where business cases were
Consolidated before
um a a uh a single Superior Court Judge
who was again in the same sort of
fashion that this proposes was initially
appointed by uh the governor
in the usual fact in the usual fashion
that appointment was made by uh Governor
Lynch when uh the first business court
judge
um some of you may know him rich rich
McNamara was a very prominent lawyer and
New Hampshire was appointed as the first
business court judge and served until he
until he until he reached age 70 and uh
retired and he was I believe you know I
think he was I Know Rich very well he's
an it was an excellent judge shouldn't
have had to retire but he did uh but he
did an excellent job uh as as the
business court judge and I think uh that
I think if you asked
um you know the overwhelming majority of
lawyers in the state was the business
Court a success they would say it was he
was uh he was you know had a very great
interest in that area really sort of
intellectual kind of guy did just an
excellent job and so
um I have no reason to believe that we
wouldn't have the same kind of thing
happen
with the with the land you stock it I
should note that the governor is a
strong supporter of this uh of this bill
um thinks it's uh you know it's a it's a
very worthwhile thing to do
um and so I hope you'll I hope you'll
support it and I'm happy to answer any
questions that anybody may have
representative kuta
so would this bill replace the hab or
would the hab still be in place no
that's a very good excellent question
um it would not replace the hab and
um at least not now
um I I at least and and my inclination
would be I think this will be a really
good addition to the Superior Court
um and it and it may be that five years
from now or ten years from now if the
you know this was the uh uh land use
Docket in the superior court is up and
running and it's running just you know
swimmingly like we like I expected it
would be it might be at that point that
the legislature would say well wait a
minute you know for housing appeals we
have sort of two Alternatives you can go
to the land you stock it in the superior
court or you can go to the hab why do we
really need to have two alternative uh
appeal Vehicles let's get rid of the hab
because the superior court docket is
working so well
I would and that may make perfect sense
to do that the only thing I would a
caveat I would say on that just so you
understand we do have and we have had
for
God I think it's got to be close to 50
years we have had alternative appeal
mechanisms in in a similar type of case
and what I'm talking about is
the board of tax and land appeals that
board which has been in existence for as
I say about 50 years at least maybe more
that handles appeals from property tax
assessments that you know at the local
level and also from eminent domain if
there's been an eminent if there's an
eminent domain taking
um you haven't you as a person who is
the subject of that you don't like your
tax assessment or you think that you
know your property's being improperly
taken by the state uh you can either
appeal to the board of tax and land
appeals or you can appear appeal to the
Superior Court they both have
jurisdiction and in either case if you
don't like the result you get from
either the board or the Superior Court
you can appeal to the Supreme Court so
if this docket were passed we would have
the same kind of situation you'd have
that you could go to the if it was a
residential development
um the you know the person the party
agreed from the decision of a local land
use board could go either to the hab or
to the Superior Court
um uh and you know as an alternative and
I guess I I would say you might you know
one of the things you might say is well
isn't that really on you know isn't it
isn't the board of tax on land appeals
situ mechanism
um sort of duplicatives does it cost you
know does it cost more money than it
should why do we have these two Avenues
of appeal and those are all very valid
questions when I was on the Supreme
Court we asked those questions a lot uh
but the reality is we didn't really see
that anybody was complaining about this
being duplicative or that the btla
wasn't doing its job in these kind of
cases or that the superior you know
which should be only the superior court
or only the btla they seem to work
together you know the parties there were
not there were not fights as far as the
Supreme Court could see uh between
litigants over you know well we should
go here pressures go there it just seem
both both bodies seem to do their job
and so I it might be that five years
from now if we pass this bill that would
be the same situation with the hab and
follow up
so to make sure I'm understanding
correctly where this isn't replacing
have you could either use have or the
superior land this new Superior land use
court but how would it work with appeals
if you had used Hab would you first
appeal to this court or could you go
directly to the Supreme Court how would
that how would this change that yeah no
you you from either the hab or this
docket or this this you know the
Superior Court land you stock it you
could go directly to the Supreme Court
you wouldn't have to go
from the have to the superior court and
then to the Supreme Court it would be a
direct appeal from either have or the
Superior Court directly to the Supreme
Court
representative Alexander thank you
adding off of the clerk's question it is
the applicants
um option to pursue the hab or the land
use docket depending on it's their
choice where that case goes exactly yes
yes it would be their choice
representative Tripp
thank you Mr Vice chair
thank you for taking my question uh just
how many of these land use dockets would
there be
well I think there'd be quite a I I
can't give you a number man more than
one oh yeah definitely more uh Mr head
is here
um he may be able to he may have those
numbers I don't I I can say that you
know when I was on the Superior Court
there I mean in in 18 years on the
superior court I did
quite a number of land use appeals over
that time in various counties where I
sat I I can't put a number on it but it
was you know it was a pretty substantial
number of of cases
follow-up so there would be more than
since there's only one right
um well
you know I I
don't know
if the the plan here would be that all
of the land use appeals would be would
would be Consolidated the ones all the
land use appeals that go to the Superior
Court would be Consolidated in the land
use docket
um
so one judge would be doing all of those
now whether
there would be a need for more than one
judge I'm I'm frankly not sure and again
Mr head may have more information I
would I would just point point this out
in the in the business you know to the
extent when I was using the business
Court analogy before uh judge McNamara
spent a significant portion of his time
doing business cases but not all of them
he did try some criminal cases and do
some other some other things so you know
I think it I think it probably would
would be uh sort of depend on the ebb
and flow of work there might be
sometimes when the business Court Judge
would have a slack and would be be able
to do some other some other Superior
Court work but I suspect that most of
the time he or she would be doing the
land use cases and in fact it could even
be the case that there would you know
the Superior Court would have to impose
would have to appoint another judge to
that docket uh depending on how many
cases there were well thank you very
much
representative Manos
thank you Mr Vice chair I wanted to know
would would this use existing judicial
resources
now the actually the bill provides that
the governor
um will appoint the first
um the the first uh
um business core I have in business
Court the first land you stock it judge
um under the bill so there would be at
least one new judge that would be
appointed to be the land you stock it
judge and then after that from the
existing Superior Court the the Chief
Justice of the Superior Court could
appoint additional judges if if
necessary but there would be at least
one new judge uh uh for the business the
docket
representative Manos thank you I also
wanted to know how this would affect
other cases in the superior court so for
example if there's a civil case that's
been pending for a long time would would
this docket take precedence over other
existing cases
no I think in other words I think that's
the idea
of having sort of a new judge
um appointed
um would be to so that that you know
that judge would would then be doing the
uh
would be doing the land use uh stuff
um other
the other judges would continue to be to
be doing their regular work now I guess
if the you know if the if the land use
docket became so new it became so full
that there needed to be more judges
assigned
um it would be up to the Chief Justice
of the Superior Court to make that
decision but I I assume that what would
happen if you know if if something like
that happened and there wasn't enough
there just weren't enough judges to do
all the work they would be back
they were the the judicial branch would
be back here asking for more judges
um as for as for example they are as I
understand their their budget request
I'm I'm not in finance anymore but as I
understand their budget request they're
asking for a significant number of
judges for this for the Circuit Court
um which I think they need
um so I mean that that's I think that
would be the way that would be handled
one more follow-up representative Manos
thank you so this
in your view this could potentially free
up or
um
speed up other civil cases yeah no I
think that's I think that that's
probably right because the to the extent
that you have
all of the
land use cases Consolidated before one
judge that means that you know it's
gonna they're gonna be taken off the
docket of of the other judges which
would give them more time to do to do
representative Smith
thank you um
representative Lynn I'm going to save a
number of questions for my good friend
from the judicial branch but um I've
read this bill a couple of times and I
don't see anywhere in this that you have
specified that there would be an
additional position added
to uh a superior court and all I see is
that the governor would name
of presiding judge of the land use court
but I see no reason why or no indication
that he's not going to take that person
well he would have to the government
account May appoint the first presiding
Justice of the land you so I'm sorry so
you're you're thinking that he might be
that the governor might say out I'm
taking from among the
yes that's what I'm thinking and I say
that based on past experience of what
has happened when over the years
additional definitions or
responsibilities have come in and that
does not necessarily get reflected in an
increase in the number of Judges or
justices I always like to use judge for
everybody except the Supremes but I know
I'm not supposed to do that well you
know I have to I have to say I
um I had not I I guess I would say I
would agree with you I suppose if you
read this language that could happen I
had not anticipated that it would happen
and I don't think
but I miss Mr head will correct me if
I'm wrong I don't
my unders my impression was that this
that the judicial branch was also
thinking there would be a new judge
appointed
um for
um and it man you know and and I assume
their budget requests
um would would contemplate that uh with
all due respect the government oh I'm
sorry may I follow up
may I thank you only this one with all
due respect
um my experience has been that the
judicial branch frequently asks for
additional judges specific number and
sometimes they don't get any and
sometimes they get some I'm not aware of
any time they received anything more
than they had requested and um that's
for sure
and so I would think that you know if
wishes were horses we would all ride I
think that there has to be something
staying very specifically uh that the
expectation is that there would be an
additional judge and I I hope you agree
well as I say I had not I had just sort
of assumed that that's what would be
that that's what was intended and that
the judicial branch was going to be
requesting an additional Superior Court
judge for that purpose uh you didn't
serve with a finance long enough that's
your problem but I and that may be right
but uh at any rate I I mean if that
needed to be put in there specifically I
would certainly be willing to file an
amendment to do that
yes and if I might direct you to the
fiscal note it does say that there will
be an additional Justice appointed
and representative Perez
thank you that's what I was going to say
it specifically says that in the fiscal
note thank you
any other questions for representative
Lynn
great thank you very much
um we now call
foreign
okay
chairman Lynn Vice chair Wallace and
Judiciary Committee members for the
record my name is Ben Ming I'm a state
representative from Hollis I thank you
for your time in listening to my support
for HB 347 which seeks to establish the
Superior Court land use docket
I'm a lawyer and my practice over the
last 10 plus years has touched on nearly
all matters relating to real estate
buying and selling residential and
commercial landlord tenant and most
relevant to this bill
litigation and land use and zoning is my
opinion that courts need efficient
systems and HP 347 will push them in the
right direction
in New Hampshire the probate process
gives a taste of this type of efficiency
her rate is the legal process of
determining among other things if a
deceased person's will is valid
probate files are e-filed and
centralized to the state
in contrast the probate process and
other states go goes through individual
County offices
and operates with the use of paper
documents
which begs the question why should this
level of efficiency be extended to the
Superior Court
the short answer is limited resources
one of the many things young lawyers are
told in law school and practices be
cautious with what you tell clients you
know
but don't let lack of experience be a
deterrent for pursuing the knowledge
required to help
I highly highlight this to say that
judges are largely owed the difference
they receive from lawyers and the public
in general
however they are not superhumans the law
is vast
and few if any can have a masterful
grasp of every single Nuance in practice
with limited time
the superior court is a trial court and
having a strong grasp of law is
important but equally important is the
establishment of the facts of the case
again
time is limited to establish facts and
review applicable law
we can't create more time but what we
can do is identify and establish the
fact that land use and Zoning is highly
consequential in New Hampshire
out of 234 municipalities in New
Hampshire only 17 have no zoning code
zoning is opt-in in other words the RSA
that gave gave life to zoning in New
Hampshire
requires formal steps to establish
zoning in any municipality
each Community must agree to it
zoning codes shaped municipalities and
the way each Community sees fit and the
people of New Hampshire have
historically and overwhelmingly said yes
to zoning does local control
because we have that type of local
control
we also have over 200 unique zoning
codes in the state many of them over 100
pages long
it isn't fair to the judge their staff
or either partying in a litigated land
use matter
to bring a hyper local issue to a
courtroom that may require a significant
amount of additional time just to
understand all the specifics that make a
certain zoning code in question unique
this is a step toward a more efficient
court system
and I request that you support the
passage of house bill 347.
there any questions for representative
Ming
none we thank you I will actually add
one comment
um
it talks about the person's knowledge
and experience in land use in Real
Property law and I think rightly land
use is highlighted
um and typically I would put land use
Under the Umbrella of real property law
and when I hear real property law I
think
a practitioner which means
if you take out land use it's
transactional it's contracts
um
and I believe representative Lynn chair
Lynn said that uh a knowledge of
property law in general is what is the
type of Judge that would be appropriate
for this position so I just want to
highlight if there's a way of saying
that land use is is truly the um should
should be the deciding factor
I would also suggest with
chairman Lin's uh blessing that the
Chief Justice also follow
um
in the appointment of additional judges
that they should
they should review
no further questions uh we now call
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch I think I will
make representative Smith happy in that
I will affirmatively say we not only
support this bill we ask that it be
voted out of committee ought to pass
we did include it within the budget for
the judicial branch and it is a
it is an important position it's an
important issue that the state faces uh
and and would provide a significant
benefit I think to the judicial branch
and to the state I will just know a
couple things in terms of
um representative Lynn's testimony he
kept talking about the business Court in
the past tense it is still and continues
to be incredibly successful
um under judge Anderson uh and and
continues with that same success
um
when asked the judges in our Superior
Court described these types of cases as
complex it is an area of the law that is
detailed and involves attorneys who are
experts and and have a great deal of
knowledge it involves experts we have uh
all of these cases involve a very
technical area of Law and fact and we
get Engineers we have Wetland scientists
we have hydrogeologists we have
um just a why surveyors
a wide range of experts who tend to be
involved in these types of cases and
they require a great deal of time to get
up to speed and one of the things the
judges commented on was if we only see
these as part of our regular docket and
mixed in and occasionally
it becomes it is just a a greater lift
to get up to speed again and to get
re-familiarize yourself not only with
the case itself but with the technical
aspects of it and the law which is also
as you heard very complicated long and
and detailed so to be able to
consolidate these types of cases the
complexity of these cases into a single
docket would just have inherent benefits
associated with with doing so
um you have the very aggressive time
frames that are laid out in the statute
we agree that those are appropriate and
and those time frames can be met under
the circumstances of having a specific
Judge assigned to the docket
um
one of the things and I do think in
response to representative Smith's
question there actually does need to be
an amendment
um RSA
perhaps not only just to clarify that
the the initial appointment would be a
new judge as described in the in the
bill but RSA 491 colon 1 currently has a
limit on the number of Superior Court
judges is currently 22 and that would
need to be increased to 23. so 490 RSA
491 colon 1 would need Amendment I'm
happy to to provide uh the chair with a
with a proposed language for that
Amendment but I do think representative
Smith's point is well taken and an
additional Amendment would be necessary
in order for that additional judge to be
able to come into the system
um
the you know in in closing what I would
say is that these files are very large
they're very dense they're very
complicated they're very technical and
to be able to have a judge who is
dedicated to this area
um and to be constantly involved in this
area is a substantial benefit to the
parties to the state and to the into the
judicial branch and to our ability to uh
resolve these cases quickly I mean
whether it be a housing issue or whether
it be a commercial issue time and delay
is money and it costs money and it
causes uh additional issues the goal is
to get these resolved quickly in
response to one of the questions one of
the things we've observed there there
range in terms of the number of cases
it's it's not our highest docket they
tend to be in the 60s to 100 uh it
depends on sort of what is happening in
the market and what is happening in in
terms of development we have not seen
any changes in our numbers that we would
associate with the creation of the
housing uh appellate to have
housing appeals board so that is
actually interestingly enough not
changed our numbers in a way that we've
observed so it may mean that folks who
are looking for that process are filing
an appeal where they weren't before but
the same number of folks appear to still
be filing in the Superior Court
um one other thing I would just well I
guess with that I would uh
in my comments but be happy to answer
representative Smith
thank you very much Mr chairman and
congratulations I am thrilled at the
strengths of which you've endorsed this
bill I also want to congratulate you on
the accuracy of the language in the
fiscal note because it says that your
judicial branch assumes
an additional judge it does not
and it does not say that there will be
an additional judge and I wrote that
fiscal note because of that exact reason
and I thank you for that and I also
congratulate you on the fact that the
chairman of division one is a co-sponsor
of this bill and um division one in
finance and therefore
um understands the importance of that
bill so all that is very good I have I'm
afraid with all those positive things
well well you know first I have to get
permission to ask the next
I have permission could you tell me do
you have a full 23 judges we have 22. I
mean 22. and that includes the the Chief
Justice of the spirit court so she also
has the administrative duties associated
with that and how current and this is
part of something how current is your
value your caseload evaluation for the
court and where does it stand in terms
of the length of time for all those
other cases that don't necessarily deal
with property but might deal with more
human kinds of questions
um so thank you for the question if I
understand one
if I'm not answering the question I
apologize we have very recently this in
last year completed uh what's called a
weighted case study
um and that weighted case study did a a
very detailed evaluation of all of the
cases both Superior Court and circuit
court and evaluated the time needed per
case
um and and the number of resources we
currently have available
and as as representative Lynn suggested
in our budget our budget recognizes what
that weighted case study found which is
in the Circuit Court we are
substantially down in terms of judges
and staff in the Superior Court which is
what we're talking about today the
number of Judges that we are deficient
is about three and a half
our budget only asks for one in in it
would be tied to this bill which would
wouldn't have to be tied to this bill if
this bill were not to pass but the goal
would be that the new judge would take
on this land use docket that does have a
ripple effect through the system of of
not having the other judges handling
these types of cases which tend to be
time consuming and and detailed so so at
least the other judges would not be
doing this docket
um but it so but overall
um the the way the case study showed
that we were deficient in terms of the
number of Judges number of Staff in both
and by about three and a half in the in
the spirit Court just an elaboration on
that one so you're short three and a
half judges you've decided that you
would like to get one judge leaving you
still two and a half short and that one
judge would focus on these cases could
you give the committee particularly the
new members of the committee some idea
of the cases that therefore will not be
handled in the timely way that you would
like them to be handled
uh I apologize I may have that would not
be handled in a timely way yes because
your short two and a half judges I'm
sorry I I get what you're saying um so
we would have an overall Improvement in
the system I think the and the Chief
Justice would speak to this in in his
comments when he's presenting the budget
so I don't want to speak for him so
um how he balance that out to be one
judge instead of three and a half versus
you know the same analysis that he had
to do with the circuit court and come up
with a number I would leave that to the
Chief Justice in his presentation on the
budget as to how he made that balance
and I don't I don't want to speak for
him perfectly legitimate response thank
you thank you representative Horrigan
um thank you very much Mr chair thank
you much attorney head um so the
effective day for this bill is January
1st 2024
um
it'll take a while to uh recruit the
candidates and convince the governor to
appoint one of them and to get them past
the executive Council and all the other
steps so like
well that process be able to begin in
the second half of
calendar year 2023 after we passed this
bill or does that have to wait until
January 1st 2024 before you can get that
whole process rolling which could take
months
so thank you for the question I I think
the
um the docket would not be created until
the judge came on board and was
appointed and had begun the position and
that that new judge would initiate the
docket whether that occurs before or
after January 1
you know whatever that date is uh that's
when we would initiate the creation of
if I understood you can start trying to
get the individual in place uh as soon
as this bill passes or as I suspect
might happen it ends up inspired the
budget and it would begin as soon as the
budget was was passed and and uh in the
nomination process then would take over
that's correct it wouldn't be there
wouldn't be in the budget the same delay
of January 1 before the judge could be
nominated and appointed
representative qatab
thank you for taking my question
I see an RSA 491-1 that it currently
remarks 21 associate judges you had just
mentioned that
um we currently have 22 and would Dean
23 I just want to make sure that I'm
hearing that correctly was there one
that came from somewhere else I may have
in and either my memory is off or or it
may say 20 21 associate and one Chief uh
or it does say a chief in 2010 that's
where I'm getting the 22 so I'm adding
uh judge Netto in my 22 so I may have
the language would would say achieve and
then probably 20 22. okay perfect thank
you
foreign
ahead
in a day's time of the land of this
would
cases you mean in terms of trial time
yeah I don't know the answer to that I
do know the vast majority of these
results have evidentiary hearings as
opposed to just simply on paper and
argument
evidentiary hearings uh take longer but
it and so I don't know whether or not
they tend to extend beyond one day or
they're typically done within one day I
don't know the answer to that I
so by having an extra Superior Court
Judge it will help to free up the the
time that other cases would be heard to
have just to have him just focus in on
this
so so I think the the
new judge would hear all of the land use
appeals um so all of them would would
get Consolidated there that naturally
has the effect of taking that off
somebody else's docket who that where it
would normally be assigned and uh every
judge in the superior court system has a
just a very large caseload so they would
have whatever time would have been
allocated to a land use docket case
would now be allocated to a civil case a
criminal case some other case that
exists on their docket can I ask one
other question how many how many judges
do you have working in one day
all of them so yes everybody is working
throughout the system at all times one
thing I would just point out it the
judge's time is not simply trial time
there there are hearings pleadings uh a
great deal of one of the aspects of what
makes these very complex is a very uh a
significant record comes as
representative Lynn said you get the
record from below those can be
especially in a very complicated
commercial case very thick and it is the
duty of the judge to become very
familiar with the facts and and details
of those of those cases so it is not
just the time the judge spends in the
court that is cons that consumes their
time in these types of cases thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Vice
chairman uh thank you members of the
committee for the record my name is Greg
Moore I'm the state director with
Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire and I realize that I'm
probably the last witness in the last
bill when all of you are trying to get
home and beat the storm so oh it's so
good so there are other people okay so I
can blame them uh for the record uh
again Greg Morris state director of
America Prosperity here to testify and
support of House Bill 347. uh we view
this as a critical critical step for
promoting economic growth in New
Hampshire having the chance to go and
talk to a number of Business Leaders
business owners Community leaders one of
the biggest problems that's facing the
state of New Hampshire right now is just
the issue of development issue of
development at large now obviously the
housing component against a Lion's Share
of the headlines but there is a real
problem in terms of development in the
commercial industrial space as well and
I know this legislature has taken action
on on the on the issue of housing
starting with the passage of the housing
appeals board in 2019 as well as the The
house's creation of a special committee
on housing which indicates the level of
seriousness and focus which which the
legislature has placed on this issue but
I would suggest to you that building
more housing without supporting that
with commercial and industrial property
as well is going to be a problem long
term so having the ability to to have a
quick access to to judgment for these
people in commercial industrial as well
as those folks who are seeking the
housing route and want to go down go
down to actually sit in front of a judge
as a have the day in front of a judge as
opposed to a housing appeals board I
think this creates a great opportunity
relative to the dynamic but with the
housing appeals board I want to point
out that I had a chance to talk to the
the leadership of both the New Hampshire
uh New Hampshire homeowner Home Builders
Association as well as the associated
builders and contractors and they are
fully in support of this legislation
they suggested that they signed in I
haven't checked so I apologize for not
doing my homework but the home builders
and the associated builders and
contractors are in support of this
legislation
the problem with the current system is
in terms of land use and this is an I
had an opportunity to talk with the
Chief Justice and he says the problem is
that in land use cases they go right to
the bottom of the docket
be coupling that with the fact that they
are very complicated very dense cases as
we've heard before
leads to very long delays to getting
results
I've heard that that uh from several
people that if you want to bring a case
on in Superior Court you're lucky to get
into trial in a year and a half
and you probably won't get a full result
for about three years
now the problem if you're a developer is
is that if you have to wait three years
between the time when there's been a
potential uh a potential violation of of
the statutes bio zoning and planning
board and they get Justice your your
financing can't hold together for three
years correct so it has the it is
essentially a sort of a veto power over
uh over your ability to build this
speeds up the process which could
potentially be as fast as five months if
it is if there's not too much of a
record sent uh into to to Superior Court
moreover by having one judge having one
judge handling all the cases you'll get
a a level of consistency of rulings
across the board so if there's one judge
right now there are potentially 22
judges
who might have 22 particular versions of
how they view how they view the statute
by having it all run through one judge
you're going to get a level of
consistency and that level of
consistency is going to actually be a
great benefit to the zoning and planning
boards across the state because everyone
will know and understand what the rules
are
as as I know this this committee has
debated in years past I know
representative Alexander who's not here
filed legislation two years ago to have
mandatory training for zoning and
planning boards uh that legislation did
not pass but there's a sense of
unevenness and that unevenness can lead
to results that might fall outside of
the statutory authority of the zoning
and planning boards and if that happens
and the recourse is to go get to wait
three years before you get a result on
that on that potential violation that's
from our perspective that's not really
what we would describe as Justice
because because if you're financing
can't hold together for that period of
time you're not likely to be able to
move forward
uh I would also just uh just like to say
that uh I'll give you an example of of
what I'm talking about because I think
it's great to talk about this in a
theoretical but just in terms of of what
what how this works in the practical
sense and I'll use my hometown because
if you're going to pick on somebody's
telling you should pick on your own uh I
live a town of Bedford a local Brewery
was looking to do an expansion in the
town of Bedford they were looking to do
it in their performance Zone which is
the area designated by the town to be
the area for development and uh to in
order to enhance the town's overall tax
base
they went before the they went before
the the planning board the planning
board said that they were going to have
to require them
to to uh put uh two feet of a fill in
the back part of the property by the way
that's the part of the property that
that uh would not be where they would
actually be putting a building
and it would add up to a cost of two
million dollars before they could even
break the ground to build a foundation
so adding two million dollars to the
cost of the project
uh at this point and I should add that
that the attorney for the for the
brewery said that there's no statutory
support for for requiring that now
instead of instead of building it what
happened is is that the brewery just
decided to scrap the plans as opposed to
trying to take go to court and and uh
have that ruling overturned
that's results obviously in in a
situation where somebody was out over a
hundred thousand dollars in design and
legal fees for to bring this to the
board and that whole plan was scrapped
and they lost all that money uh despite
the fact that at least in the the
opinion of the attorney for the for the
uh the brewery that the the request of
this planning board was not somebody was
supported under statute they exceeded
their statutory Authority so that I just
want to put a real world sort of example
as to what that looks like and and
that's a project that didn't get done
simply simply because of the ruling by
that board so uh with that and again I
know I want to be quick here because you
all want to get out of here uh happy to
take any questions
representative Smith
naturally
um Mr Moore it's good to see you and I
think we all agree that Justice delayed
is Justice denied
um assuming that this bill passes and
there's every reason to believe it will
and it comes into law
can you give us guidance as to what
civil and criminal cases
you think could now
um in effect go to the
the bottom of of the the list of KF
pending cases and
making clear that we will benefit from
the The increased uh speed in the cases
that go here to the land use review
understanding that the other cases
with a long backlog and a shortage of
Two and a Half judges what areas do you
think it's justifiable to now have those
cases take more time
thank you for the question
representative uh did I really mean that
do you I do I do
uh
I've had a lot of chance to answer
questions for Youth of the years as you
know
I work for a state agency once and uh
it's always fun when they tell you to to
paint the bar and only give you one
gallon of paint I I but but
to the to the question at hand
if this is adding a judge and you're
taking
work off the plate of the existing
Superior Court judges then I think it's
going to benefit the speed with which
those other cases are able to move
through the courts I I I think that
that's helpful
there's a secondary question I think
embedded in there of whether adding one
more Supreme Court Justice is the right
answer
um the folks down the hall the ones who
have to Grapple with that and uh but but
to your point I don't think that the
other the other dockets will be slowed
down I don't think the other cases will
be in fact I think they'll be sped up
because all these land use cases will be
taken off of the other 22
spherical justices but I I do agree with
your point about and to attorney head's
point about making sure you change that
other statute to make abundantly clear
the intent of this committee to add
representative guitar
thank you for taking my question Mr
Moore I apologize I I misunderstood a
little bit what was the two million
dollar thing that Bedford wanted the
brewery to put in so this is this was on
River Road which is part of the
performance Zone in Bedford and it's a
piece of property that abuts against the
Everett Turnpike and there's a front
developer developable part that a butts
that sits on River Road horses which is
uh route 3. and behind it is sort of a
gully that goes underneath to ever ever
turnpike now the property extends all
the way to the turnpike
and so they they demanded that they had
that if they wanted to go forward the
project that they had to fill all that
and now none
fill it entirely
and and uh none of that area was the
area that that the brewery was looking
at using they were looking at using the
footprint closer to towards the highway
any other questions
CNN we thank you thank you and we now
call Missa margonkin did I get that
right
hi good afternoon Mr Vice chairman Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Alyssa margolin I serve as
director of housing action New Hampshire
we're a Statewide affordable housing
Coalition
um thank you for hearing my testimony
our broad Coalition does not have a
formal position on this proposal House
Bill 347 but we would respectfully ask
this committee to consider amending the
bill to make clear that this proposal
would not in any way supplant the
housing appeals board
um in this letter that is uh coming
around to you I've provided some draft
language for your consideration
as you know in his um uh chairman Lynn
pointed out in his testimony many
parties seeking review of Municipal
decisions whether that be at the Bureau
of tax and land appeals that's been in
that's all right or the housing appeals
board since 2020 are benefiting now from
timely Fair inexpensive and accessible
access
the benefiting parties in the case of
housing are not only a Butters but
they're taxpayers property owners and
developers we're starting to hear that
municipalities are seeing the benefit
benefit of Speedy review as well
so um we feel like there's been a lot of
progress a lot of needed education in
terms of what the housing appeals board
does and what it does not it certainly
has a busy docket we don't doubt that
the superior court has one as well
and so would ask that you consider
amending this to to make that clear and
to to protect the work of the housing
appeals board thank you and I'm happy to
any questions
seeing none thank you
and we now call Chris Norwood
and with that anybody else which wish to
speak on House Bill 347 FN
you know just um
just so just this is really just for the
committee
um as you as you probably have seen
we've scheduled hearings for two days uh
next week uh Wednesday and Thursday I'm
I'm the speaker had suggested that
possibly next Thursday we could have a
full house session if we do obviously
we're going to have to cancel the
hearings for Thursday but I it seemed
like it was unlikely that it was going
to happen so I'm that's why I scheduled
for two days so we'll have hearings next
Wednesday and Thursday and then my my my
plan my inclination and I'm uh you know
I'm I'm gonna talk further with
representative Smith about this but my
inclination is uh that the following
week
um
we will have an executive session
at least on Wednesday of that week which
would be February 1st
the
right now the it seems
pretty likely as of the day before
yesterday that there would be a full
house session on February 2nd but based
on your comment it may be that there's
not enough bills to make that worth
ready that are ready for action that
would make that worthwhile so if we
oh all right so that takes care of that
so so so we'll have an executive session
on February 1st
um
uh and
I guess I want to think about this a
little bit but I'm thinking that maybe
we will also have an executive session
on February 3rd
um but I I need to think about that and
I also need to make sure we have a place
to have it
um so any you can count on February 1st
and and
um
you know possibly February 3rd but I I
need to uh get a little more information
as to whether we have a place to have it
and I also want to speak with
representative Smith about that all
right
um
about the third yeah
um I'll try I'll try to um
I'll try to have an answer to you uh
about that uh certainly by Monday my
next my next next Monday this coming
this coming Monday
um
yes representative Horgan
this doesn't affect our committee
directly but I did get a text which at
least probably representative Kenny also
got to the UNH law school which is
located just a couple blocks away is
curtailing operations tomorrow do you
have any indication if the State House
is gonna have full schedule uh meetings
tomorrow you know I haven't made the gel
cars meeting tomorrow and I got I did
get
I got an email
sometime I I started first thing this
morning saying you know are you still
planning to come to gel car I said yeah
as far as I know but you know
it's only it's only this is New
Hampshire and it snows that's yeah it's
and the snow is long overdue too so like
yeah we
all right well thank you everyone I
uh we'll see you whoops excuse me we'll
yeah
you know what those I you'll see that
many of the bills for next week are